thank you
hey everyone welcome back to another
video session by simply learn in this
session on C plus plus full course for
beginners we will be learning different
concepts and topics of C plus
this video tutorial will help you in
learning and understanding the C plus
programming language in both theoretical
and practical way by doing some Hands-On
examples
but before we begin make sure to
subscribe to our Channel and press the
Bell icon to never miss an update
so we'll start with the introduction to
C plus plus programming language and how
to download and install C plus plus in
Windows then we will start with the
force programming C plus plus along with
the terms like variables types then the
concepts like if else statements Loops
functions in C plus plus call by value
call by reference and friend function
then we will cover topics like arrays
pointers in C plus plus this pointer
references and memory management we will
also learn about sorting in C plus plus
after that we will move on to object
oriented programming topics like classes
in C plus plus oops Concepts Etc and
after that we will move on to topics
like vectors in C plus plus STL that is
standard template library and in the end
we'll also learn to make some projects
in C plus
so without further Ado let's get started
so let's start with the introduction to
C plus plus programming
C plus plus is a popular programming
language introduced by John strowstrup
in the year 1979. the aim was to make a
dynamic language that is efficient and
has some additional features to see
initially it was called C with classes
as it was an extension to C language but
later renamed as C plus plus
it is general purpose case sensitive
language and it is called pre-compiled
language because it converts the source
code directly to the machine
understandable code
it is an intermediate level language
because it contains both features of
high level and low level language
C plus plus supports the features of
object oriented language like
encapsulation inheritance polymorphism
Etc it also supports procedural
programming and functional programming
as well
and in today's video we will be
discussing top 10 reasons to learn C
plus plus in 2022
C plus plus is an object-oriented
language which is used in many Superior
organizations to create some complex
applications
and C plus plus is quite all language so
there are some doubts regarding the C
plus plus language like whether this
language is still in demand or not
and if it is then what are the reasons
to learn C plus plus programming
language
C plus plus is no doubt bit old language
but it is still in the dominance in the
world of programming in many sectors
in this video we will be discussing the
top 10 reasons to learn C plus plus
programming in 2022
but before we begin make sure to
subscribe to our Channel and hit the
Bell icon to never miss an update from
Simply learn
so we will start with the 10th reason
which is career opportunities
with the availability of easy to learn
languages like JavaScript python Etc
people often ignore languages like C
plus
C plus plus is considered a foundation
language of many programming languages
and is one of the most essential
languages that you must know if you are
interested in computer science
as per the tiobe index of 2022
C plus plus lies in the fourth position
in terms of world's most popular
language
the career or job opportunities for C
plus plus programmers is enormous
because C plus plus is an old language
and a lot of code is already written in
this language
C plus plus is very useful for making
complex softwares Android applications
and Games Etc
so it holds a strong position when it
comes to job opportunities
now let's move on to the next reason to
learn C plus plus programming language
which is
C plus plus is efficient and fast
language
C plus plus is a fast language it's
compile time and execution time is
faster than other programming languages
some programming languages are also
faster than Z Plus but like C plus plus
they are not close to the machine code
as it is an intermediary language so big
organizations rely or depend on C plus
plus for fast speed with lesser
resources
so our eighth reason to learn C plus
plus language is
suitable for big projects yes C plus
plus is well suited for big projects
many applications and softwares that we
use or go through in our daily lives are
developed in C plus
for example Spotify a popular music
streaming application
its backend code is written in C plus
plus
we all know YouTube
C plus plus is used in building YouTube
video processing function
the Amazon application
that we use often
was also written in C plus plus
however there are changes over the years
and many more softwares like these are
developed using C plus plus
some of the main reasons for choosing C
plus plus for big projects is that it is
fast and efficient language also it
gives a lot of control when it comes to
memory management
and its Library support helps in making
complex functionalities
now let's move on to our next reason
which is
Community Support of C plus
as we have discussed C plus plus is an
old language and is being studied and
learned by most of the programmers
around the globe
so it has a huge Community Support
in case someone needs any help or
guidance regarding C plus plus a lot of
programmers and experts are out there on
different platforms creating resources
like blogs for example C plus plus tips
of the week
podcasts like CPP cast and the
organizations like the C plus plus
Alliance and many more are out there
that can guide you through your problem
all of these resources are open source
and some of them are paid which can help
a learner or programmer to understand
this language and clear the doubts
regarding it
now our next reason is C plus plus is
required everywhere
C plus plus programming language is
almost everywhere around the world
for example it is used for making
browsers applications and software
also C plus plus is used majorly to make
operating systems and almost all of the
plating systems are built with C plus
for example Mac operating system Windows
operating system Linux Etc
similarly the browsers like Safari Opera
Chrome Firefox Etc are written in C plus
plus because it is fast and efficient
language that is why it is more
preferable
many games are written in C plus plus
and some Advanced gaming systems are
also developed using C plus plus
language
so it is being widely used and learning
a language like this opens up the doors
for your career to many different
sectors of organizations
so next our fifth reason to learn C plus
plus is
it helps you in learning other
programming languages
C plus plus is an intermediate level
language
learning this language will give you
much deeper understanding of programming
structure because in C plus plus you
have to write declare and explain
everything in the source code
which gives you deeper knowledge of all
the parts of the program
languages like python are much easier to
understand because it is almost syntax
free language and you don't have to
specify everything while writing its
code
which makes the programming part easy
but you don't get the opportunity to
learn the logic structure of the program
like C plus plus
once you learned the C plus plus
language then other languages will be
easy for you to learn or grasp
as your foundation becomes strong
now our next reason to learn C plus plus
is embedded systems
an embedded system is a microprocessor
based software and Hardware system
that is used to design a specific
function
C plus plus is widely used in embedded
system because it is intermediary
language which means that it has both
the features of high level language and
low level language
which gives C plus plus an edge over
other languages because it directly can
access the hardware part without
sacrificing the high level part
many embedded systems like smart watches
GPS systems MP3 players Etc are created
using C plus plus
to choose a language for embedded system
C plus plus is the one
because it is Hardware level language
moving on to the next reason which is
versatility
C plus plus is around 40 years old
language and still is one of the most
popular language why is it so
it is because of its versatile nature
C plus plus is a highly adaptable
language and because of that it is still
useful when it comes to software and
developing games
it is widely used for so long that it is
compatible with many languages and is in
demand in many sectors
also the top tire companies seek
employees with a fine understanding of C
plus plus programming which is a very
good reason to learn C plus programming
so next our top second reason which is
C plus plus language for simulations
apart from python C plus plus is also
used for simulations
many simulators are created with the
help of C plus plus libraries it is
considered as an alternative to the
Python language
the object-oriented approach provides
faster execution full accessibility to
the base language
portable models and executables
and a variety of complementary
development tools
the simulation built with tools has the
benefits of an object oriented design
including the involvement of
encapsulation polymorphism inheritance
and parameterized typing
now let's move on to the top reason to
learn C plus programming in 2022
that is
C plus plus has high salary packages
C plus plus is in demand in reputed
organizations like Facebook Google Etc
these organizations also pay some
handsome salary to the C plus plus
Developers for working on their products
usually different organizations pay
differently to the entry level C plus
developers and the experienced ones but
the average salary of a C plus plus
developer in India is 7 lakh 78 290.
and the average salary of a C plus plus
developer in USA is
118
305 dollars
the entry level C plus developer salary
is bit average in the early one to three
years because of less experience and
mastering C plus plus language usually
takes some time
but the salary package grows after four
years of experience at a fast pace which
is a good reason to learn C plus plus
programming language
how you can install C plus plus on vs
code and Dev C plus plus after we are
done with the installation we'll also
learn how to run a program on both of
these code editors so we'll start with
Visual Studio code
to download vs code let's go to Google
and search for visual studio code
or vs code
we'll click on this first link
this is the official web page for
downloading the visual studio code
and we'll now click on this download for
Windows Blue Button
and now we'll click on download now
here it is getting download and
as you can see
thanks for downloading Visual Studio
code for Windows
once we are done with the download we
can click on this open folder
here it is
now we need to install this file so
we'll double click on this file
and this is the setup wizard
we'll click on this I accept the
agreement
and we'll click on next
as we have accepted the license
agreement now we can select our
destination folder or we can leave it as
it is but make sure there must be 293.2
MB of free space on that particular disk
space
now
we'll click on next
here we can again click on X there is no
need to change over here
and now
you can click on this create a desktop
icon button or anyone else has for your
choice
now we'll click on next
and now we'll click finally on install
it is getting installed it will take
some time
now we can click on this finish button
launch Visual Studio we have marked it
it is already marked so when we click on
this finish button it will launch the
visual studio code
so as we can see this is the visual
studio code
so as we have installed vs code now we
have to configure it so that the C plus
plus programs can run in this code
editor
so in order to do that we need to add
some extensions so we'll click on this
extensions button
now here we will write code Runner
extension write code Runner
and this is extension
when click on this install
and it is getting installed
here are some instructions we can click
on control plus all plus n or press F1
and then select type run code but we'll
deal with that later
now
we'll add another extension that is C
slash C plus plus
here it is
we'll click on this install
here we can see downloading Visual
Studio Windows debugger
it is getting installed and I think it
is installed now
so as we have added both the extensions
so let's move on and do a program of C
plus plus in this code editor
we can Define strings as a collection or
group of characters it is basically used
to represent text in the program and we
can perform many operations on strings
in order to manipulate it
the syntax of string contains a
collection of characters surrounded by
double quotes for example here string is
the type Str is the name of the string
and coffee is the value that is assigned
to the string
in C plus plus there are two ways to
create a string
first is C style strings in C style
strings collection of characters are
stored in the form of arrays they are
basically arrays of type character
the second way is using string objects
we can create string object to hold a
string
they are implemented in the standard
Library which we must include in the
program using hash include
so here we will do an example of string
and we'll do some push back and pullback
operation on it so first of all we'll
include the header file
hash include iostream
then using namespace standard
namespace standard okay now we'll start
with int Main
all right first of all we'll write
string
data type then the name of the string s
here s is the name of the string all
right now first of all we will display a
message
to enter a string
so
okay enter a string
now
get line
this is the syntax when you want to take
the input
of a string so get line C in is used to
take the input and S is the name of the
string
so this is how we take the input
and now we will print another message
saying that
you have entered
now here we will print the string s
next line and
okay
now
we'll do some operations like s dot
pushback
this will add an element at the end of
the string
so
let's say we want to add y
yes
so we'll write y inside the bracket
s dot pushback and inside the bracket
with single quotes we'll write y
now
will display a message saying
after
using
pushback function
will print the string
that is after using the function
pushback the string would look like this
and
now
we'll use another function s dot pop
back
it will delete the element from the end
so we'll write C out
and we'll display the message
after using popback function
foreign
and we'll print the
string
okay now after that we'll write return
0.
and I think it's done only the spelling
is wrong over here
okay
yeah now let's try to run this
as you can see the message enter a
string so let's say I have entered
Barcelona
so you have entered Barcelona after
using pushback Barcelona why because we
have used y over here we want to add y
at the end of the string so after using
pushback Barcelona Y and pop back
function after that we have used and we
know that it will delete the element
from the end so
here we can see there is no y power bank
function have deleted the element
so this is our output
next is if file statements
if else are two conditional statements
that are generally used when we want to
run the code based on some conditions
we run a block of code which is inside
if statement only if the condition is
true for example
if the number variable here is equal to
10 then only the block of code will
execute and will print the message you
got it
otherwise it will run the else block and
display the message written inside that
block which is not this one so first of
all we'll create a new file we'll go to
file and click on this new file
now in order to save this one we can
click on control s or we can go over
here and click on this save as
now we can select the location
like
let's keep it over here only
let's name it as
visual dot CPP dot CPP is extension
which is used when we want to do a
program in C plus plus
now we'll click on this save button
now let's do a simple program to check
whether the program is running on this
code editor or not
so we'll include the header files
include IO stream
now we'll write namespace standard
now we'll write int Main
now inside end main will display a
message
welcome to this video
okay now return zero
make sure to
save this after making changes or you
can click on Ctrl s or you can go to
file
and click on this save
so once you have saved the program now
you can run it
we can click on this play button it will
run the code
as we can see in the output
welcome to this video we can see
here it is
so it means our program is working it is
running fine now let's do another
example in which we will take the inputs
from the user
so let's make a new file
we'll go to file and click on this new
file
now we'll save as
and we'll write visual
2 dot CPP
all right in this program we'll take the
input from the user
so start with
header files hash include iostree
our spelling is wrong
hash include i o stream after that using
namespace standard
now inside int Main
will take the inputs from the user
will display the message
enter the
first number
Now using C in
we'll take the input
we forgot to mention this declare this
N1 variable so write int N1
int and 2.
and int
sum equals 0.
all right here we have taken the input
of N1 the first number now we'll take
the input of another number by
displaying the message
enter the second number
we'll write N2
now we'll
add both of these
and one plus
N2
and will display the result
we'll write end line
so that it looks good
all right now we need to save it
we'll go to file and click on this save
now it is saved now we can run this
program
I will click on this run code
now in order to write the first number
over here that is in order to write in
the terminal we have to configure the
visual studio code and to do that
will go to file
and will now go to preference and in the
settings we'll click on the settings
and here we will type run in terminal
all right now we can scroll down
and here we can see code Runner running
terminal in my vs Studio it is already
marked but you have to mark this if you
want to write in terminal or enter the
inputs in the terminal
all right once you have marked this you
can
close it and then you can control s that
is save and then you can close the vs
studio and then open it again
once you are done
now
let's try to run this
so now you will be able to write the
inputs
like let's say 4
the first number is 4
now the second number let's say
nine
on addition it becomes 13 which is the
right answer
so these were some configurations that
you need to do if you want to run a
program of C plus plus in Visual Studio
code
so as we have understood how to download
and configure Visual Studio code for C
plus plus programs so let's move on to
learn how we can download Dev C plus
plus and run C plus plus programs in
that
so let's go to Google
and type Dev C plus plus
this is the first link
we'll click on that now this is the
green button saying download will click
on that to download Dev C plus plus
as we can see it is getting downloaded
your download will start shortly
so now we'll click on download now
it is getting downloaded
it will take a while the size of this
file is 48.1 MB
so as you can see the downloading is
almost done
so the downloading is complete now we'll
click on open folder
here it is Dev C plus plus setup now
we'll click on this setup
just click on yes
the setup is loading
so now here we will select the preferred
language it is English we'll click on OK
now we'll click on this is the license
agreement we'll click on I agree
now
we'll click on next we don't need to
change this I think the space required
is 346.8 MB
and we'll click on next
now if you want to change the
destination folder you can but I don't
want to change it so I'll click on
install
now it is getting installed
it will take a while
it's done and now we'll click on finish
and it is marked so when we click on
finish it will launch the dev C plus
plus
so here we have to select the language
it is English so we'll click on next
here again we'll click on next and now
we'll click on OK
so this is our code editor that is Dev C
plus plus
so let's write a code
first of all let's create a file
we'll go to file and go to new and we
click on source file
all right now we need to save this one
and in order to save this we'll click on
file then we'll go to save as
and now we'll select the destination
and name it as
dev.cpp
all right now let's start
with the header file
hash include I have stream
we'll do a simple program over here
using namespace
STD
because we want to check that whether
the program is running in this editor or
not
namespace STD
now we'll write into Main
inside int main will display a message
welcome
to
Dev C plus plus
all right after that we'll write return
0.
now let's try to run this
and in order to run this program we'll
go to execute
and now we'll click on compile and run
here this is the pop-up welcome to Dev C
plus plus as we can see this is the
output now press any key to continue it
will close this window
so our output is correct welcome to Dev
C plus plus so this is how you can run a
program in Dev C plus plus
and
our program was also working fine in the
visual studio code
so this is how you can download both of
these code editors to run the C plus
programs today we'll be discussing about
loops in C plus plus so let's begin and
see what's in it for you
so we are going to be learning today
about while Loops what is a loop then
different types of Loops like for Loop
while loop do while loop then there is
nested Loop
after that there are control flow
statements like break and continue
but before we begin if you're new here
and haven't subscribed already make sure
to hit the Subscribe button and the bell
icon for interesting Tech videos
so let's start with the first topic that
is while loops
in order to perform a particular task or
operation many number of times we need
loops these are used when we want to
execute a block of statement repeatedly
rather than just writing those
statements again and again
for example imagine you want to display
your name on the screen 50 times now to
do that there are two methods method one
is writing your name 50 times by doing
the hard code
and Method two is writing your name once
with the loop condition and your name
will be automatically displayed 50 times
now it is pretty obvious that you would
prefer the second approach because you
don't have to put effort in writing your
name 50 times plus it is easy to write
code in few lines
so method 2 is the functionality of loop
it reduces time in writing the code plus
it increases the simplicity
now let's understand what is a loop
Loops in computer programming is a
series of tasks that are used to run
some particular code repeatedly until a
specific condition is met
Loops tells the computer when to start
the condition and when to stop it
now this is a basic flow of a loop after
the initialization the condition is
checked if it's true then the blog of
statement will get executed as long as
the condition is true and if the
condition is false the loop will
terminate
depending on the program different types
of Loops are used in different times
so let's first see different types of
loops
first is for Loop then while loop then
there is do while loop after that there
is nested Loop these are four types of
Loops in C plus plus so let's discuss
these loops
first is for Loop it is a repetition
control structure that is used to
iterate a piece of code based on the
condition is true or false if the
condition is true the statement inside
the loop body is executed and once if it
transforms the execution of statement
will get terminated and after every
execution of for Loop the incremental
decrement paths will update the loop
counter
now let's move on to the while loop
in this Loop the condition is evaluated
first if it's true then the set of
instructions inside the loop body will
execute then this will happen repeatedly
until the condition becomes false and
when it becomes false the loop will end
now the main difference is we use for
Loops when we know the number of times
the body of the loop needs to run
whereas we use while Loops when we don't
know the accrual number of times the
body of loop needs to run
now moving to the next Loop that is do
by Loop
this Loop is quite similar to the while
loop in this the loop will execute the
set of instructions once before checking
if the condition is true after that it
will repeat the loop as long as the
condition is true
that means in do while blue body will
execute at least once irrespective of
the test condition
now coming to the nested Loop
when one Loop is defined inside the body
of another loop then it is known as
nested Loop in C plus plus there are at
least 256 levels of nesting and the flow
of execution for nested Lopez First it
includes initialization of variable
followed by condition 1 if it gets
satisfied then it will search for the
second condition if that also gets
satisfied then it will get increment and
when the condition gets satisfied it
will search for the new set of
statements and follows the same flow of
execution
in C plus plus break statements are used
to terminate the execution of the loop
and by terminating the execution of loop
we means finishing or stopping the
execution like if we want to block or
terminate a loop at some point all we
need to do is to use the break statement
with a condition on which we want the
loop to stop and it will terminate the
Loop's flow or iterations so break
statements are mainly used for two cases
one is it can be used inside the loop
and second is it is mostly used in
switch statements and this is the loops
flow diagram in which first there is a
loop body then if the condition is true
then there is a break statement which
will terminate the loop and if the
condition is not true then the loop will
continue to iterate
as you can see in this example the loop
is iterating from 0 to 10 inside the
loop there is a condition and then the
break statement which will make sure
that the loop will terminate when I
becomes equal to 4. after the break
statement the control will jump out of
the loop body and that's how the break
statement Works its output would be 0 1
2 3. it will not exceed 4 because of the
break statement now coming to continue
statement the continue statement is a
bit similar to the break statement as it
is also used for termination but the
difference is that it is used to
terminate the current iteration and not
the complete Loop for example if a loop
is iterating from 0 to 6 and inside the
loop there is a continue statement on 4.
then all the elements will be printed
except for because continue statement
skips that particular iteration and
continues with the next one
and in break statement the complete Loop
flow terminates
so when the continue statement is used
then within the loop the control skips
or terminates that particular iteration
and continues with the next iteration
as you can see in this example first
Loop body
then there is a condition if that is
true then the continue statement will
terminate and continues it with the next
iteration and if that is false then
control will go to the remaining part of
the as always
now in this example we are using
continue statement here the loop is
iterating from 0 to 10
inside the loop there is a condition and
then the continue statement which will
make sure that if the value of I becomes
4 then terminate that iteration and
moves to the next iteration
after that elements are getting printed
with the help of C out function
now its output would be 1 2 3 5 6 7 8 9.
it will not display 4 because of
continuous statements as we know that
the continuous statement skip that
particular iteration so when we use I
equals 2 equals to 4 then it skips that
particular iteration
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
all right so as we have covered the
theoretical part so now let's do some
examples on break and continue
statements in our code editor that is vs
code
now we'll make a new file
and we'll name that file as
Loops dot CPP
okay
oops1.cpp
foreign
in which we have to print the digits
from 0 to 10 using 4 loops it will be a
basic program just to understand it
write the header file
hash upload I'll stream
now I will write using namespace
standard
now here is the ink name
now we will write the for loop with a 4
keyword
inside the for Loop
will initialize I with 0
now we'll put a condition I less than
equal to 10.
which means
the loop will keep on executing until I
is less than 10.
now
we'll put increment I plus plus
now inside the loop brackets all we have
to do is to print I
so that all the digits get printed
so now let me tell you here what we are
doing is
we are just making the loop to run from
0 to 10. as we can see that I have made
i 0
to I less than equal to 10 that means
Loop will move from i 0 to 10.
now let's try to run it
here we can see
all the digits zero one two three four
five six seven eight nine ten
here is our answer and
let me tell you one thing more to put
return zero
after the loop it's a good practice
now I'll again run it
the output will be the same but it's a
good practice to write return 0 in the
end
zero one two three four five six seven
eight nine ten so instead of writing the
hard code we can just use the for Loop
in this case
it's an basic example of for Loop but
you can try some more examples in order
to understand it better
now let's do one example of while loop
to understand it better
we'll be doing a basic example of while
loop in which all we have to do is to
print happy New Year 11 times
let's start first of all let's name this
file
loops2.cpp
now let's start with the header file
that is Hash include iostream
now we'll write using namespace standard
now is the main
now first of all we'll declare n equals
0 we'll take a variable n and initialize
it with 0.
now we'll put the while condition with
the while keyword writing while
n
not equal to 11.
here what it means is
the loop will keep on executing until n
becomes equal to 11.
now here all we have to do is to print
happy New Year so that it will get
printed along with the Loop 11 times
now we'll write n Plus
we have written n plus plus so that the
loop will keep on incrementing every
single time
after that now we'll write return 0
outside the loop
now we'll try to run this
so here's our output happy New Year 11
times so this is how it's done
this is again a basic example of while
loop but to understand it better one
must practice some more examples on it
now let's do one example of do while
loop also
foreign
first of all let's name that file
loops3.cpp
I think the name is already taken
then we'll write loots4.cpp
okay now so we'll write the header file
first of all
we'll write hash include live stream
after that using namespace standard
now in this program all we have to do is
we have to print the sum of all the
digits from 0 to 9.
so let's start
we'll write int Main
so now let's first of all declare a
counting variable sum and initialize it
with 0.
now we will initialize another variable
I
with 0.
now the syntax will do while loop is
do keyword
and now we will add some code inside the
body
will write sum equals sum plus I
here what we are doing is we are simply
adding some variable and I variable and
storing it to some variable itself
we are doing this because we want to
find the sum that is why we have to
store it in a single variable
now we will need to increment I or else
Loop is going to run forever
now we will write file
I less than 10 we have
written I less than 10 because we want
to find the sum from 0 to 9.
and make sure to put a semicolon in the
end in case of 2 while loop
now we will print
some
in this while loop
we'll write sum is
some variable
now this Loop will keep on executing
till I is less than 10.
now in the do while loop sum is
calculated by repeated addition and
increment
in each repetition it is checked whether
the number I is smaller or equal to the
inputted number
if it is smaller then the loop continues
but exits the loop if it isn't
after the control exits from the loop
sum is printed
now let's try to run this code
here it is
sum is 45.
which is the right answer this is our
output
so this is how it is done in do while
loop
so now let's do one example of our last
Loop that is nested Loop
first of all we'll name the file
loops 5.cpp
now we'll start with the header files
Now using namespace standard
now in this program all we have to do is
to print a star pattern of half pyramid
form using nested load
so let's try
we'll write int Main
now let's initialize two variables that
is I
and J
now let's say we want to make a half Ram
bit of 10 rows then it means we need to
run a loop which runs for 10 times
so let's write
or
initialize it to zero
I less than
10.
I plus plus
now here we have written I less than 10.
instead of this we'll write I less than
equal to 10 because we want the 10th row
to be printed also
now we will print slash n
in order to insert a new line
now we'll write another for Loop
which will decide number of stars in a
particular row
so we'll write J equal to 1 because this
for Loop is for the column section
then J less than equal to I
which is a row
then J plus plus
now we'll print star
now one more thing instead of 0 we'll
write I equals to 1 because we want to
print stars from 1 to 10.
so now let's discuss it's working
initially we have I equals to 1 that is
the outer loop value
now for this value a complete run of jth
loop is happening that is J equal to 1
validated by J less than equal to I
now this condition is used because the
pattern which we are going to build is
having increment of Star as the number
of rows increments
so for I equals to 1 J equals to 1 is
executed then J plus plus is done which
increments the value of J to 2.
now J equals to 2 failed to execute as 2
is less than equal to 1 is false
therefore only one star is printed
[Music]
again we go to ith Loop now for I equal
to 2 we'll check every value of J which
can be executed that is 1 and 2. since
only two values can be true therefore 2
Star are printed
similarly we check for I equal to 3 4 5
and so on till 9. as we have the
condition I is less than 10.
so now we'll try to run this
and check whether the pattern is
printing or not
here it is
half pyramid form using stars with the
help of nested loops
so this is our star pattern
we can make some more different types of
patterns using nested loops
but we have done only one example in
order to understand the concept
so now let's move to our control flow
statements and let's do some examples of
them
okay now
make a new file
let's name this file as
Ctrl 1.
CPP
now we'll write the header file and the
namespace standard as we have done
previously
so let's do it
Dash include
live stream
using namespace STD
now here
we will write a program in which we have
to print the numbers from 100 to 200
like 110 hundred and twenty hundred and
thirty with a gap of 10. but after 150
we will terminate the ongoing Loop now
how can it be done with the help of
break statement so let's start
first of all we'll write intimate
now we'll take a variable num
and initialize it with 100.
now we'll write a while condition
and we'll write num is less than equal
to 200 because we want the loop to run
from 100 to 200.
num less than equal to 200
now we'll simply display those numbers
now we'll write any condition that if
num equals 150
then we'll terminate the loop and for
that we have to write the break
statement inside the if statement
so let's write
if num equals equals 150
then we have to break the loop
write the break statement
now after that we'll increment this
by 10.
we are incrementing this by 10 because
we want the numbers to be printed like
100 110 120 like this that is why we are
incrementing it with 10 and not with 1.
now we'll write out of the loop
just to be informed that we are finally
out of the loop
return zero
now we'll try to run this
here we can see yeah here we can see 100
110 120 up 250 after that we are out of
the loop
this means the code works fine
so this is the example of a break
statement now after this we'll do
another example of continue
so let's start
let's make a new file
and name it
ctrl2.cpv
now we'll write the header files
[Music]
using namespace standard
now in this program all we have to do is
to print the numbers from 100 to 90.
only excluding 96 from them
now how do we do it with the help of
continue statement
so let's start
first of all we'll write into Main
now we'll declare a variable
num and initialize it with 100.
now we'll write a while condition
while loop in which we write the
condition num greater than equal to 90
because we want the loop to run till it
is equal to 90 that is why we have wrote
greater than equal to 90. basically we
want the loop to run from 100 till it
becomes equal to 90.
now inside the loop we'll write the if
condition in order to skip 96. so we'll
write
if
num equals 96 num
quilts equals 96.
now we'll use a decrement operator
because our starting point is 100 and
ending point is 90 that is why we have
to use the decrement operator
now continue statement
after that write
value is
and we'll write the variable num
now we'll write num minus minus
here we are writing minus minus because
we want it to get decrement after
printing also that is why we have
written num minus minus after printing
num
now let's try to run this also hope it
works
okay I think there are some errors
so
some brackets were missing
and we'll write return 0.
now we'll try to run it
here it is
as we can see
199.90 and 97
but 96 is missing
so this is all we have to do in this
program
and this is the basic example of
continue statement
in order to understand these examples
better you must try more examples on
each of these loops and control flow
statements so that it will be easier for
you all today we'll be discussing about
C plus plus functions so let's go ahead
and look what's in it for us
first we'll discuss what is a function
then we'll understand why we use
functions then types of functions like
built-in function and user defined
function then function declaration after
that function calling then function call
methods and at last we have recursion
also don't forget to subscribe to our
Channel and hit the Bell icon to never
miss an update
moving on to the first topic that is
what is a function
functions are blocks of code that are
designed to perform a specific task
it basically divides the complex problem
into smaller portions and make the
program easy to understand and reusable
and by reusable it means we can Define
the code once and we can use it many
times
we can also pass data into the functions
in the form of parameters
and this is the syntax
first is return type of the function
then we will write function name then
inside the bracket these are the
parameters
now let's discuss why we use functions
functions make the program less
complicated because once function is
defined in the program then it can be
used over and over again which reduces
the complexity of code
and it helps in avoiding the duplicity
of code and it reduces the amount of
code due to this we can easily debug and
maintain the code
now coming to the types of functions
there are two types of functions in C
plus plus that is built-in functions and
user defined function
now let's discuss these functions
first is built-in function
these are also known as predefined
functions or Library functions we don't
need to Define these functions because
these are already present in C plus
libraries and the implementation of
these functions are also available in
library file
and to use these functions we don't have
to write them separately we simply call
them now coming to the user defined
functions
C plus plus allows us to Define our own
functions these functions are created by
programmers according to their
requirement
this allows a way to wrap a set of
statements to perform a specific task
and that group of statement is given a
name so that it can be invoked later
from any part of the program
following is the example of user defined
function here Club is a user defined
function with the return type void and
it is being called from the main
function
now let's learn about function
declaration
function declaration basically acts as
an identification for the function
it informs the compiler about the
existence of function functions name the
number of parameters in the function and
its return type
these things acts as an identifier for a
function
and this is the Syntax for a function
declaration
first we will write the return type then
we will write the name of the function
after that inside the bracket we will
write the number of parameters
for example in this chess function int
is the return type chest is the name of
the function
and inside the brackets these are the
number of parameters
although we can write the names of
parameters but names of parameters are
not important in the function
declaration only their type is required
now let's learn about function calling
in order to use a function we'll have to
invoke or call a function when a program
calls a function the control of the
program is transferred to the call
function and when the code function
completes its task then the control is
returned back to the main program
so the functions are called by writing
the name of function and after that
writing the required parameters inside
the brackets
and this is the syntax first we will
write the function name and after that
we will write the arguments which you
want to pass
for example sum is the function name and
a and b are the arguments so first is
call by value
call by value is a method in which
copies of variables are passed to the
functions and as the copies of variables
or arguments are being passed so that is
why the changes that are done inside the
function does not affect the arguments
and this is the syntax inside int main
we can see that we are calling a
function and passing the values here
well 1 and Val 2 are the actual
parameters these are those which are
passed to the functions and inside the
brackets of call function we can see N1
and N2 these are formal parameters
forward parameters are those which are
received by the function
so here we can say values of actual
parameters that is well 1 and well 2
will be copied to the formal parameters
that is N1 and N2
now let's have a look at an example in
which we are swapping two numbers
as we can see inside int main we have
assigned 120 to X and 152i
after that we have called a function
named swap it and inside the brackets we
are passing the values of X and Y
and these values are getting received by
called function
and inside that function there is a
logic to swap the code with the help of
temporary variable temp
and these values of X and Y are then
displayed inside int Main
but its output is same
X is still 120 and Y is still 150 there
is no change after swapping it also
so this shows that actual value of the
variable is not getting modified
this shows that change is done to the
parameters inside the function does not
affect the arguments
now let's learn about call by reference
in this method instead of passing the
arguments the address of the argument is
passed to the formal arguments of the
function
and the address is used to access the
actual argument referring to the same
location so any changes that are made
gets reflected to the actual parameter
this is the syntax of call by reference
in which we have assigned 200 to the
variable num and then the address of
this variable is passed to the function
and 20 is assigned to it
now on displaying the output the value
would be 20 and not 200 because the
value is assigned to the memory location
that is why change is getting reflected
now let's have a look at an example of
swap
this is the same example as that of the
call by value but instead of passing the
copies of variable we are passing the
address of the variable
and inside the function values are
getting swapped with the help of temp
variable and then it is getting
displayed in the main function
in this case we can see in the output
the values of variables are actually
swapped m is now 300 and N is now 250.
now let's do some examples of call by
value and call by reference in a code
editor that is vs code
now we will do an example of call by
value in which we will try to change the
salary with the help of a function
so let's start first of all let's make a
new file and name it
call1.cpp
now we will include the header files
hash include
i o stream
now we will add namespace standard
foreign
and we will declare a variable cell
and assign a value 27
000 let's say
salary to this cell variable
now we will call a function
let's name that function as salary
underscore change
and now inside the brackets we'll write
cell
as we know that in call by value
we pass the copies of the variable
so
now we'll display
that variable
we'll write
value
inside Main
and now we will write the variable name
cell
and handle
now return 0.
now let's make the function salary
change
we'll write
void
salary underscore
change
let's avoid
now here we will write hint the data
type and the variable
s that is the formal parameter cell here
is the actual parameter and S is the
formal parameter
now
we will assign as a new value
let's say 30 000.
here we have assigned as 30 000 earlier
the value of cell was 27 000 and then we
passed the copy of the variable cell
to the function salary change and there
we assign 30 000 to it
so let's print over here
value
inside function
[Music]
cell
handle
here we have to write s
because the variable name is s
okay now let's try to run this
here we can see value inside function is
30 000. and value inside main is 27 000.
here we can see the value of the
variable that is passed gets changed but
the original value inside the main
function doesn't changes
so we can say changes are not reflected
to the original value which happens in
call by Value method
so now let's do one example of call by
reference
let's make a new file
call to
dot CPP
let's include the header files
hash include
i o stream
now we'll write using namespace standard
different
ly
now we'll start with int Main
here we will declare a variable cell
and assign 27 000 to it
as we have done previously
now we'll call a function named
increment
foreign
the address of cell
as we know that in case of call by
reference we pass the address
so after that we'll just write the
message saying
salary
inside Main
and
we'll write the variable cell
then handle
after that we'll write return 0
now our job is to write the
function
we'll write void
increment
and here
we'd write Ampersand sign s
because here we are passing the address
not any copy of the value or the
variable here we are passing the address
of the variable
so that is why we have used Ampersand
sign now
we will simply write the logic to
increment
so we'll write s equals S Plus
5000 let's say we want the salary to
increment by five thousand
then we will display
the variable s so first of all we'll
write the message
salary
inside
function
the name of the variable after that and
then
now let's try doing this
foreign
here we can see that the salary inside
the function is 32 000 and salary
outside
the function that is inside the main
function is 32 000 as well
here we can see that the changes are
reflected to the original values as well
in the main function and we know that in
case of call by reference any change
inside the function is reflected outside
the function because we are passing the
address of the variable
foreign
so this is our output thirty two
thousand and thirty two thousand so
these were some basic examples of call
by value and call by reference now here
we will do a program in which we have to
do the sum of two integers with the help
of function
so let's first of all
make a new file
function dot CPP
okay so let's start first of all we'll
declare the header files
that is Hash include Airstream
now the namespace standard
now we'll write int Main
now inside end main we'll declare a
variable named s
here we have declared this variable
because we want to store the sum of
those two integers in this variable
so
we'll call the function let's say let's
name the function as sum
and let's
assume the variables to be 5 and 5.
here sum is the name of the function and
5 comma 5 are the arguments now we'll
make the function sum
here end is the return type
sum is the name
and
a command B
are the parameters
so in this function we'll write the code
to do the sum of these two integers and
for that we have to store the sum in a
variable
for that we will now declare a variable
C
now we will write C equals a plus b
here we are storing the sum of a plus b
into the variable C
now as we know that the return type is
end so we have to return the variable
instead of printing it
will write
return
C
now in the main function
will print that variable
we will print the variable as because
after the function completes its task of
addition the output will come back to
the calling function which is getting
stored in the variable s
so
we'll write
the result is
now we will write the variable s
let's see
hope it runs
the result is 10.
5 plus 5 on addition will get 10.
let's write three
and again
try to run this
the result is 8.
5 plus 3 equals to it so this is the
right answer
now we will do another example of C plus
plus function
in which we have to find the larger
number or greater number among two
elements
so let's do that
let's create a new file
function1.cpp
now we will include the header files
hash include I have stream
Now using namespace standard
now first of all we'll write the in
plane
yeah
the variable N1
now we will declare another variable N2
these are the two variables among which
we have to find the greater number
so
we'll display a message saying that
enter
the first number
foreign
now we'll do the same for the other one
we'll write
enter the second number
we'll input the second number
now
we have to make a call to the function
named let's say maxi
and we will pass these arguments N1
comma into
now let's make this function maxi
the return type is void
Maxi is the name
we'll write the variables N1
and 2.
now we'll write the if condition because
we have to find the greater number among
both these elements so we'll write the
if condition
if
N1 is greater than N2
then it must print the n-word
we will also display a message saying
that
the larger number is
N1
if N1 is greater than N2 then we'll
display the N1
and
if N2 is greater
then we'll display the N2
we'll write the variable N2
thank you
so let's see if that runs or not
I think we have to write the first
number here we can see enter the first
number
enter the first number so we will write
let's say
56
and the second number would be 78
the larger number is 78. so
among both the numbers as we know that
70s is greater than 56 so this is how we
can show it with the help of functions
so these were some basic samples of C
plus functions and in today's session we
will learn about C plus plus recursion
now let's have a look at what we'll be
covering today
first of all we'll discuss what is
recursion then we'll understand the
working of recursion that is how it
actually works after that we will learn
about types of recursion and at last we
will go through the advantages and
disadvantages of recursion so what is
recursion recursion can be defined as a
process in which a function calls itself
again and again until a certain
condition is met recursion basically
brings about several number of iterative
calls to the same function
however it is important to have a base
case to end the recursion
for example imagine you are calling your
friend again and again for an urgent
piece of work until he picks up the call
now here calling your friend again and
again or one after the other is a
recursive function and when he picks up
your call is the termination condition
and this is the basic syntax where the
function name is recursion and it is
being called from the main function and
inside the recursion function it is
calling itself now let's understand it's
working
in a recursive function there are two
parts that is the recursive case and the
base case in the recursive case the
function is being called by itself again
and again and the base case is when the
function finally stop calling itself
so when the recursive function is called
from the main function then the call
function will execute and it keeps on
repeating as it is being called by
itself from within the function again
and again until it meets the base case
that will terminate its calling
for example factorial of 5. in this
problem we can see a pattern an into
factorial of n minus 1. to be clear n is
5. so n minus 1 is 4. and it is going on
till n becomes 0.
here factorial is the recursive function
and N minus 1 is the argument that is
getting passed for every n into the
recursive function in this case if n
becomes 0 or 1
it is the base case and N into factorial
n minus 1 is the recursive condition
now let's understand the types of
recursion
first is direct recursion as the name
suggests in this type of recursion
function calls itself directly for
example void recursion here recursion is
the name of the function and is being
called by itself from within the
function directly although there is no
base case in this example but it shows
the idea of direct recursion
now coming to indirect recursion when a
function calls itself indirectly that is
if a function calls some other function
to make a recursive call then it is
known as indirect function
for example here recursion function is
calling some other function sub
and sub function is calling the
recursion function here both the
functions are calling other functions to
make a recursive call this is called
indirect recursion now coming to
advantages and disadvantages of
recursion the advantages are in
recursion we only need to define the
base case and the recursive case
so therefore it provides a Simple and
Clean way to write a code
second is recursion is more preferred in
problems like tree traversals Tower of
annoy graphs because these are
inherently recursive problems now
disadvantages disadvantages are the
recursive program generally acquires
more space than the iterative program
this is because after every call to the
function each function call will keep on
adding to the stack until the base case
is reached
second is it requires more amount of
time because of function calls now let's
do some examples of recursion on our
code editor that is vs code now here we
will do a program in which we will find
the sum of natural number up to a number
which we will enter and we will do this
example using recursion
so let's start
first of all we'll name this
recursion
dot CPP
okay now we will start with writing
header file that is Hash include
iostream
now we'll add namespace standard
using name space
STD
now first of all we'll write int Main
now we will declare a variable let's say
num
so basically we want to enter a number
so for that first of all we'll display a
message saying that enter a number
now we'll take the input
input as num
sorry
okay so now here we will make a call to
the function and in that function we
will pass the variable num which we have
taken the input of and we will print
this with a message
so let's say
we'll print it like C out
and the message would be
sum is
and this is the function name sum
and this is the variable which we are
passing
to that let's write return 0.
now let's make this function some
will write int the return type
sum the name of the function
and
the variable num
foreign
now first of all we have to make a base
case
so we will write the base case as
we'll make if
num
is not equal to zero
then
here we will write the recursive case
return
num Plus
some
num minus 1.
so here we are adding the numbers with
its previous number and because of
recursive condition it will keep on
calling the same function some function
again and again till the base case that
is num becomes equal to 0 is achieved
and once it is achieved the calling
would be stopped
num not equal to 0 here means that if
num is not equal to 0 then only this
statement num plus sum num minus 1
will execute
Okay so
now after this
will
try to run this
enter the number let's say
five
sum is 15 here we can see
sum is 15.
okay let's recheck 5 plus 4 equals to 9
9 plus 3 equals to 12 12 plus 2 equals 2
14 14 plus 1 equals to 15 so our answer
is correct so this is how we can find
the sum up to any numbers which we want
to find the sum of and
now let's do another example
so let's name this as
recursion
2 dot CBP
now here we will do a program of
factorial we will enter a number and we
have to find the factorial of that
number
so let's start
first of all we'll write hash include
iostream that is the header file
Now using namespace standard
now we'll write int Main
okay now we will declare a variable
number
and we want to take the input from the
user so we'll display a message saying
enter the number
now we will take the input
we'll write number
now we will call a function and we will
send the pass the argument number as we
have done in the previous question
so let's do it
first of all we'll display that
saying
the factorial
of the number
you have entered
is
now we will make a call to the function
let's say the name of the function is
fact
and
will pass the argument number
as we have done previously
now we'll write return 0.
now let's make this function
we will write the in return type int
now fact
after that now we will write the
argument
and number
now we will write if condition
and we'll write
number
less than one
and we will return
one
so here we have wrote this condition
because as we know that the factorial of
0 is 1 and if a number is less than 1
that it means it is 0 and if it is 0
then our program should return 1.
and
you will write now else condition
else
if it is not 0 that means
we will write the recursive condition
that is
number
into
fact
number minus 1.
now this is the condition that is
responsible for finding the factorial of
a number
for example if we input 5 then here we
can see the condition would become 5
into fact 5 minus 1 that is 4. and this
4 will be passed as argument to this
fact function and then the condition
would become 4 into fact 4 minus 1 that
is 3 and it is also passed to the
function and similarly it will go on
until it becomes less than 1.
now let's try to run this
enter the number
let's say six
the factorial of number you have entered
is 720 and we know that the factorial of
6 is 720 so this is the right answer
and let me tell you this is uh this is
the base case and this is the recursive
case in this program
now after that let's do one last example
of recursion
okay so now let's make a new file
and name this file
now first of all we'll add the header
files
I have stream
now namespace standard using name
space standard
so here we will do the program of
Fibonacci series and we know that
Fibonacci series is basically each num
in Fibonacci series each number is
basically the sum of its two previous
numbers
so let's start so first of all we'll
make int Main
now we'll declare a variable num
now we want to take the input from the
user so first of all we'll display a
message saying that
enter the number
now we'll take the input
we'll write num
now
we will make a for Loop and iterate that
loop from i 0 to num
so we'll write for keyword
int I equal to 0
I less than num
I plus plus
now inside the loop we will write C out
to display and we will call fibo
function and we will pass I as an
argument because we want to print the
series
so we will write C out
fibo
and we'll pass I
as an argument and
just for the space
now I will write return
0.
in fibo function we have passed is an
argument because we want to print the
series so first 0 will be passed then 1
will be passed after then 2 will be
passed and so on
so now we will make the function fibo
and is the return type Vivo is the name
now the argument num
now in this fibo function we will put if
condition for checking if the num is
equal to 0 or 1. if yes we will return
the value of num else we will
recursively call fibo using n minus 1
and N minus 2 because Fibonacci series
is basically the sum of previous two
numbers
so first of all we'll write
if
num is less than equal to 1.
then
return num
num
else
return
fibo
num minus 1
Plus
fibo
brackets num minus 2.
because we know
Fibonacci series is basically the sum of
previous two numbers
now if the
num is 0 or 1 then it will go to the if
statement and if it is greater than 0
and 1 then it will go to this recursive
statement
so for example if n equals to 2 then we
will call recursively 2 minus 1 and 2
minus 2 that is 1 and 0 respectively
since 2 minus 1 will give 1 and 2 minus
2 will give 0 these will be evaluated in
if statement as they are less than equal
to 1 so it will give 0 plus 1 that is
equal to 1.
now let's try to run this code
enter the number let's say six
all right
zero one one two three five which is the
right answer
the Fibonacci sequence for six is zero
one one two three five
so this is how we can do Fibonacci
series or Fibonacci Sequence with the
help of recursion
and I suggest you to do some more
examples on recursion to understand it
better in this session we will learn
about fan functions in C plus plus so
let's go ahead and have a look at what
we'll be covering today in this session
we will cover topics like why do we need
a friend function what is a friend
function in C plus plus then the
Declaration of friend function and after
that we will learn what is a friend
class then we will understand features
of rent function and its advantages but
before we begin make sure to subscribe
to our Channel and hit the Bell icon to
never miss an update so first is why do
we need a friend function friend
functions are used when we want to
access the private or protected members
of the class but without the help of the
objects it helps us in avoiding the case
where the functions must be a member of
both the classes in order to access them
or in other words a function doesn't
have to be a member of both the classes
in order to access the class data a
friend function is also used to perform
operator overloading like functions
operators can also be overloaded and
because of the friend function it is
possible now let's understand what is a
friend function a friend function is not
a member function of the class and it is
defined outside the class
and we know outside members cannot
access the class data but the friend
function can access those private public
and protected class data because the
friend function is friendly with the
class now let's move to Declaration of
friend function the Declaration of Rand
function must be done inside the class
the friend function is declared using
the front keyword then the return type
then the name of the function that is
made a friend of the class its
definition is done outside the class and
we don't use the front keyword while
defining it but while declaring it
inside the class we use the front
keyword now coming to the next topic
that is what is a friend class exactly
like a friend function a class can also
be a friend of another class A Friend
class is that class that can access the
data members and member functions of a
class to which it is a friend we need to
pass the objects of the class us to a
member function of the friend class if
we want to access those private and
protected members also if the classes
are declared friends then all the member
functions of the class will be a friend
function to the friend class now let's
have a look at the syntax here we have
done the forward Declaration of class
table this will allow the access of the
objects of the class table in the class
club inside the class club we have
declared friend class table that means
the class table is a friend of class
club and it can access members of that
class after that we have defined the
class table without the front keyword as
we can see now coming to features of
friend function so here are some
features of friend functions so let's
start with the first one that is a
friend function can be easily involved
just like a normal function it doesn't
require any object or so to invoke
next is the scope of a friend function
is not limited it can be a member of
another class as well third is a friend
function can be declared in any part
that is private protected or public
parts of the class fourth is the object
of the class can be used as an argument
for the function and the last is a
friend function can access the members
by using the object name and Dot
operator along with the member's name
now coming to advantages of friend
function the First Advantage is with the
help of Rand function we are able to
access the non-public members of the
class that is the private members the
second Advantage is fan function helps
in operator overloading and the third
Advantage is because of the friend
function we are able to share the
private information by a known member
function as friend function is not a
member function the last Advantage is
fan function allows us to generate more
more efficient code so these were some
advantages of friend function so now
let's go ahead and do some examples on
friend functions to understand it in a
better way so let's open our Visual
Studio code and do some examples so
first of all let's make a new file let's
name it friend1 dot CPP
all right so now here we'll do a simple
program of Rand function so let's start
with including the header file hash
include I have stream
now we will write using namespace
standard
all right
and inside the main function first of
all we will create an object of a class
let's say the name of the class is
salary and the name of the object is s
all right after that we will
simply write return 0 and we will do the
rest of this after creating the class so
we need to First create the class now
we'll write class
salary which is the name of the class
and inside this class first of all we'll
write private access modifier and here
we will write or declare
a variable named cell after that now we
will write or declare the friend
function so we know how to declare a
friend function we'll write friend
keyword
then the return type that is int and
then the name of the function let's say
increment and then the objects as we
know we have to pass
the name of the class with the object
because we want to access the private
member of the class so salary s which is
the object
and after the class we'll write the
semicolon now we have to create or
Define this increment friend function
we'll write
int increment here we haven't used the
front keyword because this is the
definition now inside the arguments
we'll pass the
the object
all right now inside the main function
we will call this friend function so
first of all we will display a message
saying that
increment
is
that the increment in the salary is
and then we will call this function
and we will pass this object
all right now inside this increment
function which is a friend function we
will use object as dot operator and then
the name of the variable which is
private
now all we need to do is to increment
this salary variable so we'll write s
dot cell plus 7000 which is the
increment and then we will return
s dot cell all right now as we can see
this increment function which is not a
member function of this class is
accessing this private variable of
salary class and is incrementing 7000 to
the salary so now let's save it first
and let's try to run this
there is some error let's have a look at
that
all right yeah there is some spelling
mistake increment let's save it
and run it so as we can see increment is
7000 so this is the correct output
so this was a simple example of friend
function let's do another example so
here we will do an example of friend
class and we know friend class is a
class that can access the data members
and number functions of a class to which
it is a friend
so let's start first of all we'll
include the header files
hash include iostream
and then the namespace standard
and we forgot to name this file so let's
do it let's name it friend2.cpp
all right now let's proceed
didn't mean inside the main function
first of all we will create an object of
a class let's say the class name is num2
and its object is obj2 object 2. now for
now let's say we'll write only return 0
we'll do this part later onwards now
let's create the class all right so the
class name would be num2 num1 actually
but we know in front class we have to do
the forward declaration so we will write
class num 2 so this is a forward
Declaration of class num2 now
inside class num1 first of all we'll
declare a variable in private
so let's say the name of the variable is
int N1 enters the data type and one is
the name of the variable now we have to
do the Declaration of friend class so
we'll write front keyword after that
class
num2 which is the name of the class
all right after this let's create this
first of all we have to put the
semicolon all right now let's write this
class num2
so this is our friend class num2 we
haven't used front keyword over here as
we can see
all right in this class we'll use a
private access specifier and
we'll create another variable N2 and
then we will write the public access
specifier and we will create a
Constructor of num2 as this is the name
of the class and this is object we have
created so now we will create the
Constructor of this class
num2 and now in this Constructor we will
initialize N2 with 65 or whatsoever
number we want because in the end we
have to find the average of two
variables so this is the second variable
N2 and we have assigned the value 65 so
now let's make the function of average
because we want to find the average of
both the numbers
so enter the data type AVG is the name
of the function let's say and inside
this function we will make an object of
num1 class and the object name is obj1
now as we have created the object
by mistake we have wrote I obj1 so as we
have created the object of num1 class
with its Constructor would be invoke
which we will create now but first of
all here we will write return
the average so we'll write obj1 Dot N1
plus N2
divided by
2
so as we know that obj1 is the object of
num1 class so that is why we have used
obj1 dot operator N1 that is the name of
the variable plus N2 divided by 2 from
here we can find the average and before
that we have to create the Constructor
of this class so
now all we need to do is write Public
Access modifier
now num1 and inside this num1 we will
assign the value to N1 variable which is
let's say 11. all right so now in the
main function we have to call this
function avj that is the average
function and
we forgot to put semicolon over here all
right now we'll display a message
average is
and now we will call the function
obj 2 dot AVG
which is a function so here we are
calling this function so let's save this
so we have saved this now let's try to
run this one as you can see the average
is 38 so
65 plus 11 6 and 76 divided by 2 which
is 38 so this is the correct output so
this is a fine example of friend class
as we know class num2 is a friend of
class num1 so it can access all the
members of class num1 in class num2 we
have created the function AVG over here
this is the function AVG here we are
doing the average of both the numbers
and as class num2 is a friend of num1 so
we can create objects of num1 in num2
class
and after doing this this is our output
that is average is 38 so this is an
example of friend class now let's do
another example so here we will do an
example of friend function in which a
friend function is a friend to two
classes and this would be an example in
which we have to do the product of two
numbers so let's start first of all
let's include the header files as we
have done previously
iostream
namespace standard now let's save it
friend3.cpp and
spelling is wrong
now let's start with the main function
inside the int main first of all we will
create the object of Class A that is a
and Class B object would be small B
and we will use these objects to call
the functions but we will do that part
later onwards first of all we'll simply
write return 0 over here and now we'll
create the classes all right so here we
will create a class but before that we
have to do the forward Declaration of
another class so this is the forward
Declaration of Class B and now we can
create the class A and inside the a
class we will declare the variable X
let's say now
we'll use this public scope
and we will create a function within
this class let's say void assign
now inside this function we will pass
the variable I because because we have
to assign the value of this variable I
to the variable X
so
we will assign the value of I to X
like this and before that we have to do
the calling from the main function so we
will do that later first of all we will
create the front function and here we
are declaring this print function
void is the return type product let's
say is the name of this friend function
and a comma B are the arguments
now
let's call this assign function first of
all so all we need to do is we will make
a call from this main function a DOT
assign which is the name of the function
and let's say we have passed the value
45 now here we will create the class B
inside the b class we'll similarly
create another variable y
and now inside the public scope we will
create function of the same name that is
assign now in this assign function we
will pass
I as the argument as we have done in
class A similarly we'll do it over here
we will assign the value of I to this
variable y
once we have done this
then we will declare friend function as
we know that the front function is
friend of both of these classes so we
have to do it inside both of these
classes we have to declare the friend
function and now we will declare the
front function in this class as well
product
all right after the class we will use
the semicolon now
we will create the friend function so
here we are defining the front function
we use void product which is the name of
the function now data type object name
all right now all we need to do is we'll
do this sum a DOT X into B dot Y and now
we'll use semicolon so here a DOT X will
hold the value which have been assigned
that is 45 and now B dot x b dot y will
hold the value which we will call from
here B dot assign
here we are calling and we are assigning
the value let's say 20. you're passing
the value 20 and this 20 value
will be assigned to this Y and 45 into
20 would be the product
so everything is done now all we need to
do is to call the
product function and as we know that the
product function that is the friend
function is the friend of both of the
classes so it can access the private
variables so we'll do that
product
a comma B here we are calling this now
let's save this one and let's try to run
this
there are some errors
let's check them Class A all right so
before I go to make some space over here
now let's save it again and let's try to
run this
as we can see the output is 900 so 45
into 20 is equal to 900 which is the
correct answer
and it means the program is working fine
so this is a fine example in which a
function that is this product function
is a friend of both the classes that is
Class B and this class A here we have
done the forward declaration and we have
made the front of Class A and here we
have declared the friend function in
class B and as we can see that this
product function can use or access the
private variables of both the classes
and so this is by using the private
variables we we have done the product of
both of these numbers and its answer is
900 so these were some few examples of
rent functions you can try some more
examples on it it will enhance your
knowledge in Z Plus as it is an
interesting topic welcome to this video
on C plus plus header files and in
today's session we will learn about why
we need header files then what is c plus
header file after that we will learn
about types of header files and how can
we create our own header file and at
last we will have a look at some
examples of header files
header files allows us to assemble all
the predefined functions in one place
and it is helpful because it is easier
to get the Declarations in one place and
then use them whenever we need them and
as all the Declarations are gathered in
one place so it automatically reduces
the complexity and it also decreases the
number of lines of code
there are many functionalities of header
files one of them is it helps in taking
the input from the user and also helps
in displaying the output in a program
now let's learn what actually a C plus
plus header file is
header files are the set of libraries
that contains predefined functions at a
common place so it basically stores the
Declarations at one common place and
they are being used while writing a
program
these header files usually have a dot h
extension and we use hash include before
writing the header file to inform the
preprocessor that we are including this
header file now let's discuss types of
header files
there are two types of files in C plus
first is predefined header file these
files are already present in C plus
compiler we simply need to import these
header files using hash include which
will inform the compiler about the
header file and then we can write the
name of the header file between the
angle brackets
next is user defined header file these
header files are defined or created by
users in C plus user can create their
own header file and include it in the C
plus library and it can be used whenever
it is required now let's learn how to
create this header file in order to
create your own header file first of all
we will write the C plus code which we
want to use whenever we want after that
we will save the file with dot h
extension as we can see in Step 1 we
have written the code of two integers
that are getting multiplied
and now we will include this in the
program
to include this in the program we will
use hash include and after that we will
write the name of the header file inside
the angle brackets with the dot h
extension here hash include will inform
the compiler that a header file is added
and now as we can see in Step 2 after
the Declaration of two integers we are
calling the function product and passing
the arguments X and Y
after running this program we will get
the output as 45. because 9 into 5
equals 45 and we don't need to worry
about writing the logic of it because we
have already included this header file
now let's have a look at some examples
of header files
hash include iostream iostream is the
header file that is used to read and
write the standard input output streams
because of this header file we can take
the input and display the output and in
case of iostream dot h is not used
because after standardization of C plus
plus IO stream became standard header
whose function is now in STD namespace
unlike earlier when functions were
defined in iostream before
standardization
next is f stream fstream are associated
with files it is basically used to read
the information from files and write the
information in it
and next is IO manip IO manip is a
library that is used in the manipulation
of input and output statements
so these were some examples of header
files today we'll be discussing about C
plus plus array so without further Ado
let's get started so what's in it for
you
we will start by understanding why do we
need arrays then what is an array after
that types of array like one dimension
array two Dimension array
multi-dimension array and then memory
representation and lastly we'll go
through error initialization
so first is need of arrays
we use arrays because it allows us to
store similar type of data within
contiguous block of memory
and it allows us to iterate through
those variables conveniently using
indexing
usually an array is used to store
similar kind of data like marks scored
by all the students of a class and
record of attendance of all the
employees in an organization
now moving to what is an array
an array can be defined as a collection
of similar kind of elements these are
always stored in contiguous memory
locations that is one after the other
the total number of elements in an array
is called the length of the array now
this is the way you can visualize the an
array here each block is capable of
storing data values of some type in
sequential Manner and each element can
uniquely identify by its index in the
array
and this is the syntax of array hint is
the data type array is the area name and
5 is the size of array
now there are few types of variance C
plus plus
those are
one dimension array two dimensional
array and multi-dimensional array so
let's first of all discuss 1D array
this is the simplest form of an array in
this array data items are arranged
linearly in one dimension having single
index value to represent data elements
now this is the syntax of 1D array type
is the data type then there is array
name and after that size of array and
this is the example of one dimensional
array
now coming to its memory representation
here we can see 2 7 4 8 1 6 are the
elements inside the memory blocks
and 0 1 2 3 4 5 are the indexes
so by using index we can easily access
the elements and once the array elements
are accessed a number of operations can
be performed
here array of 0 means 2 and array of 1
means 7 and so on
as each element is of type int that is 2
byte that means the array occupies 12
contagious bytes because each block
contain 2 byte and there are total six
blocks
now coming to the two dimensional array
in this array each element is referred
by two indexes that is rows and columns
and they are stored in the form of
matrices the first index shows a row of
the Matrix and the second index shows
the column of The Matrix
now moving to its memory representation
as you can see this is a 2d array with
three rows and three columns and we can
also say that these are basically three
1D array containing three blocks each
combined to form a 2d array in the form
of a matrix with size of 3 cross 3. the
horizontal line step its rows and the
vertical line step its columns and we
know that index starts from 0 so first
elements get stored at array 0 0 that is
0 through and zero column then second
element is stored at array 0 1 that is
zeroth row and column 1 and likewise all
the elements are stored in the array now
coming to the multi-dimensional array
[Music]
these are defined as area of arrays that
means each element of multi-dimension
array is an array itself they can have
any number of dimensions and it stores
the data in tabular form
a two-dimensional array is also
multi-dimensional array
and this is the Syntax for a
multi-dimensional array
here type is the data type of array then
array name is the name of the array and
size 1 size 2 up to so on size n are the
dimension of sizes
after that this is the basic example of
a multi-dimensional array
now coming to the next topic that is
error initialization
so there are two ways to initialize an
array in C plus first is you can
initialize an array when you declare it
by including the initial values in
braces after the Declaration
while declaring we could use curly
braces to set the values inside it
for example in this array of size 6 the
element 2 is at 0 index 5 is at one
index one is at 2 index and so on
if we don't mention the size of array
then the array will only be large enough
to hold the elements added within the
curly braces
other than this we can set the value
after the Declaration by assigning the
element to the array using its index
like array of 0 equal to 5
here we are assigning 5 to index 0 and
array of 1 equal to 7 here we are
assigning 7 to index 1 and same goes for
the array of 2. now let's do some
examples on array to understand them
better we'll do these examples on our
code editor that is vs code if getting
your learning started is half the battle
what if you could do that for free visit
scale up by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
now we'll make a new file
and let's name that file as
array.cpp
array1.cb
now we'll do a basic example in which we
have to print
the elements of array
so let's start first of all we'll write
the header file
[Music]
Dash include irstream
foreign
Spades standard
[Music]
I will write into Main
now we'll start by writing the data type
int now we'll write the array name that
is let's say open
and now the size of array
let's say 6.
now curly braces now inside these curly
braces we'll write those elements
let's say five
eight
seven
three
nine
one
so these are those elements and this is
a
array declaration
now
here int means the data type coupon is
the array Name six is the size of array
and five eight seven three nine one are
the elements of array
now after that we'll write the for loop
with four keyword
now we'll initialize I with 0
I less than 6 because it is the size of
array
now we'll increment I
now in this Loop all we have to do is to
print this array so how do we do that
so let's do c out
and inside the bracket we'll write I
so here we have printed the array inside
the loop and we have put I inside the
array bracket
now the loop will run from i 0 to 6 and
likewise all the elements from 5 to 1
will get printed so let's see
let's try to run this code
so this is our output
[Music]
587391 so this is how we can print the
elements of an array
and if we want to print a particular
element from the array all we have to do
is to write the index number of that
element inside the bracket let's say if
we want to print 7
[Music]
all we have to do is to print its index
number that is 2.
now let's run this
see 777 it is because of the loop that
from i 0 to I6 that is why it is getting
printed six times
now if we remove the loop and try to
print it then it will get print only one
time
let's see
foreign
and this is what we want to print
now let's do another example
let's name this file
array2.cbd
foreign
all we have to do is to do the sum of
all the elements of the array
so let's start by writing our header
file
stream
[Music]
Now using namespace STD
okay
now we'll write into Main
now here first of all we'll declare a
variable sum and initialize it with 0.
[Music]
now we'll declare another variable n
and N will depict the size of the array
so first of all in order to scan array
first of all we have to scan the size of
it
so we'll scan and
foreign
[Music]
and inside the bracket we will mention n
because it is the size
[Music]
now we'll write for Loop
and we will initialize with I equals 0.
I less than n which is the size of array
and we'll increment I plus plus
we are writing for Loop here because we
want to scan the array and as in this
array there are more than one element so
that is why we need four loops
so now we will scan the array
we'll write C in
the name of array
and inside the bracket we'll write I
now here we have written I inside the
brackets because we want to take input
of elements from I equal to 0 to n which
is the size of area
no
we'll take another for Loop
now here we will write another for Loop
in which we are initializing I from 0 to
n and inside that for Loop we will do
the sum of the array
so we'll write
equals to zero
I less than n which is the size
now we will increment I plus plus
now inside this for Loop
we'll do the code we'll do the logic of
adding the elements of the array
we'll write sum as we know that we have
already initialized sum with 0 we'll
write sum equals to sum
Plus
array of file
now for this statement sum equals to sum
plus array of I we are adding each value
in the array one by one into the sum
which is initially 0. when I equals to 0
then the sum will be equal to 0 plus
array of 0 and this sum will keep on
getting stored inside the variable sum
as our I increments are sum keeps on
storing the addition value
now we'll print this sum
outside the loop
we'll write C out
and we'll write sum is
[Music]
now we will write the sum variable
return
let me tell you return 0 is optional in
C plus plus basically return value is
exit status of the program and 0 is
considered as okay in C plus plus
compiler includes it automatically but
it's a good practice
here we forget to write the data type
now we'll try to run it
[Music]
so first of all we'll write the size
like
let's say six
now the elements of the array
let's say one
two
three
four
five and six
now we want to find the sum of these
elements
sum is 21 let's recheck 1 plus 2 equals
to 3 3 plus 3 equals 6 6 plus 4 10. 10
plus 5 15 15 and 6 is 21 so this is our
right answer so this is another basic
example of array
so after this we'll do one example of
two Dimension array also
so let's make a new file
and we'll write the head file
let's name this file as
array3.cpp
now namespace standard
now we'll write int Main
now we will declare a 2d array of three
rows and three columns with elements
inside it
three rows
and second bracket will write three
columns
now we'll write the curly braces
and
and another curly braces
this is the way to declare a 2d array
now to
seven
nine let's say
now again curly braces
one three
eight because we are creating a matrix
of 3 cross 3
that is why there are total nine
elements inside the array
so now we will create a nested for Loop
where the outer loop IE which is for the
rows of Matrix is initialized from 0 to
2.
we'll write int I equal to zero
now I Less Than 3
i e plus plus increment
now we will write inner for Loop J which
is for the column and we will initialize
it from 0 to 2 as well
we'll write for
int J equals 0
J Less Than 3
J plus plus
now we will print the array
in the first bracket we will mention I
that is the number of rows and in the
second bracket we will mention J that is
number of columns
and in order to add space
we will add
paste in the output
now
outside the bracket we will mention NL
shift the elements to the next line
after that we'll write it 0.
so this is our output
541279138 in The Matrix form that is why
I have used this space
to make the output look good and this
handle
so this is our output 541279138
so this is how we can print the elements
of a multi-dimensional array or two
dimensional array these were some basic
examples of array and in order to
understand these programs you must
practice more examples on it in this
session we will learn about sorting in C
plus plus so let's go ahead and have a
look at what we'll be covering today
we will learn what is sorting in C plus
plus then the categories of sorting
which are internal and external sorting
after that we will understand types of
sorting in C plus plus that are bubble
sort selection sort insertion sort and
quick sort
and at last we will understand sorting
using C plus plus Library
but before we begin make sure to
subscribe to our Channel and press the
Bell icon to never miss an update
so first is what is sorting in C plus
plus
sorting in C plus plus is a concept in
which the elements of array are
rearranged in a logical order
now this order can be from the lowest to
the highest or highest to the lowest
rearranging them in a sorted order helps
in dealing with many problems like
searching the maximum element or the
minimum element from an array of
elements
in C plus plus sorting is categorized
into two types that is internal sorting
and external sorting
so let's understand these in internal
sorting the data to be sorted is present
in the main memory
and the process of sorting will also
take place in the main memory itself
while in case of external sorting the
data is not always present in the main
memory because the data is large
so data is filled in the main memory in
small portions
so this is the difference between
internal sorting and external sorting
now coming to types of sorting in C plus
plus
there are various types of sorting in C
plus plus that are bubble sort selection
sort insertion sort and quick sort
select start with bubble sort
bubble sort is one of the easiest
sorting techniques in C plus plus
in this technique the comparisons are
done starting from the first two
elements
the adjacent elements are compared if
the element on the left is greater than
the element in the right then the
swapping is done and it will proceed
till the end of the array
so first the comparison will start from
the first two elements that are 22 and
13. and as we know that 22 on the left
is greater than 13. so we will swap
these elements and make them 13 on the
left and 22 on the right
now it became
1322 5 7 11.
so now we will compare 22 which is at
index 1 with 5 that is at index 2. and
as 22 is greater than 5 we will swap
these elements as well
then again we will compare it with the
next element
and F22 is greater than that element as
well then we will swap them as well so
in this way round 1 of comparison is
complete as one of the element reached
its actual position
two more rounds of the comparisons will
occur till the array becomes sorted
it is because for n elements the number
of comparison are n minus 1.
so number of comparisons here would be 3
as the elements are 4 in numbers
now coming to selection sort
in this selection sort technique the
smallest element is fetched by comparing
itself with the rest of the elements
and is sorted at the first position of
the array
once the first element is sorted the
search for second minimum element begins
from the rest of the array and is
positioned at the second place
similarly one by one all the elements
are positioned like this
so this is selection sort now moving to
insertion sort technique
in this sorting technique the elements
are sorted by comparing the second
element with the first element
if the second element is smaller than
the first then we will swap it after
that we will compare the third element
with all the elements that are before it
similarly it goes for the fourth element
and so on
once all the comparisons are done the
elements becomes sorted
as we can see in the figure
so this was insertion sort technique
next is quick sort technique or quick
sort algorithm
quick sort algorithm is one of the most
widely used algorithm and the most
efficient sorting algorithm
the quick sort algorithm follows a
divide and conquer approach
in this approach a pivot element is
selected and the array is partitioned
into two halves on the basis of this
pivot element
the elements that are smaller than the
pivot element are shifted to the left
side of it and the elements greater than
the pivot element are shifted to the
right side of it
after this both the left and the right
sub arrays are sorted and combined
for example
let's suppose we have six elements
5 15 1 8 22 and 6 and we want to sort
them using quick sort so first of all we
will select any pivot element let's say
6.
now we will divide the array to two sub
arrays based on the pivot element in
such a way that the element smaller than
the pivot element are on the left and
the elements greater than the pivot
element are on the right as you can see
in the figure element smaller than 6 are
on the left and elements greater than 6
around the right
now we will sort both of these sub
arrays separately
we will select a pivot element from each
of the sub array
like we can see
from the first sub array we have
selected five and the second sub array
we have selected 15.
similarly if the element is less than
the pivot element then adjust it on the
left otherwise on the right
by doing this both the sub arrays will
become sorted and now we can combine
them to become a complete sorted array
so this is how quick sort algorithm
works
so as we have understood about the
Sorting technique now let's understand
how to sort using C plus plus Library
we can sort using the C plus plus
Library as well to use that Library
function we must include the hash
include algorithm header file
this function Compares each and every
element within the range
the syntax of function is sort then
within the brackets there will be the
starting iterator and the ending
iterator
and we must include this algorithm
header file with hash include which is a
preprocessor
so as we have understood about these
sorting algorithms so let's move to our
code editor that is vs code to do some
examples on this sorting algorithms
all right so this is our code editor and
here we will do some examples of sorting
techniques so let's first of all create
a new file
and let's name it
sort 1 dot CTP
so let's add first of all the header
file hash include IO stream
absolutely
then the namespace standard
so first of all we will do an example of
bubble sort algorithm
and
now we'll create a main function inside
the main function we will create some
variables let's say int I int J and a
temporary variable
temp
after that we will declare an array here
are and let's say the size of the array
is 8.
and the elements of array are
12
let's say 3 1
5.
18 and
10
7
and 35.
so these are the elements of the array
now we will display these elements so
we'll
display a message unsorted array as we
know that these array elements are
unsorted so we'll print the message
unsorted
with selection
all right
now
we'll
write the for Loop in I equals 0 that
runs from i 0 to I8 because you want to
print the array
I less than equal to 8 I less than 8
I plus plus
now here we will print the array
ARR
I so one by one all the elements will
get printed
and we'll add the slash T to add the
horizontal space between each element
all right
now
for space we will right we can write
handle
now we will write the logic for bubble
sort as we know in bubble sort the
swapping is done starting from the first
two elements and if the element on the
left is greater than the element on the
right then the swapping is done
so we'll do that
we'll write a for Loop
which runs from i0 to 8. and I equals 0
I less than 8.
I plus plus
and
the second for Loop would be
int J equals I plus 1
J less than 8
J plus plus
now I'll explain both of these loops
but before that let us just write the if
condition for swapping if ARR
Ive
I
is less than
ARR
J
oh
I Write the opposite of that which I
have to write let's make it I yeah if
ARR of J is less than a r of I then
we'll do the swap so now I'll explain
this part
here when I is at 0 then J is at 0 plus
1 that is at index 1. so now comparison
will take place between element and
index 1 and element at index 0. if the
right element that is index 1 element is
smaller than the left element that is
index 0 element then swapping will take
place and similarly one by one each
element is compared with the next
element and it will proceed till the end
of the array
so now here we will write the swapping
logic
we will store the first variable into
the temporary variable
and then we will store the second
variable into array of I
then will again store
into array of J
the value holded by the temporary
variable
all right so this is how swapping is
done
now all we need to do is to just print
the array elements because it
because we have to show the sorted
elements of the array so we'll first
display a message
sorted elements
all right
and then we'll use slash n as well
now here again we will use the for Loop
and which runs from i 0 to i8
is less than 8.
I plus plus
and now we will print the elements of
the array of sorted array
just to add the horizontal space we can
write slash t
and now
after that return zero
let's save it and let's hope it will
work
so as we can see this is the unsorted
array 12315 18 10 7 35 and this is a
sorted elements of the array 1 3 5 7 10
12 18 35 so as you can see these
elements are sorted and using the slash
D we have added the space between each
of these elements
all right now let's do another example
so now let's do an example of insertion
sort first of all let's save it and
let's name it as
sort
2 dot CPP
now let's add the head files
hash include our stream
then write the namespace standard
then we'll start with the main function
into Main
now we will write the variables like
and I int J and
num variable then the temp variable
temporary variable
and we'll also initialize the array
let's
make it 30 size
now we'll take the input from the user
so
right enter the elements
enter the number of elements first of
all
right
we'll take the input
as num
and then
we'll ask the user
to enter the
elements
all right now
using for Loop
sorry
using for loop I
equals to zero
till I less than num
I plus plus
we will take the input
of the elements of the array one by one
so
num is the size of the array so one by
one all the elements will the user will
enter all the elements
all right after that
all right now we'll write the code for
insertion sort
please keep in mind in insertion sort
we start by comparing the second element
with the first element if the second
element is smaller than the first
element then we will swap it after that
we will compare the third element with
all the elements that are before it
similarly it goes for the fourth element
and so on
we can see this figure for reference and
now we'll start doing the code
we'll start by writing the for Loop
which starts from 0
till num minus 1.
less than I plus plus all right after
that
we will store the array in the temporary
variable
once it's done
then we'll write j i minus 1.
first of all we have copied the elements
of array to the temp variable then we
have set J equals to I minus 1 because
we have to compare it with the previous
element
and
all right now we'll write the while loop
Okay so
temp is less than a r r of
J plus 1
okay
now only J
and for termination J must be greater
than zero
all right let's
make them inside the brackets
all right now
first of all let's write the code then
and I'll explain the part
Arrow J plus 1
area of G
we will move this element forward and
then we'll write
J minus 1 will decrement it
then
you have to insert the element in this
place
all right
I'll explain this part in this part we
have copied the elements of array to the
temp variable first of all and then we
have set J equals to I minus 1 because
we have to compare it with one previous
element
and while in while loop we are checking
if the value of element prior to array
of J is more or less
if it is less than we moves the element
in order
set it to the right position
using array of J plus 1 equals to Temp
we are actually inserting the element in
a proper place
over the right position
we are validating that J remains greater
than equal to 0.
so this is how it's done and now we have
to print the elements
so now we have to print the sorted
element so we will write the message
will display the message so sorted
elements
and then using the for Loop
you will display all the elements one by
one
I plus plus
error
inside it will write I
and
will add some space
once it's done then all is left is to
write return zero
return zero now let's save it
once it is saved then now let's check
if it is running fine or not
as we can see enter the number of
elements in the array let's say there
are five elements
right
eight
one
four
nine
two
all right eight one four nine two so
our output is wrong let's check
by where it is
I less than equal to
this is the problem let's save it
and let's check it once more
five
now
eight five seven
two
six
eight two five six seven
all right now I get it actually we are
checking from the first element so we
have to start with the first index
now let's save it
and try one more time
and five
nine
five eight
two
and let's say 12.
2589 12. so finally our output is
correct
because of some logical mistakes our
output was getting wrong but now we
finally can see that two five eight nine
twelve the elements of the array are
finally sorted and this is how you can
do insertion sort
now after this we'll do another example
all right now let's do an example of
selection sort
let's name it as sort 3.
CBB so let's understand the selection
sorting Technique One More Time in this
technique the smallest element is
fetched by comparing itself with the
rest of the element and is sorted at the
first position of the array
after the first element is positioned
the search for the second element begins
from the rest of the array and is
position and the second place similarly
all other elements are positioned like
this as we can see in the figure
now let's do its practical
implementation
so let's start by adding the header
files
hash include iostream
then we'll write the username space
standard
now we'll start with the main function
all right so first of all we'll declare
some variables like int I
and J
and num variable
then
a variable p
and a temporary variable temp
and we also need a minimum variable
we'll name it Main
and now we will declare the array
let's make it of size 10 and yeah
now
we will display a message saying that
enter the number of elements
we'll write enter
the number of
elements
all right
now we will take the input
see in Num
now we'll ask them to enter the elements
so we'll write slash n
enter the
elements
all right now again we will use slation
once it's done now we can take the input
of the array
so we'll start with end I equals 0 I
less than num
I plus plus
and now C in
array ARR
index I
so yeah
now we can take the input from the user
and now we have to do the actual part
that is the selection sort we have to
sort the array using the selection sort
technique
so let's start
we'll write a for Loop and I equals 0
I less than num minus 1
.
I plus plus
inside this Loop we will store the value
of the first element of the array
Min equals ARR of I we are showing the
first element of array into this main
variable
so here we are storing the value now we
have to store the index
so the P variable which we have declared
and we are storing the
index I to this P variable
all right after that we have to use
another for Loop
where the actual comparisons begins
no we will write
J
equals to I plus 1
and
J less than num
J plus plus
now I'll explain you this for Loop
in this for Loop we are doing I plus 1
because here the comparison will take
place and the comparison will occur with
the preceding elements
so we have to do J equals to I Plus 1.
now we have to do inside this for Loop
we'll use a if condition so we'll write
if
minimum is greater than array of J
that if
that is
if any element is smaller than the
minimum element then that particular
element will be set as minimum element
so we'll do that right Min equals
array of I array of J sorry
and we also have to change the index so
we'll assign the index of J to the P
earlier we have assigned the index I to
P but if that particular element is
smaller than the minimum element then we
also have to assign the index to p
now all we need to do is to swap
so now let's do the swap pink part as
well
all right
so first of all the temporary variable
temp we will assign ARR of I
we have to swap error of high and ARR of
P because the index J is assigned to p
and we all know how to do the swapping
if I
now we will
put the value of here of P into a R5
thank you
now the value at temp goes to error of P
so the swapping is done here and now we
have to just print the sorted array
so now let's first of all display a
message saying that the sorted elements
are
right slash in
sorted elements
are
slashing again
Now using for Loop we will print all
those elements
equals zero
I less than n
um sorry I plus plus
all right now we will just print the
array
and now in order to give some space
we'll use the double quotes
now it's done
now return 0 will write
now everything is done now let's check
if it is working or not
it's done by our end so let's save it
and
let's try to run
enter the number of elements so okay so
let's add five
now five elements are eight
one five
sorry
one
five
three
seven
one three five seven eight as you can
see
these are the sorted elements and this
is correct
so this is how we can do the selection
sort this is our logic behind the
selection sort
you can try this example as well
all right now we'll do an example of
quick sort so first of all
let's create a new file
and name it as sort4.cpp
now as we know in quick sort follows the
divide and conquer algorithm so let's
have a look at it
as we know in quicksort our pivot
element is selected like here we have
selected six other pivot element and
then the elements which are smaller than
6 are put on the left side and elements
which are greater than 6 are shifted to
the right side and similarly same thing
is done with the partitions or the sub
arrays and in the end when we combine we
get a sorted array so now practical
implementation so first of all we'll
start by creating a main function and
before that we'll add the header files
hash include myostream
and the namespace standard
all right now we'll start with the main
function
inside the main function we will
declare a variable num and another
variable I
and
declare an array ARR to size let's say
10
now we'll display a message saying that
enter the number of elements
foreign s
all right now
here it is now we will take the input
from the user
num
now we'll display another message saying
that enter the elements
and now we'll use for Loop
to take the input from the user
I equals 0 I less than
num I plus plus
so inside this Loop C in and arri will
take the input from the user
user enters all the digits or the
elements
now we will call a function quick
and we'll pass the arguments array and
the starting index and the ending index
the starting index would be zero
and any index would be num minus 1 that
is size minus 1.
so this is where we are calling the
quick function and after that we can
display a message saying that
after sorting
the elements are
foreign
loop again
we can display the sorted array
afterwards
and add some space
yes
and we'll write return zero so our main
function is done now all we need to do
is to make the quick function
all right so let's create this quick
function
quick
and it's data type would be void quite
quick and we'll pass the
the arguments all the parameters are
array and the starting index and the
ending index
start
and and
so these are the parameters and inside
this quick function
will write the if condition that is if
start of the index is less than n that
is if the array element is more than one
then
here we will find the point of division
D and then there would be recursive
calls for the divided sub arrays or the
partitions
so now
we will make the division Point d
and now we'll call the function divide
and we'll pass the parameters array and
the starting index and the ending index
to this function as well
so here
D is the division point and by calling
this function we'll find this division
point
after that we will do the recursive call
for the left sub array and the right sub
array
so let's do that
quick
array in starting index and ending index
but here ending index would be as it is
a sub array as it is the left sub array
so the division point is the point of
division so the ending index for the
left sub array would be D minus 1.
and similarly now again we'll call for
the right sub array
here's the starting index would be D
plus one
and ending index would be
end
let me explain this part again
the first recursive call would be from
start
to D minus 1
and the second recursive call from is
from D plus 1 to the end
so these are the two sub arrays this is
the right sub array and this one is the
left sub array so D minus 1 is this
element and D plus 1 is this element
all right now we'll make this divide
function
and we have to make this divide function
above the quick function otherwise it
will show an error or if you don't want
to do that then you can do the forward
declaration but I'll prefer doing this
only
so
print is the data type divide is the
name
and now
int ARR
as we have passed the starting index
and the
sorry the starting index
and the ending index
all right
now inside this divide function first of
all we will set a pivot element
foreign
we always usually select the last
element as pivot element or you can
select the first element as well or any
random element
now
we'll create another variable int index
and
will assign its start index now this
variable will keep the track of elements
in the array starting from all first
element and all these elements so
now
we'll use a for Loop and now we will do
the comparison with the pivot element so
inside the for Loop int I equals 0
sorry int I equals start because we'll
start from the first element so I equals
start I less than and we will not use
less than equal to we'll use I less than
n because we don't want to include the
pivot element
so that is why we'll use I less than end
and now I plus plus
all right
all right now inside this for Loop we
will create if condition now in this
condition if the array of I
is less than the pivot element then we
will shift it towards the left then
we'll do the swapping
arri
is less than
pivot
then
temporary variable temp and we all know
how to do the swapping
so we'll do that
arri index
please note that index is storing the
start and pivot is storing the end
to keep in mind that now
ARR
index
this temporary variable
now we will increment this index plus
plus because this index plus plus will
do the further comparison with pivot
element
so if
that particular element is smaller than
the pivot element then it will move to
the left side otherwise on the right
side
all right now it's done now the only
thing left is the positioning of the
pivot element
and to do that because we have to find
the partitioning point so we have to
position the pivot element at its proper
place so for that we'll use the
temporary variable again
and
ARR
and index
then
we'll swap it
with index
so here we are done with the swapping
now we have found the partitioning point
so we will return the index now the
pivot is at its proper position now all
the elements on the left side of the
pivot element are smaller than that and
all the elements on the right side of it
are greater than that
now let's try to save it and run it
I hope it works
there are some errors let's check
all right
all right let's do it
and this one is
this one is extra
all right now let's save it and run it
enter the number of elements let's say
we have entered five not that place
five elements
three one nine five
seven
one three five seven nine
so this is our sorted elements of the
array and we have done it using the
quick sort method or the algorithm
and this is our code
and this is a logic behind the quick
sort method
you can also practice this quick sort
algorithm it is one of the most
efficient sorting algorithm
and we have done the examples of bubble
sort selection sort insertion sort and
quick sort you can practice them all
today's topic is pointers in C plus plus
and in today's session we will learn
about what is a pointer reference and D
reference operator
then declaration and initialization of a
pointer then there is pointer arithmetic
and after that we'll go through pointers
and functions pointers and arrays and at
last we have arrays open so let's go to
our first topic that is what is a
pointer pointer can be defined as a
variable that contains the address of
another variable it basically stores the
memory address which means it points to
an address of a particular value
and like a regular variable pointers
have a data type also now coming to
reference and D reference operators
reference operator or address of
operator is defined as that operator
which is used to get the address of the
variable
it can be easily obtained by preceding
the name of the variable within
Ampersand sign
now D reference operator D reference
operator basically Returns the content
stored in the variable pointed by the
specified pointer
for example if we write asterisk a then
it will return the value of variable
pointed by a now let's see how to
declare and initialize a pointer to
declare a pointer first of all we will
write the data type
after that we will write the name of the
variable with an asterisk sign for
example int asterisk sign a float
asterisk B care asterisk C
suppose if we want to store the address
into a pointer
then we will write int that is the data
type then PTR that is the name of the
pointer
with an asterisk sign equals to a
variable a with Ampersand sign which
means PTR will contain the address of
the variable a
now moving to a pointer arithmetic
C plus plus allows us to perform
addition and subtraction operations on
pointers a pointer is basically an
address that is it's a numeric value
therefore operations like addition
subtraction can easily be done on
pointers
there are four types of arithmetic
operations that can be used in pointers
that is increment Operator decrement
Operator addition and subtraction
each time a pointer is incremented by
one it points to the memory location of
the next element
but if the pointer is an integer pointer
its value on PTR plus plus would
increment by 4 bytes because of the size
of in data type for example assume an
integer pointer with current value of
10.
now after the increment its value would
be 14 instead of 11 because int is of 4
bytes now let's learn about pointers and
functions
like a normal variable has an address
similarly every function has an address
also and we can easily access the
function using its reference or address
only if we know the address of the
function
function pointers are similar to that of
normal pointers when pointers are passed
to the function the address of actual
arguments in the calling function is
copied into the formal arguments of the
called function
and this is the Syntax for a declaration
of function pointer
here int is the return type and
parenthesis around function pointer
tells the compiler that it is a pointer2
function and after this they are
argument lists now let's discuss
pointers and arrays
arrays and pointers are very closely
related to each other and both of them
are objects
when an array gets declared the compiler
assigns a continuous block of memory so
that all the elements of an array can be
stored in the memory
and C plus plus treats the name of the
array as a pointer that contains the
address of first element
which is known as Base address so
basically array name is the Base address
of the array
and if we have to sign the address of
first element of array in a variable X
then instead of writing x equal to
Ampersand array of 0 we can simply write
the name of the array only now moving to
the last topic that is array of pointers
like in Array we can store similar type
of elements it is same in case of array
of pointers but the only difference is
instead of storing the elements the
address of similar type of element is
stored
in other words it stores the pointers
which point to the similar data type
and this is the syntax first is data
type then name of array with an asterisk
sign then in the brackets it is the size
of array now let's do some examples in
our code editor that is vs code if
getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
here we will do one example of pointer
to understand reference and D reference
operator
we will print the values of variable and
the address of that variable also and it
will give us an idea about reference and
reference operator
let's start first of all we'll make a
new file
and name this file as
pointer1.cpt
so first of all we will import the
header file
stream
now we will include namespace template
after that we'll make int Main
and now we will declare a variable
well
and assign it a value let's say 105.
now we will declare a pointer variable
PTR
now we will store the address of the
variable well into the pointer variable
so we will write PTR equals
Ampersand well
now
will display a message
before printing well variable will
display a message saying
value is
value of Val is
now let's see what is the value of PTR
for that we will have to print PTR also
and we'll write
foreign
PTR
is
now we will print the pointer variable
PTR also
although the value of Val and PTR would
be same but in order to check we will
print that also
so we'll write
C out
value of
music PTR
is
now as we have printed variable Val
PTR and asterisk PTR so now let's check
all these values
next question we will write return 0.
now let's check all these values
here we can see value of variable Val is
105.
and the value of PTR is this this is
actually the address
and the value of pointer variable PTR is
105 as we know that the value of VL and
the pointer variable is same because we
have assigned this value the address of
variable well to PTR
and then the D reference operator
as we know Returns the actual content of
the variable so that is why the value of
variable well gets printed when we print
the pointer variable PTR
and the address over here
is the address of the Val variable which
we are assigning to the PTR
so that is why this address is getting
printed
now we'll do another example let's name
it
pointer 2.0 CPP
now we'll include the header files
hash include our stream
after that using namespace standard
so here we have an example of arithmetic
operations in C plus plus so first of
all we'll write int Main
now here we will take four variables and
two pointers
so let's do it
and num1
command number two
and
sum equals zero and end sub
equals 0 will initialize it with zero
now I will declare the pointers
ptr1
ptr2
so let's take input of the required
variables num1 and num2 and after that
we'll do some mathematic operations on
them
so let's just write
first we'll display a message
enter two numbers
enter
two numbers
now we'll take the input
after this we will store the address of
num1 and num2 into ptr1 and ptr2
respectively let's do it
ptr1
ampersand
number one
ptr2
ampersand num2
now we will increment pointer ptr1 and
ptr2
we'll do in a bracket and we'll use D
reference operator also
pkr1 plus plus
operator
etr2
plus plus
here we are using D reference operator
because we want to increment the value
only
and as we can see we have used increment
operator so by incrementing ptr1 and
ptr2 the values of num1 and num2 will
increment and after that we will print
those values
so let's do it
before printing we'll just print a
message
after increment
foreign
ptr1
and line
now ptr2
now we will do the sum of these
incremented values so we will write some
equals
D reference operator PTR one
Plus
D reference operator ptr2
now we will simply print it
write addition
and we'll print some variable
which we have already initialized as 0
earlier
and we'll write and line
so this will give us the sum of the
incremented values of num1 and num2
now let's talk about decrementing the
value of pointers using decrement
operator
hereby using this operator the value of
the ptr1 and ptr2 gets decremented so
let's start
document ptr1
minus minus
that is the decrement operator
now
ptr2
and S minus
now we will write
after decrement
the values of ptr1 and ptr2
so we'll display a message saying
after decrement
now we will print ptr1 and ptr2
this will display the values of ptr1 and
ptr2 after decrement
and at last we will find the subtraction
of 2.
so we'll write sub
ment operator ptr1 minus decrement
operator ptr2
and C out
will display first subtraction will
write subtraction
then we'll write the variable sub
let's see how it before that I think
before going to mention the D reference
operator
while printing
we have to mention this because we want
to print the values
the reference operator
and let's put some space over here
now let's try
enter two numbers so let's say We'll
enter four
and five
as you can see we have entered four and
five after increment it becomes 5 and 6
and on addition it becomes 11 after
decrement it becomes 4 and 5 again
then 4 minus 5 that is equal to minus 1
so this is the right answer and this is
how it's done this was the basic example
of arithmetic operations in pointers
now let's do another example
name this file as pointer3.cpp
now we will include the header files
hash include
by your stream
using namespace standard
now we'll write int Main
now we will do an example of pointer and
arrays in which all we have to do is to
print an array with the help of pointers
so let's start
first of all we will declare a pointer
now we'll declare an array
named Rory
and let's add some elements inside it
five
17
[Music]
sorry 20
7.
9
fourth six
I think these are seven elements
now we will assign array ARR to pointer
PTR so we'll write PTR equals ARR
after that we'll run a loop from I equal
to 0 to I less than 7 because we want to
iterate array elements so let's write
for Loop and I equals 0 I less than 7 I
plus plus
now we will display
using D reference operator with pointer
because we want to display the values
that is why we have used the reference
operator
now we'll do
PTR plus plus
we have used PTR plus plus because we
want the pointer to move to the next
position after each iteration
and endl will help to print the output
in the next line after each iteration
so after this we'll write
return 0.
and let's try to run it
I think there is some error
yeah
namespace
now let's again try to run it
um instead of array we have used ARR
hope it works now
here it is
27946
5 17 20 7 9 4 6. so these are our array
Elements which you want to print so this
is how we can print the array elements
with the help of pointer
so these were some basic examples of
pointers in C plus plus in this session
we will learn about this pointer in C
plus plus
so let's go ahead and have a look at
what we'll be covering today
so in this session we will cover topics
like what is this pointer
then we will have a look at the syntax
of this pointer
then we will understand the working of
this pointer and after that we will
learn how to access the executing object
using this keyword
and we will also learn about the
features of this pointer
but before we begin make sure to
subscribe to our Channel and hit the
Bell icon to never miss an update
so first topic is what is this pointer
in C plus plus this is a keyword that is
used to represent an object that invokes
the member functions
it automatically points to the object
for which the object is being called
or in other words this keyword points to
the current instance or object of the
class
for example let us suppose we have a
local variable of same name as that of
the data member and we want to assign
the value of a local variable to the
data member but having the same name
would create a problem
so in this type of case we use this
pointer
this keyword tells the compiler that we
are referring to objects data members
now let's learn about the syntax of this
pointer
the Syntax for referee class variable or
instance variable would be this keyword
then Arrow operator with class variable
equal to local variable value
and the Syntax for reference to current
object of class would be this with
asterisk sign or D reference operator
sign
now let's understand working of this
pointer
that this keyword represents the address
of current instance of the class
that this pointer acts as an implicit
parameter to all the member functions
now implicit parameters are similar to
normal parameters
the only difference is these parameters
are passed silently to the functions
that is it is passed as a hidden
argument and is automatically passed to
the member function when it is called
now let's learn how to access the
executing object
as we can see in the example we have
created an object obj of class o
and with the help of this object we have
called this function display in which we
are printing the address of the object
and we are also printing this pointer
and this is the executing object so by
printing this we will get the address of
object in the memory
along with this we can also access the
data members using this keyword
all right now let's move to features of
this pointer
the first feature would be to
distinguish the data members from local
variables which means it helps in making
the class members more readable by
differentiating the members of the class
and the parameters which have the same
name
this keyword helps in differentiating
between the class variable and the
parameters
as we can see in the example we are
assigning the where variable which is a
parameter to the class member where and
this can only be done with the help of
this pointer
now let's move to the next feature that
is
method chaining in C plus plus
method chaining in C plus plus is a very
useful feature of this pointer it helps
to chain methods together for ease and
cleaner code
in this each method returns an object
and allows the code to be changed
together into a single statement
it helps in invoking multiple methods
that are chained together as we can see
in the example set method replace method
and Inc method are chained together in a
single statement
and arguments are also passed if getting
your learning started is half the battle
what if you could do that for free visit
scale up by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
so now let's go ahead and do some
examples of this pointer in our code
editor that is vs code
all right so here we will do an example
of this pointer in which we will show
that how this pointer differentiates
between the class member and the
parameters having the same name
so let's go ahead and first of all let's
create a new file
and let's name it
this
one dot CPP
all right now we can write the header
files
hash include iostream
now we'll write the namespace standard
now we'll start with the main function
we'll write int Main
inside int main first of all we will
write the class name and then the object
of that class let's say obj
now
let's write return 0 first of all
and now we can make some calls with this
object but before that let's create
class
so all right now we have to create a
class which has the name a as we know
the class name is a we have already
defined and the name of the object is
obj so let's create class
a
and inside that class we will inside the
private scope
we will declare some variables let's say
int X
y
and Z so these three are the variables
now
sorry
spelling is wrong in Z so these three
are the variables now inside the public
scope
we will create a function let's say the
name of the function is set
so data type is void name of the
function is set
and
from the main function we will call this
set function
so all we need to do is we'll write the
name of the object obj dot operators
set which is the name of the function
and we will pass the arguments let's say
20
54 and 65.
these are random numbers
now
here we will write
int X
and Y internet
as we can see the parameters and the
class members have the same name
so variables are of same name
so for that we know that we have to
write this
pointer
so
we will write
this
X
so here
this x is the parameter one and this x
is the class variable
this pointer differentiates between both
of them
as the name is same so this will help in
differentiating
we'll do the same for y
and we'll do same for X this Arrow
operator
Z equals to Z
so here we are assigning the values to
these class members
now after that we will display these
values so let's create another function
let's say the name of the function is
void print
all right so inside this function we'll
simply display these variables
so we'll write
x value is
the small One X
x value
is
the variable X and after that we will
write handle
right
y value is
y
handle
we'll do same for Z you can copy it
and just paste it
will save some time
all right as we have displayed or
printed all of these three variables so
as the class ends so we need to add the
semicolon in the end
now
this print function we need to call this
one
so with obj object we will call this
print function
all right
so after calling this we have already
added return zero so let's save this one
and try to run it
all right let's check
here it is x value is 20.
y value is 54 and Z value is 65. so
Arrow operator helped us in
differentiating between the class
members and the parameters what if we
don't use this
let's
have a look at that as well
if we do not use this
pointer
then let's save it and let's try to run
this
let's check the output as you can see x
value is 0 y value 0 Z value zero it is
not correct so
this one is right and this is our output
correct output now let's do another
example
so here we will do an example and see
that the
this pointer can be used for calling the
member function as well
so we will do an example regarding that
so first of all let's name this
this two dot CPP
let's save it and we'll start with hash
include iostream
now the namespace standard
we'll start with int Main
inside int main we will name the class
and create the object obj
class name is king and the object name
is obj
so from here we will call a function
let's say obj dot
let's say the name of the function is
text
here we are calling and let's say return
0 after this
now we have to create this class
so let's create this class
King and inside this class King
inside the public scope
we will declare the functions
first of all we'll declare a function
call
and now we will Define a function
that is text
so inside this text function all we need
to do is to print a message
and call another function
so first of all we will print a text or
a message let's say thank you
hello brother
so after that
we'll write handle
now we will call another
not C out we will call this function
call which we have declared and not
defined yet so we will write this
Arrow operator
c a l call
this is how you can call using this
pointer and here we are calling this
call function
so
we'll close the class using semicolon
and now
inside the class scope let's say
avoid King scope resolution operator
this means that this function is
of class King
so
now we will print whatsoever we want
let's say
okay is
will display a text
let's say a
and that's it
then we'll do the same for
B and C
here we will print B and now we'll print
C
all right now all we need to do
and everything is done yeah because we
have created this function outside so we
don't have to use this semicolon now we
can save this
and we can try to run this
here we can see uh hello brother and ABC
so this is what we want to print here we
can see we have used this pointer to
call this call function
and after printing this hello brother a
b and c is getting printed so this means
this is the correct output
now let's do another example
let's make a new file and save this one
let's name it this three dot CBP
all right so here now we will do an
example of method chaining as we know we
use method chaining when we want to
return the reference of the object
and Method chaining help us in writing a
clean code as it chains up the calling
together into a single statement so
let's start
first of all we'll include the header
file
hash include iostream
now
write the namespace standard
now I'll write the main function
foreign
all right
now inside the main function first of
all we write the name of the class that
is test
and we'll create the object the name of
the object would be in N1
now we will chain up the calls let's say
the name of the object N1
and the name of the function let's say
is assign
and we are passing 100. and now we'll
chain up display function with it
so this is Method chaining now
we'll write it on zero
and now we'll start with the class
so
class name is test
and inside the class we will declare a
variable let's say
num
and
foreign
public scope
we will write the function and will not
Define the function in a usual way we'll
write the data type first of all let's
say test is the data type
address of operator
assign which is the name of the function
and
argument would be num the parameter
would be num
and inside this function
we'll use this
Arrow operator
and now we will assign
the value of
parameter num to the class variable
after that we can return reference to
the object we'll use the D reference
operator
and this pointer
now
we will make another function that is
display and inside this display function
will print a message
and we'll print the variable that is
done
so first of all we'll print the message
saying that
the value
of num
is
all right after the class we'll put a
semicolon
and we'll try to run this one
after saving it
so as you can see
the value of num is 100. so let's do
some modifications in that let's say we
want to add 1000
so it will get added we need to save it
first
now I'll try to run
as you can see the value of num is now
1100
so these are chain function calls and
when the reference is returned this
reference is returned then this
reference can be used to change the
function calls from a single object that
is N1 in this case so this is the data
type and this is the address of operator
when we are doing the method chain we
must do it like this and then we will
return the reference to the object
so these were some examples of this
pointer in C plus plus you can try some
more examples if you want to learn this
topic in a much better way
in this video we will learn about
references in C plus plus
so let's go ahead and have a look at
what we'll be covering today
so we will learn what our references in
C plus plus then the creation of
references
after that we will learn about reference
in the function and returning the
reference from the function
next we will have a look at the
applications of references and
understand the difference between
reference and pointer
but before we begin make sure to
subscribe to our Channel and press the
Bell icon to never miss an update
so first is what are references in C
plus
a reference can be defined as an
alternative name of the variable
as the name suggests it is used to refer
to an existing variable
it is basically used to store the
reference of the variable and is stored
using an ampersand sign
although the reference and address are
the same thing but their context is
different
when we are talking about reference
variable then we will call it reference
rather than address
the variable can either be accessed with
the help of variable name or by the
reference name
so as we have understood about
references in C plus plus so now let's
learn how to create reference in C plus
let's suppose we have a variable named
data
and we know how to declare a variable
first its data type then the variable
name and then we will assign the value
to the variable
here int is the data type
data is the variable name and 10 is the
value that is assigned to the variable
if we want to declare a reference
variable for the variable data then it
would be like this
first is the data type
with Ampersand sign then the name of the
reference variable equals to the
variable name of which we are storing
the reference of
as you can see int Ampersand ref
which is the name of the reference
variable equals to data which is the
name of the variable
so we can say ref is the reference
variable for the data variable and it
can be used instead of the variable name
now coming to reference in the function
we can pass the reference to the
function as a parameter
it is similar to passing the pointers to
the function but it is safer
while passing the reference to the
function the changes made inside the
function will also be reflected outside
because after passing the reference to
the function the past reference will
access the actual argument
so the changes that are done to the
parameter inside the function will
affect the arguments
in addition it is safer and provides a
cleaner code
to pass the value as reference all we
need to do is to change the function
parameter as reference type
as you can see in the calculation
function int Ampersand a
now let's learn about returning the
reference in C plus plus
similar to pointers references can also
be returned
while returning the reference an
implicit pointer is also returned
in return by reference
no local variable is returned and no
constant is returned only the global
variable is returned
in return by reference function calling
is done on the left hand side of the
assignment operator
as you can see in the example n is
returned from the function but it is not
the value that we are returning but the
address of the variable
when this variable is returned then the
value 15 is assigned to it
which is then printed as we can see in
the example
now coming to Applications of references
in C plus plus okay so first is
references helps in modifying or
changing the values inside the function
without actually passing the actual
arguments because we can easily pass the
reference instead of variable and if we
pass the reference to the function then
also it can modify or change the values
second is references helps with operator
overloading because unlike pointers they
work with references and values rather
than pointer variables
third is references helps with writing
less error prone code and by replacing
values with references while calling
avoids the unnecessary copy of data
so these were some applications of
references in C plus plus
now let's understand the difference
between reference and pointer
the reference can be defined as an alias
of the variable
here the word Alias means additional
name or we can say also known for the
name
on the other hand a pointer is used to
store the memory address of the variable
reference cannot have a null value
whereas pointers can have a null value
references cannot be reassigned to other
values whereas pointers can be
reassigned to other values
it Returns the reference of the variable
on the other hand pointer Returns the
value located at the address of the
variable
reference can be initialized during its
creation only it cannot be
re-initialized whereas pointer can be
initialized as many times as required
so these were some differences between
reference and pointer
now let's go ahead and do some examples
of reference in C plus plus in our code
editor that is vs code
all right so here we will do an example
of Return by reference in C plus plus we
all know how to return a value from a
function
so now we will understand how can we
return a reference from the function
all right so let's start
first of all create a new folder and
let's save it
and name it as
ref1
dot CPP
now we will save it all right so first
of all we'll include the header files
and then we'll start with the main
function
hash include iostream
and then the namespace standard
now let's start with the main function
inside the main function
first of all like normally we'll do for
the functions we'll call
let's name the function as Club
so this is how we normally call a
function
and
after that we create a function like
this
like
int
club and
then this is how normal calling works
but in this case we want this function
to return the reference and for that we
have to use the Ampersand sign
so we have used this Ampersand sign and
this is a syntax int which is the data
type then the Ampersand sign then the
name of the function and if we want to
pass any arguments then we can do that
and keep in mind that inside this
function we cannot return any local
variable or any constant like we cannot
return we cannot create a variable
inside this function assign it some
value and then return it we can't do
that and we can only return the global
variable
let me show you that we cannot return
this return 8 as this is a constant and
we can't do like this like
in
P equals to 9
and then we will return it
return P we can't do like this as well
all we need to do is to create a global
variable and then we will return
all right so let's create a global
variable
let's say the global variable is n
and
so we'll return n
now if we want to assign some value to
This Global variable we have to call
this club function
and we have to make this calling on the
left hand side of the assignment
operator
like this
and now we have to assign the value like
let's say the value is 75.
so here we are assigning the value and
calling this reference operator we are
assigning the value to This Global
variable this and Global variable and in
this part we are actually assigning this
75 value to This Global variable n
now we can print this n variable which
is global and check if its value is 75
or not
all right so let's save it and let's try
to run this
as you can see 75
so this is an example of Return by
reference in Z Plus now let's move on to
another example
all right now
all right we know a reference cannot be
reassigned that also means a single
reference cannot refer to two different
values
but two different references can have a
single value
or in other words a value can have two
different references
so in this example we will show how a
value can have two different references
so let's start doing this example first
of all we'll include the header files
hash include our stream
now the name speed standard
all right
now inside the main function we will
create a variable
and two different references
the variable is num and we will assign
it a value let's say 70.
and
we will create two different references
in
num1 N1
and
we will assign it to num
and
two
which is also signing to the same
variable so there are two references N1
and N2 which are referring to the same
variable num
so now we will print this variable num
and both of these reference variable
that is N1 and N2 to check if they are
pointing to the same value
so let's do this
we will write
C out
value of
num is
all right now
again
value of
reference
N1 is
and one
handle
similarly
value of
reference
and 2 is
N2
handle all right
so we have printed all of these
variables and references
and now return 0.
and let's check if there
running fine or not
as you can see value of num is 70 value
of reference N1 is 70 and N2 and 2
reference is 70. so we can say all of
these
references and variables are pointing to
the same value and the value of num can
also be accessed by these reference
variable N1 and N2
all right now let's do another example
let's name it ref
2 dot CPP
so here we will do an example of
references in C plus plus in which we
will pass the reference into the
function to swap the actual values
basically we don't pass the actual
arguments we only pass the references
and swap the values
so let's start
so let's include the header files
now we will create the main function and
inside the main function we will declare
two variables and assign the values
and Y
17 let's say
now we'll print first of all we'll print
before swapping right
foreign
afterwards
and we'll pass not the values but the
references
and then we can similarly
copy this one
and just paste it again
and we'll do that
after swapping
here we have to do before swiping right
so first of all we'll print the value of
X and Y before swapping then we will
print the values of X and Y after
swapping
so now we have to create the definition
or write the definition of swap function
so let's write wide swap and do remember
that here we are passing the references
not the values so we have to write like
this int ampersand
N1
this is how when we are passing the
values we have to write like this
and
ampersand
and two
here this N1 is referring to X and this
N2 is referring to y
and inside this swap function will
simply swap as we know how to swap int
temp equals N1
then we'll do N1 equals N2
we all know how to swap to here we
haven't passed the values actually we
have passed the reference and using
those references we are swapping the
values
so now let's try to run this
save it and
let's run this
as you can see before swapping x value
is 12 and Y value was 17 after swiping
17 and 12.
so as we can see clearly that the value
is swept
so we can say using the references by
passing the references to a function we
can actually swap the values so this
also proves that references can access
the values
so these were some examples of
references in C plus plus references in
C plus plus is a very simple topic and
there are very limited examples on this
topic and if you find some more examples
please do try them in today's session we
are going to learn about C plus plus
memory management
and do check out our other videos on the
C plus plus Series so let's go ahead and
have a look at what's in it for us
first is what is memory management then
we will understand why we need memory
management in C plus plus then we will
learn memory allocation and D allocation
in C plus plus using new operator and
delete operator and at last we will
understand the advantages of new
operator in C plus
so without further Ado let's get started
what is memory management memory
management can be defined as a process
in which management of a computer's
memory occurs for example assigning
memory to programs variables Etc in such
a way that it doesn't affect the overall
performance
sometimes the computer's data can range
up to terabytes
so efficient use of memory is necessary
so that we can minimize the memory
wastage and boost up the performance
now let's understand why we need memory
management in C plus plus
memory management is required so that
there will be no wastage of memory and
to make sure that allocation takes place
efficiently
during the Declaration of an array there
are times when the correct memory is not
determined until runtime
and to avoid such cases we usually
declare array of maximum size and
because of this maximum size some Memory
Remains unused
for example let us suppose we have
declared an array of size 30 and after
declaring the array it turns out that we
only need space of 10 size
so the rest of the space is of no use or
we can say it will get wasted
to avoid such cases we use memory
allocation
so let's understand memory allocation
and deallocation in Z Plus
other programming languages like Java
python Etc they don't need to allocate
memory dynamically
in C language we use the malloc or
Kellogg functions to allocate the memory
dynamically at runtime and these
functions are also supported by C plus
plus but in C plus plus allocation and
delocation is done manually
in C plus plus there are two operators
that are used for the allocation and
deallocation of memory that is new
operator and delete operator
so let's understand this new operator in
C plus plus
the new operator in C plus plus is used
for the dynamic memory allocation it is
used to allocate the memory at runtime
the general syntax of new operator is
pointer variable which is the name of
the pointer equal to new which is a
keyword and data type is the type of the
pointer
the Syntax for arrays is almost the same
but after the data type we have to write
the size inside the brackets which
specifies the number of elements in an
array
and here in the example we first of all
are declaring a pointer PTR of n data
type
after that we are dynamically allocating
the memory using new keyword and at last
we are assigning the value 75 to the
allocated memory
coming to the delete operator
the delete operator in C plus plus is
used for the deallocation of memory
when we no longer need to use the
variable that means the memory is no
longer required then we have to
deallocate or release the memory using
the delete operator
Syntax for delete operator is
delete keyword with the name of the
pointer variable
the Syntax for arrays is delete keyword
following the empty brackets and then
name a pointer variable
as you can see in the example once the
printing of value is done
we have deallocated the memory using the
delete operator
moving on to the advantages of new
operator
the new operator and delete operator can
be overloaded unlike the malloc function
next is a return type of the new
operator is of the same type for which
the memory was allocated we don't need
to use the typecasting
third is the new operator automatically
computes the size of data object we
don't need to use the size of operator
next is new operator in C plus plus
allows us to initialize object while
creating memory space for them
so these were some advantages of the new
operator
so now let's move on to our code editor
that is vs code to do some examples on
the new operator and delete operator
here we will do an example using new and
delete operator in C plus plus that will
allocate the memory location for three
values and find their average
so first of all
let's
create a file and name this file as
mm1.cpb
mm means memory management so now first
of all we'll include the header files
hash include iostream
Now using namespace standard
now we'll start within domain
okay
so first of all we'll create three
pointer variables
so we'll start
int
star ptr1
paint
star ptr2 we are creating three pointer
variables because we have to find the
sum of three variables so that is why we
have to create three pointers also
and
now we have to store the sum of three
variables into some another variables so
we now will create the variable average
okay
now we will allocate the memory
dynamically
using the new keyword so we'll write
ptr1 equals
new
end which is the data type
same we will do for ptr2
equals new keyword
hint
here we are allocating the memory
dynamically with the help of new keyword
new and
sorry m is there
now we will print the value that is
stored in the memory
but before doing that
as we have allocated the memory so now
we will take the input from the users of
those three variables
of which we have to find the average of
so
we'll display
enter first number
after displaying this
we'll take the input from the user write
C in
and using the D reference operator
write ptr1
here we are taking the input from the
user for the first memory location
now we'll take the input of the second
number from the user for that we have to
print the message again
enter the second number
yeah now
we'll take the input
using the dereference operator
with the pointer
now same goes for the third one
enter the
third number
the reference operator ptr3
as we have taken all the three numbers
from the user now all we have to do
is to find the average of these three
numbers as we know that D reference
operator will point to the variable
so that is how we'll get the access for
the variable now we'll write
the variable AVG that is average
we know that D reference operator will
display the value that is pointer
pointing at
so
we are actually adding the values
etr1
plus d reference operator ttr2
plus d reference operator ptr3
divided by 3
this is how we can find the average
after that
all we have to do is to print the
average
so we'll write
average is
AVG that is the variable
as the result is getting stored in this
variable AVG so we'll print that
variable and once everything is done
once the printing is then we have to
deallocate the memory
and we will deallocate the memory by
writing delete
ptr1
we have to do this for all of these
three pointers read ptr2
because we have allocated the memory for
all of these three pointers so that is
why we have to deallocate for each one
of them
okay now
everything is done and let's try to run
this
here we can see enter the first number
so let's say
five
we have to find the average of three
numbers so we'll select the easy number
to check whether it is right or wrong
then we'll write 5 again
now we'll write 2.
as we know this 5 plus 5 equals 10 plus
2 equals 12 and the average of 12 is 4
yeah 3 4S are 12. so this is the correct
output
so first of all we have allocated the
memory over here dynamically then we
have deallocated the memory using delete
ptr1 ptr2 and ptr3 so this is how it's
done
so let's do one another example
let's name this as
mm2.cpp
okay
we'll write mm4.cpp
I think 2 and 3 are already taken so
we'll start with hash include I have
stream
hash
include
i o stream
then we'll write using namespace
standard
so in this question we'll simply enter
the elements of the array and then we
will display those elements but we will
use new operator and delete operator in
this question
so let's start first of all we'll write
int Main
now inside int main first of all we'll
write the variable size we have declared
the variable size
and this variable size is the size of
the array which we will take as an input
from the user
so
first of all
will display
enter the size
enter the size
now we'll take the input
size
after that we will declare a pointer
variable
PTR
all right
now here we will allocate the memory for
the complete array so we'll write
PTR
new keyword
int
which is the data type and here size
okay here we are allocating the memory
for the complete array of size that we
will enter
okay now
now we will display
the message saying that enter the
elements
as we have allocated the memory now all
we have to do is to enter the elements
we'll use a for Loop
so we'll start with i equals 0
I less than size
I plus plus
now
we'll write
element
and after this we'll take the input from
the user
for the elements of the array so we'll
write C in
now just like Aries we can do it for the
pointer as well we can write PTR
and just like it is
inside the bracket I
and we can do it
for the output as well
so here we are taking the input of the
elements from the users
now
we have to display those elements
so for that first of all we will display
a message
elements that you
have entered
now we'll use for loop again
and I equals 0
I less than size
I plus plus
now we'll
print those elements so first of all
we'll write
element
now
PTR
like just we
did earlier ptri
and end line
so that the output looks good
now everything is done we have allocated
the memory then we have taken the input
from the user and displayed the output
now all we have to do is to delete the
operator
so we'll write
delete
then empty brackets
PTR
all right
now everything is done
we have allocated the memory and here we
are deleting the allocated memory
okay
now let's try to run this
here we can see enter the size let's say
four
now enter the elements three
six five seven and here is the output
elements that you have entered
three six five seven that is right but
it is not looking good
let's use slash n over here
and now let's again try to run this
enter the size
4
now 2
4
7
9.
here is the space between them now it is
looking good enter elements that you
have entered are two four seven nine so
this is how it's done
we have allocated the memory
to an array of size
of size variable
then we have entered the elements then
we have displayed those elements and at
last we have D allocated the memory
using delete operator
so these were few examples on memory
management C plus plus memory management
you can try some more examples on them
in this video we will learn about
classes in C plus plus first we will
learn about why do we need classes then
we will learn what is a class then we'll
go through access modifiers and object
of a class after that member functions
and at last we will learn about
Constructors and destructors
so first is why do we need classes
to understand this we need to know that
C plus plus is an object oriented
language and it also introduces the
concept of real world entities so in
order to describe the real world
entities we need two things and that is
characteristics and functions and the
class is a mechanism of binding these
two methods together in a single unit
also class has its own members like
functions variables Constructors
destructors Etc which are commonly used
in C plus plus and class has an
important role in the concept of an
inheritance as well now let's understand
what is a class classes are one of the
most important features of C plus plus
that leads to object oriented
programming
it represents the set of properties that
are common among all the objects of same
type
a class basically represents a group of
similar objects which holds its own data
members and member function together and
this is the basic syntax of a class
first is class keyword which is used to
create class then after that we will
write the name of the class then inside
the name of the class there is access
specifier that can be private public or
protected
after that there is data members that is
the variables and then the member
functions and also class body must be
surrounded with braces
now let's discuss access modifiers it
basically Grant permission or set the
restriction for data members of the
class
access modifiers in a class are used to
provide accessibility to the class
member
for example in a school teachers are
allowed to see the question papers
before the exams but the students are
not allowed to do so anyone other than
teachers cannot access those questions
now we can relate these teachers to data
members of class which have access and
students are outside functions that do
not have the access
so there are three types of access
modifiers
private public and protected
private members can only be accessed
from within the class that means outside
data members and member functions cannot
access it
public as the name suggests it can be
accessed from within the class and from
outside the class as well
protected members can be accessed from
within the class but cannot be accessed
from outside the class but with the help
of Rand function it can be accessed from
outside the class as well
now let's learn about object of a class
an object is an instance of a class it
is a real word entity that contains
State and behavior
when we create an object of a class then
the memory is allocated and no memory
allocation occurs when class is defined
and we can create as many objects of a
class as we need
in this example state is the class and
St is the object name or reference
variable
so this is how an object is created now
coming to member functions
member functions are also known as
methods these are as much as part of the
class as the member variables these
member functions can be invoked by
sending messages through an instance of
a class with the help of dot operator
for example if the name of the object is
obj and we want to access a function
named sum then it will be obj dot sum
here obj is the name of the object and
sum is the name of the function what is
a Constructor in C plus plus
in C plus plus Constructors are special
functions that are different from normal
functions they are used to initialize
objects of a class
whenever an object is created The
Constructor is invoked or called
automatically even if we do not create a
Constructor the compiler automatically
creates a default Constructor
now let's move to the Declaration of the
Constructor
Constructors are the member functions of
a class that has the same name as that
of the class and it doesn't have any
return type
a Constructor can be defined inside the
class and outside the class as well
using the scope resolution operator
the syntax of a Constructor is as
mentioned
inside the class cons we can see there
is a Constructor which has the same name
as that of class that is cons and we can
initialize variables inside it
this Constructor will be invoked
automatically when the object is created
now let's understand how the Constructor
is different from functions
there are some differences between
Constructors and functions so the first
is Constructor doesn't have a return
type unlike function which has a return
type
next is the name of the Constructor must
be the same as that of the class and it
is not so in case of function
third is whenever an object is created
then a Constructor is invoked
and the last one is function can be a
virtual function but it is not so in
case of Constructors
so these are some differences between
Constructor and a function now coming to
types of Constructors
there are actually three types of
Constructors in C plus plus that is
default Constructor parameterized
Constructor and a copy Constructor
so let's start with the default
Constructor
a default Constructor is a Constructor
that doesn't have any arguments inside
it it can either be declared explicitly
or can be generated automatically which
means even if we do not Define The
Constructor then also it is generated by
the compiler
for example here cons is the default
Constructor
in this case the name of the class would
have been cons that is why the name of
the Constructor is cons
now coming to the parameterized
Constructor
a parameterized Constructor is similar
to that of the default Constructor the
only difference is we can pass the
arguments to the parameterized
Constructor
The Constructor can be overload and also
be used to initialize elements
here is an example of the parameterized
Constructor
cons is the name of the Constructor in
N1 and 2 are the parameters of the
Constructor
now
coming to the copy Constructor a copy
Constructor is a type of Constructor
which initializes an object using
another object of the class
in this Constructor properties of one
object is copied to another object
this copy Constructor is invoked when an
object is passed as a parameter
if a class has pointers or there is some
dynamic memory allocation then it is
necessary to have a copy Constructor
its syntax is as follows
here cons is the name of the Constructor
and Ampersand obj is the reference of
the object as we have understood all of
these three Constructors so let's go
ahead to our next topic that is
Constructor overloading
like functions Constructor can also be
overloaded and it is pretty much the
same as function overloading The
Constructor must have the same names and
the difference in the number or the type
of arguments will decide which
Constructor should be called
here in the example we can see two
Constructors with the same names as that
of the class are being overloaded
here the difference in the number of
parameters will determine which
Constructor will be called
now coming to the last topic that is
destructors in C plus plus
just like the Constructor the destructor
is also a special function
which deletes or distracts the object as
soon as the object goes out of scope
it basically delocates the memory that
has been assigned to the variables
the name of the destructor is same as
that of the class name with a tilt sign
the destructor doesn't have a return
type and it also doesn't take any
arguments and here is the syntax of the
destructor now here we will make a new
file
and let's name this file as
class.cpp
now here we will do a program in which
we will make a class and inside that
class we will make some functions and
with the help of objects of that class
we will call those functions
so let's start first of all we'll
mention the header files hash include
iostream
Now using namespace standard
now let's
make a class
and with a class keyword
and name this class as let's say
franchise
foreign
now
here we will write the access modifier
that is public
now we'll mention those functions
let's say void
let's name this function as KFC
now inside this function
we will print
something like let's say
we have the best chicken
foreign
now we'll make another function named
Burger King
as we know that these two are
famous franchise so that is why we have
put this under class for franchise
now let's
print here we have the best burgers
now we'll try to
print these two functions with the help
of object that are made from the class
franchise
so what we'll do is
we'll write end Main
after the franchise class we'll write
int Main and inside this class
will make an object
of class franchise
franchise is the class name friend is
the object name
now all we have to do is the calling
we'll call the function KFC and we'll
call the function Burger King with the
help of friend object
so let's do this
friend dot operator
KFC
that is the function name
after that we'll write friend
Dot
Burger King
return 0.
now let's try to run this one
here it is actually I have run it twice
so that is why it is again getting
printed twice we have the best chicken
we have the best burgers that is what we
want to print
first here friend dot KFC call this word
KFC inside this class franchise after
that friend.berger King called this
function Burger King so that is why they
have printed serial wise we have the
best chicken we have the best burgers
after this we'll do another example
so let's do this
first of all we'll name this file
yes
Plus
two dot CPP
okay I think it already exists
we have to name it something else
three
okay now we will write
the header files
hash include I have strain
foreign
Now using
namespace standard
in this example we will try to access a
private variable as we know that it can
only be accessed from within the class
but it can be done with the help of
segregator methods
so let's start first of all we'll write
int Main
now we'll
make an object
for that we have to write the class name
which is
billboard
will make this class afterwards
first of all we'll write the class name
after that we'll write object
let's name the object bill board is
class name Bill is the object name
now we will call
a particular method or a function
which we call Setter method we will
write
bill
dot we'll name that Setter method as set
title
basically this function will access or
assign the value to the private variable
which we were talking about
so we'll write here
let's say top
five songs
of 2020
we want this title to be written on the
billboard
now I will write the getter method
basically the setter method or set title
method will set or assign the value of
to the private variable and get method
or get title method will return that
value from there
so we'll write Bill Dot
get title
all right
now because we want to print it so that
is why I will write it
in C out
okay now after that we'll write return
0.
now we will make the class billboard
class keyword
billboard
after that bracket starts
now we will write private
because you want
the variable to private
so
the data type string
and the variable is title
now this variable is private and we want
to assign the value to this variable
which is not possible because they are
not of the same class but we will do
that with the help of ceterogator method
so let's do that
now we will write public
because we want our functions to be
public
now void that is the data type
set title
and inside the bracket we'll write the
variable
now this method is taking this very this
parameter X so we'll assign this
parameter x to the private variable
let's do that
title that is the private variable
X
now
we will write another method named get
title
there are no parentheses in get title
method because this method is only
returning the value so we'll write
return
title
now get title function or method is
returning the value of private variable
title so here what happening is here the
function set title which is public is
taking a parameter X and is assigning to
the title variable
so the message will get assigned to the
title variable now get title function is
returning the value of private variable
title
which is getting called in the main
function
one more thing we forgot to
put semicolon over here
and
we get title cannot be void
because it is returning
it would be string
because it is returning some value
now
so basically build dot set title in the
main function will set the value or
assign the value to the private variable
and build dot get title will return the
value of that private variable which
will get printed
foreign
so now let's try to run this
[Music]
top 5 songs of 2020 here we can see
it is getting printed so this is how we
can do that we can access the private
variable using Setter and getter method
now let's do another example
let's name this as
class 4 dot CPP
now here we will do the same example but
we will do it with the help of
Constructors
so let's continue first of all we'll
write hash include iostream
after that using namespace standard
now here first of all we'll write int
Main
now we'll name the class we'll write the
name of the class that is billboard
and we'll make the object of it
as we have done previously like Bill
now we'll make a Constructor of this
object
and we'll pass the parameters
we'll pass the string as
top 3
songs
of 2020
.
as we are passing this string to the
Constructor that means the Constructor
is parameter is constructed and now
we'll write Bill Dot get title
foreign
this
function is returning the value of
private variable title so that is why we
have to write it
and we'll print it actually
C out
return 0.
now let's do the other thing
as we have done previously we'll write
class
billboard we are making this class
and inside this class we are making the
variable private
string title is private
now we'll write Public Access modifier
now here we will write the Constructor
in which we were passing the string from
the main function so we'll write the
name of the Constructor as we all know
the name of the Constructor is same as
that of the class so it would be
billboard
and
the parameter is
B
that parameters which we are passing
from the main function is getting stored
in b
now inside this Constructor we'll call
the method set title
so we'll write set
title
we are passing the same string to the
set title method
now
we'll make this method
set title we'll write
void
set title
string a
foreign
so actually what is happening we have
passed a string named top three songs of
2020 to the Constructor The Constructor
is further calling to the method or
function named set title and is passing
that string to the same function
now that function is set title and now
we will assign that string to the
private variable title
so let's try it
title equals a is that string
now
as we have done previously we'll write
void get title
now get title function is used for
returning the value of private variable
as we know so we'll write
string actually
string get title
return
title
semicolon
now let's try to run it
I think something is wrong
here capital S we have written
let's make it correct
now let's try to run again
here we can see top three songs of 2020.
so this is how we can print with the
help of Constructor
this was the same example as that of the
previous one but to understand
Constructors we have done this with the
help of Constructors and we get the
right output
so after this we'll do the example of
destructors
okay let's name this
as class six
Dot cpb
now let's write the header files
hash include
i o stream
using namespace standard
now we'll start with int Main
so first of all we will write the class
name that is Gambit
to access the class we need to have an
instance or object of class
here the name of the object is gan
after this we will call a function
display
so we will write
again dot display
return zero
now let me tell you what is happening
so as we declared this object
Constructor will be called that is
Gambit and the message inside the
Constructor will be printed
after the Constructor gets completed we
will return back to the main now we have
game dot display which is used to call
display function inside the Gambit class
so after this we will write the class
let's make it
class keyword
Gambit
now we'll write Public Access modifier
now we'll write the Constructor
foreign
we'll write hello
hello there
I am Constructor
I am in Constructor
now here we will write the destructor
Gambit
and inside the destructor we will print
the message
just to indicate that we are in the
destructor
hello there
I am in Destructor
semicolon
but before that we have to
write the function display also so we'll
write
void
display
okay
and we'll print the message
let's say hello
handle
now let's try to understand this again
as the object is declared constructed
will be called lettuce Gambit and the
message inside the Constructor will be
printed after the Constructor gets
completed we will return back to the
main now we have gam dot display which
is used to call display function inside
the Gambit class
so hello will be printed
now as we can see the program has
finished the execution now the
destructor will be called and hello I am
Destructor will be printed
as we know Destructor destroys the
object at as the scope of the object
ends so after the scope of the object
ends hello I am in Destructor gets
printed in the last
so now let's try to run this
here we can see
hello there I am in Constructor
then hello is printed then hello there I
mean Destructor is printed as we have
thought
the structure is getting printed in the
last because as we know that when the
scope ends the destructor is called
so these were some basic examples of
classes in C plus plus in order to
understand them better you must practice
some more examples on them in today's
session we will learn why we need oops
then what is object oriented programming
then we will discuss the difference
between oops and procedural programming
then we'll go through basic concepts of
oops and at last we will learn about the
benefits of hooks
there were some limitations in earlier
approaches to programming and oops help
to fill those gaps
in object oriented programming it is
easy to maintain the code with the help
of classes and objects and with the help
of inheritance there is code reusability
that is we don't have to write the same
code again and again which increases the
Simplicity of the program
now let's understand what is object
oriented programming
object oriented programming is a
programming pattern where the programs
are structured around objects rather
than logic and functions in other words
who basically focus on objects that are
required to be manipulated instead of
logic
for example let us suppose we have made
blueprint of a mole then that blueprint
will be a plan that explains what
properties the mall should have and how
it should look like Etc
but it is just a blueprint of the mall
we cannot go inside it physically as of
now
now the constructors will go through the
blueprint and they will construct them
all and they can make as many malls as
they want with the help of that
blueprint and each model can have its
own different shops and showrooms in
this case blueprint is the class the
mole is the object and the show-ups and
showrooms inside the malls are data
stored in the object's properties and
these are some basic concepts of oops
first is classes then objects then data
abstraction and encapsulation then there
is inheritance polymorphism Dynamic
binding and message passing we will
learn about these Concepts later first
we will discuss the difference between
oops versus procedure programming
procedural programming follows top-down
approach a top-down approach means
fragmenting a bigger complication into
smaller chunks
oops follows bottom-up approach and
bottom-up approach means piecing
together smaller tasks to give rise to
complex tasks
in procedural programming overloading is
not possible in oops overloading can be
done
in procedural oriented programming there
are no excess specifiers in oop they
have excess specifiers like private
protected public
procedural oriented programming is less
secure oops is more secure because of
the concepts like abstraction and
encapsulation which are used for data
hiding
now let's learn the basic concepts of
oops
first is class
can be defined as collection of objects
it is a logical entity
then there is object it is defined as an
entity that has State and behavior or in
other words anything that exists
physically in the world is called an
object
inheritance can be defined as when one
object acquires properties and behavior
from its parent class
it provides code usability
polymorphism polymorphism is a
combination of two words poly which
means many and morphs which means forms
it is basically an ability to exist in
more than one form
next is abstraction
hiding the internal details and showing
the functionality to the user is called
abstraction
then encapsulation encapsulation is The
Binding of code and data together into a
single unit
in Dynamic binding
Dynamic binding is the method called at
runtime that means which code will
execute is unknown until the program
runs
then there is message passing
it is basically a communication that
exists between the objects
as we have gone through some concepts of
oops now let's discuss some benefits of
oops
in oops code can easily be reused with
the help of inheritance and object
we don't need to write the same code
over and over
second is with the help of abstraction
and encapsulation certain parts of
program can be hidden and it helps to
make a secure system
third is maintaining and modification of
code is easy in object oriented
programming
now to do some examples on concepts of
oops let's move on to a code editor that
is vs code
now here we will do a program of
inheritance in which we will make a
parent class and a child class and we
will call the attributes using object of
child class
so let's get started first of all
let's name the file
dot CPP
okay so first of all We'll add the
header files
hash include
higher stream
now adding namespace standard
now we will write int Main
so we want to create the object of child
class so first of all we'll write the
name of class child that is child
let's put C capital
child and now the name of the object ch
so now we will call the attributes using
this object so we'll write first of all
displayed so we'll write C out
CH
dot name
one
which is the attribute we will declare
it later
foreign
so basically we want to write both the
names of both the classes together so
that is why
we are doing like this we'll write name
two
name one will be the attribute of the
parent class and name two will be the
attribute of child's class
so after that we'll write
return 0.
now
will make the parent class and the child
class so first of all let's write class
parent we'll name it as parent
then
we'll write Public Access specifier
string is the data type
name one
let's write
um
Harley
okay now
it is mandatory to write the semicolon
at the end of the class
now
we'll write the derived class that is
child
we will write the column symbol then we
will write public
name of the parent class that is parent
so here we are writing
the child class is derived from the
parent class
now
within the bracket we'll write public
then string the data type
name to
we'll write ha Davidson
it's a popular bike brand Harley
Davidson so
now we'll write the semicolon over here
now we'll try to run this
[Music]
as you can see Harley Davidson
here Harley is from the parent class and
Davidson is from the child class so as
we can see that we are calling from the
object of child class and still we are
able to access the attribute of parent
class so this shows that the child class
inherits attributes or properties from
the parent class
now as we have done one example of
inheritance so now let's do one example
of polymorphism also
let's name it oop
one dot CPP
first of all we'll include the header
files
slash include iostream
stream
now we'll write using namespace standard
after that we'll write int Main
now here we will do an example of
polymorphism in which we will make a
base class and its derived classes and
inside these classes we will override a
function which is common in all of these
classes
so let's start first of all we'll write
the name of the parent class or Base
Class
animal
and will make an object a
after that we'll write the name of the
child's class cheetah
and its object name is Seal let's say
now
another derived class dolphin
and we'll name the object as d
now while making these classes we'll
write a function name speed in all of
these classes inside all of these
classes and now in order to overwrite
that function we'll call them
so first of all we'll call it by the
object of animal that is a
a DOT speed
now C Dot
speed
this is the object of cheetah class now
D dot speed
after that we'll write return 0
now let's make these classes
first of all we will make the animal
flash that is the base class
animal
now we'll write the excess specifier
public
now we'll write the function
void that is the data type speed
now we will display a message inside
this function let's say
it displays who is more faster
who
is
more
faster
okay
now we'll put a semicolon in the end
now we will make a derived class that is
dolphin
we'll write class
dolphin
child of
animal class
okay so now inside this class
we'll write public
and we'll make the same function speed
and will display a message
saying
as this class is of dolphin so we'll
write
I'm faster
in water
we'll put semicolon
now we'll make another child's class
Plus
cheetah
Okay C is capital cheetah
public animal
now here we will write
Public Access specifier
and we'll write the same function wide
speed
and over here we'll display a message
saying that
I am
faster on the ground
semicolon
so now as we can see that a DOT speed is
calling this speed function
in animal class
C dot speed is calling this cheetah
function in cheetah class
and D dot speed
D dot speed is calling the dolphin
speed function in Dolphin class
okay so now let's try to run this
foreign
in very good form so
let's put slash n in the end
okay
slash n
slash n
okay
here it is
so first who is faster is displayed then
I am faster on the ground
then I am faster in water is displayed
so as we know that first of all we have
called the animal class so that is why
who is more faster is displayed after
that we have called the cheetah class
and cheetah says that I'm faster on the
ground then dolphin class then dolphin
says I am faster in water
so
here we can see that each of the class
have its different implementation for
the same function that is speed and this
is how polymorphism allows us to do a
single action in variety of ways
okay now let's do one example of
abstraction
let's name it as
oop three dot CPP
first of all we'll include the header
files we'll write hash
include iostream
now we'll write the namespace standard
using namespace STD
now as we know abstraction helps in data
hiding so in this program we will make a
variable named coupon as private and
with the help of set coupon function we
will try to assign some value to the
coupon variable
and after that we will display it
so let's start first of all we'll write
int Main
now we'll write the name of the class
that is Trade Fair
Trade Fair
and now the name of the object t
now with the help of this object we will
call a function named set
coupon
I would say coupons
and we'll pass 50 as an argument to this
function
now
will display
a message
open
and after that
we will call get coupon method in order
to display the number of coupons
so we'll write T Dot
get
coupons
and
brackets
done
after that we'll write return 0
. now let's make the class and the
functions so let's start first of all
we'll write
class
Trade Fair
now we'll write an access specifier
private
and
I private
now
we will declare a variable coupon
and as I've already told you we will
make this variable as private so that is
why we have used this Express specifier
as private
now
after that we will write Public Access
specifier
to write a function
that is set coupons
set
coupons
and the parameter is c as we know that
we have passed 50 to this parameter so
now
we will write
the private variable coupon
equals c
so here we are basically assigning
the value of C to the coupon that is we
are assigning 50 to coupon
variable now
after that
we will make another function
and we'll put its data type as int
because it is returning something
so we'll write int get coupon
and we will return
variable coupon
now as the class ends we'll write
semicolon
now let's try to run this code
there is some error
okay we haven't tried s over here
now let's again try to run it
open
50.
as I have told you
so here we have assigned 50 to this
function and
the variable C is assigning 50 to the
variable coupon
now after that we have used get coupon
function to return the value of coupon
and that is why it is getting displayed
over here
so we got our answer that is coupon 50.
and as you can see that in this example
we were not allowed to access the
variable coupon but still somehow we
have managed to do that with the help of
some functions so this is an example of
abstraction and
it helps to increase the security of the
program
so this these were some basic examples
of oops in C plus plus
in order to understand it better we must
practice some more examples on it
today we will learn about C plus plus
inheritance so without further Ado let's
get started so in this session we will
learn about what is C plus plus
inheritance why do we use inheritance in
C plus plus then we will understand
different modes of inheritance and after
that we will learn about types of
inheritance that is single inheritance
multiple inheritance multi-level
inheritance and Hybrid inheritance in C
plus plus but before we begin make sure
to subscribe to our Channel and hit the
Bell icon to never miss an update so
what is inheritance in C plus plus just
like a child inherits the behavior and
characteristics from his or her parents
similarly inheritance in C plus plus in
the process in which the derived class
acquires all the properties and
characteristics from the parent class
that is the base class derived class is
also known as child class and base class
is also known as parent class
inheritance is one of the most important
feature of C plus plus oops that is
object oriented programming in
inheritance there are two types of
classes the class which inherits the
properties and behavior from the base
class is known as derived class and the
class whose Properties or
characteristics are inherited is called
a base class now let's understand why we
use inheritance in C plus plus
inheritance is used in C plus plus
because it increases the reusability of
the code and it helps in removing the
redundancy to understand it let's
Suppose there are two classes two
wheeler and four wheeler both of the
classes contain similar functions like
color brand and mileage now if we create
these classes we have to create all the
three functions in both of the classes
or in other words we have to write the
same code two times in both of the
classes so instead of writing that code
again and again we can use inheritance
and create a parent class named class
vehicle and both of the two wheeler and
the four wheeler classes will be
inherited from this parent or base class
now with inheritance we have inherited
both the classes from one Base Class
that is class vehicle now we no longer
have to write the code again and again
and we can simply write the functions
once in the base class as both of these
classes are inherited from The Base
Class vehicle so as we have understood
about inheritance in C plus plus and why
we use inheritance in C plus plus so now
let's go ahead and learn about modes of
inheritance there are three modes of
inheritance in C plus plus that is
public mode protected mode and private
mode inheritance so let's start with the
public mode in this mode of inheritance
the public members of Base Class remains
public in derived class and same goes
for the protected members that means
inside the Base Class the class members
that are public will remain public in
the derived class and similarly
protected class members will remain
protected in derived class now protected
mode in the protected mode the public
and protected members of the base class
will become protected in the derived
class that means the class members which
are public or protected in the base
class will all become protected in the
derived class in the private mode of
inheritance protected and public members
of class will become private in the
derived class so now let's go ahead to
the types of inheritance so there are
various types of inheritance in C plus
plus that is single inheritance multiple
inheritance multi-level inheritance
hierarchical inheritance and Hybrid
inheritance so let's start with the
single inheritance in this type of
inheritance a single derived class is
inherited from the single Base Class it
allows the derived class to inherit
properties and behavior from the parent
class the derived class objects can
access the members of the base class but
the Base Class objects cannot access the
members of the derived class so now
let's have a look at the syntax as we
know this is single inheritance so there
will be only a single derived class and
a single Base Class and this is how we
derive a child class from a parent class
class keyword then the name of the
derived class then the colon operator
after that there is an access modifier
with the base class now as we have
understood about single inheritance and
its syntax now let's move on to multiple
inheritance multiple inheritance when a
class inherits from more than one base
class or multiple base classes then it
is known as multiple inheritance it
allows us to inherit properties and
characteristics from more than one Base
Class Syntax for multiple inheritance is
class keyword with the name of derived
class then the colon operator and access
modifier with the name of the Base Class
separated with comma and the name of
another Base Class here we have shown
only two base classes but we can make
more than two base classes depending
upon our requirement now coming to
multi-level inheritance in this type of
inheritance the derived class is
inherited from another derived class
that means when a class extends a class
that further extends another class is
known as multi-level inheritance for
example if there are three classes a b c
and Class C is inherited from class B
and Class B is inherited from class A
then it can be called as a multi-level
inheritance syntax of multi-level
inheritance is as follows Base Class 2
is derived from Base Class 1 and the
derived class is derived from Base Class
2. these Base Class 1 base Class 2 and
derived class are just the names not a
syntax you can write whichever name you
want with the class now let's learn
about hierarchical inheritance in this
type of inheritance more than one class
is inherited from a single Base Class
that is there would be a single Base
Class and multiple derived classes
which have the properties and features
same as that of the base class as you
can see in the figure and in the syntax
the derived class 1 is derived from base
class and similarly derived Class 2 and
derived class 3 are also derived from
the base class so this was hierarchical
inheritance and our next type of
inheritance would be Hybrid inheritance
the Hybrid inheritance is the
combination of more than one type of
inheritance and it can be said that it
is a combination of multi-level and
hierarchical inheritance in the figure
we can see the Base Class 1 is a parent
class of derived class 1 and derived
class 1 is the parent class of derived
class 3 which makes it multi-level
inheritance but if you look at it in
this way that the Base Class 1 is the
parent class of derived class 1 derived
Class 2 and derived class 3 then it is
hierarchical inheritance as multiple
glasses are inherited from a common Base
Class so we can and say it is a
combination of more than one type of
inheritance or a Hybrid inheritance so
as we have understood about inheritance
in C plus plus so now let's go to its
practical aspect and do some examples on
our code editor that is vs code so this
is a visual studio code and now we will
do an example of inheritance we'll start
by doing the single inheritance example
in which we will make a parent class and
a child class and let's start first of
all we'll create a file and let's name
this file as
let's name it inherit dot CPP
so here we'll do an example in which we
will create two classes a base class and
a derived class and we'll create
functions in those classes like we'll
create one function in base class and
one function in derived class and using
the object of derived class we will
access the member of parent class or
base class so let's start first of all
we'll include the header files
hash include iostream now the namespace
standard using namespace STD now we'll
create a base class first then
afterwards we'll create the main
function all right so let's create the
Base Class let's say the name of the
base class or the parent class would be
beverage
and inside this class let's make the
scope public and now let's create a
function as we have said
drinks
so this is a function and we will print
something inside this function so let's
say we are printing all rings are
available
all drinks
are available now I will write handle
now we will use semicolon in the end of
the class so this is a base class and we
have created a function drinks and we
have printed a message all rings are
available all right now we will create
another class which is derived class or
child class
we will write class coffee is the name
of the derived class and use the column
operator Public Access specifier and the
name of the base class that is beverage
all right now we'll write Public Access
specifier inside this class and we will
create a function in this class also
like let's say the name of the function
would be mocha
it is a kind of a coffee so mocha and we
will print that mock Art Is Good Taste
the best I would say okay now
let's use the column operator in the end
of the class so here we have created the
parent class or base class and this
derived class of child class so now we
will create the main function we will do
the calling
so now we will create the object of
child class so our child class is coffee
and now we will create the object that
is C the name of the class and the
object okay now we will use the object
with DOT operator and call this function
that is drinks and now using the same
object we'll call the mocha the spelling
is wrong yeah now it is right mocha
so using the object of child class here
we are calling the drinks function which
is of the parent class
so let's see if it works or not let's
save it and now run it
as you can see all rings are available
and MoCA test the best both of these are
getting printed that means the object of
child class is able to access the member
of the parent class so this is
inheritance when the child class
acquires or inherits the behavior or
characteristics from a parent class or
access the members of the parent class
this is an example of single inheritance
so now let's do another example of
multiple inheritance so let's create a
new file and name it as inherit 2 dot
CPP all right now here we'll do an
example of multiple inheritance in which
we will create two base classes and a
derived class as we know that in
multiple inheritance there are more than
one base classes to a single derived
class
so let's start first of all we'll
include the header file
now we'll use the namespace standard
and now we will create a class that is
the base class and we'll name it as
party so Class party inside this Base
Class we will first of all declare the
public scope and now we will declare a
variable let's say meals so now we will
create a function and in this function
we will take the input from the user
about the number of mails to enter the
number of meals so let's start avoid
food this is the function name and first
of all we'll display the message saying
that enter number of meals
all right now
we will take the input and meals is the
variable
now we will use the semicolon at the end
of this class
so in this function we are taking the
input of the number of meals now in this
in the other class that is another Base
Class we will take the input of number
of drinks from the users and then in the
derived class we figure out the total
bill of the party all right now we will
create another Base Class that is drinks
node brings drinks all right now we'll
write the public scope and similarly
we'll create or declare another variable
drink and
then now we will create a function let's
say the name of the function is liquor
all right now inside this function we
will take the input from the user
regarding the number of drinks so we'll
display the message enter
the number of drinks
so the user will enter the total number
of rings used in the party or consumed
in the party similarly goes for the
meals now we will take the
input and we'll write
drink
all right now we have created this
liquor function now we will use the
semicolon at the end of the class where
we have created both the base classes
that is Class party and class strings
now we have to create the derived class
so this is example of multiple
inheritance so we will create
the derived class
and use the column operator now we will
write the public specifier and the name
of the Base Class for space class would
be party separated with comma the second
base class would be drinks
all right so this is how we can do that
now inside this class we will first of
all create three variables let's say
hint total meals in total
drinks and in total bill because in the
end we have to find out the total bill
all right now inside the public scope
we will create a function
name as total now inside this total
function we will write the logic to
calculate the total bill so what we'll
do is first of all write the total meal
total meals equals meals into the price
of a single meal let's say the price of
a single meal is 90 so the total product
would be stored in total meals all right
now we will do same for total drinks
total drinks not drinks quills drink
into let's say the price of a single
drink is 60 yes all right now after that
we have to compute or calculate the
total bill
total bill would be the addition of both
of these total means plus total Rings
we'll simply do the addition over here
total drinks
so once it's calculated we'll simply
display a message saying that the total
bill for the party total will for the
party is and we'll write the variable
that is total bill where the total bill
is actually getting stored all right
after this you will use the semicolon so
this is the derived class here we have
calculated the total money spent in the
party so now we have to write the main
function where it all started inside the
main function first of all we will
create the object of child class so we
know that our child class or the derived
class is Bill
so bill is the derived class and B would
be the object so using this B we will
first of all call call a function that
is food function so by calling this we
will take the input of number of meals
now we will call another function named
liquor all right using this function
calling this function will take the
number of drinks from the user now we
will call this total function so this
will calculate the total money spent in
the party
and after that let's say return zero we
are calling all these functions using
the object of derived class and this is
where multiple inheritance is going on
so let's see whether it works or not we
will save it and we'll try to run this
enter number of meals as you can see
enter number of meals let's say the
number of meals would be 20 it was a
short party then enter number of drinks
17 would be so our total bill for the
party is three two seven zero which is
the correct answer so this is how we can
do multiple inheritance and this is a
fine example of multiple inheritance now
let's do another example so let's name
this one as inherit three dot CPP
all right so here we will do an example
of multi-level inheritance and we know
that in multi-level inheritance a single
derived class is inherited from another
derived class or in other words we can
say a class extends a class which
further extends another class then it is
called a multi-level inheritance as the
name suggests so we will do example of
that in this example we will calculate
the marks of a student scored by him in
three subjects we'll calculate the total
marks scored by him using multi-level
inheritance so let's do this so first of
all we will include the header file hash
include I String then we will write the
namespace standard now we will create
the class Base Class chemistry all right
in this class first of all we will make
the public scope and marks one so here
we will take the input of Max scored by
that particular child in this chemistry
subject so we'll create the chemistry
function white chemistry which is of
same name as that of class so let's take
mystery marks all right now we will
display the marks code in chemistry
enter the marks score in chemistry
spelling is wrong okay now we'll take
the input marks one so the student will
enter the marks after that let's put
semicolon in the end now we'll create
another class named physics which is
inherited from chemistry class that is
chemistry classes it's Base Class
chemistry all right so in this class we
will do the same public
int marks to hint marks two now I'll
write void
physics marks we'll do the same as we
have done in the previous class
so now we will display a message saying
that enter the marks
scored in physics all right
now we will take the input C in marks
two all right so now we will put
semicolon in the end of this class as
well so now we know that this physics
class is is inherited from this
chemistry class that is the chemistry
class is the base class of physics class
now
we will do same for maths like class
maths
which is in inherited from the
physics class
we will write physics inside this class
as well we'll do the same and as you can
see this physics class is the base class
of maths and the Base Class of physics
class is chemistry so this is a
multi-level inheritance
so in this class we'll do the same
public scope and now after public scope
hint marks 3 is the variable we have
declared and we will declare another
variable in this one like total because
we have to find out the total marks Now
function maths marks
inside this one we will display the
message that enter the marks yeah enter
the marks score in maths all right now
we'll take the input marks 3 and we'll
write the semicolon in the end so here
we have created all of these three
classes which is of multi-level
inheritance as you can see
we have taken the input from the user of
its match fields and chemistry marks now
we'll do the total so we have to do the
total inside this class only so the name
would be result function so the total
func variable that we have declared
is equal to Max 1 marks 2 plus marks
three so physics commission maths marks
we will add all of them
and then we will display the total all
right now this is done now we have to go
to the main function
now first of all we will create the
object of child class maths once this
object is created now we can call the
functions as it can access the base
classes so chemistry marks first of all
then m dot physics marks in m dot maths
marks
and then the total that is result result
function m dot result
then we'll write return 0. so
return 0. so here first of all m dot
Mistry marks will call this function in
the chemistry class so the user will
enter the marks code by him in chemistry
then this will call physics marks so the
user will enter the marks code by him in
physics subject then similarly we will
match marks we will enter the marks of
Max then we will call the result
function we will do the total of all the
marks scored by the student we'll do the
total and then we will display that
total so pretty much it's done now we
can save it and now let's try to run
this one there are some errors all right
that's a silly one by mistake we have
done this all right now let's save it
and run it again hope it works now yeah
another error marks now let's try again
now it's working fine enter the marks
code in chemistry let's say 80. physics
80 my maths is vehicle let's say 75
235 which is the right answer 80 plus 80
plus 75 is equal to 235 and using the
object of child class we have called the
functions of all of these base classes
like we have called this chemistry marks
function and this physics marks function
which is of Base Class and this was a
fine example of multi-level inheritance
and this is how we can do multi-level
inheritance so these were some examples
of C plus plus inheritance you can try
some more examples on it and these were
some decent examples to understand it
better you can start with some basic
level examples then go to the
intermediate level
hey everyone welcome back to another
video session by simply learn
in this session we will learn about C
plus plus polymorphism
so let's go ahead and have a look at
what we'll be covering today
so we'll start with what is polymorphism
in C plus plus then types of
polymorphism in C plus plus that is
compile time and runtime we'll also
study function overloading and operator
overloading under compile time
polymorphism
and under runtime polymorphism we will
learn about function overriding and
virtual function in C plus plus but
before we begin make sure to subscribe
to our Channel and press the Bell icon
to never miss an update from Simply
learn
so what is polymorphism in C plus plus
polymorphism is an important topic of C
plus plus oops concept the word
polymorphism is derived from two words
that is poly which means many and moths
which means forms so basically it means
many forms
polymorphism in C plus plus can be
defined as when the member function or
the object behaves differently in
different situations or circumstances
then it can be called as polymorphism
for example a mother has different
relationships with different family
member inside the house for example
she's a parent to her child
she is a wife to her husband she's a
sister to her brother and she is also a
daughter to her parents
so we can say a mother as a single
entity has different Behavior among
different members
and same goes for polymorphism where
functions behave differently in
different situations
now let's understand the types of
polymorphism
there are two types of polymorphism in C
plus plus that is compile time
polymorphism and runtime polymorphism
so let's start with compile time
polymorphism
as the name suggests this type of
polymorphism occurs during the compile
time and it is achieved by overloading
the function or overloading the operator
that is by function overloading or
operator overloading
so what is this function overloading
function overloading is a feature in C
plus plus where the functions having the
same name but different in terms of
parameters or type of parameters can be
overloaded
for example as we can see two functions
with same name func differ in the type
of arguments one data type is double
another data type is integer so when we
make a call to the function with
arguments of type double it will invoke
the suitable function and the same goes
for the other one
in example 2 there is a difference in
number of parameters among functions so
while calling the function if we pass
two arguments it will invoke the first
function and if we will pass three
arguments then it will invoke the second
function
then next is operator overloading
like functions operators can also be
overloaded
in operator overloading we can redefine
the functionality of the operator
it helps us in redefining the already
existing operator
for example instead of writing sum
equals
S1 dot add
S2 we can easily write sum equals S1
plus S2 that is we can redefine the plus
operator and use it to add the numbers
in the operator function
and we will discuss the syntax of
operator overloading in the examples
now coming to runtime polymorphism
in this type of polymorphism the
functions are invoked during the
execution of program that is during
runtime
this runtime polymorphism can be
achieved through function overriding
so let's understand this function
overriding
in function overriding the function of
the base class gets a new definition in
the derived class
in this more than one function has the
same name and same type of parameters
the only difference is in the definition
of both the functions
that is functions have different
definitions in the parent class and the
child class
as you can see in the example void
message function has a different
definition in the parent class and in
the child class
both have the same name
but in parent class it is printing hello
there and inside class it is printing
nice to meet you
by using the object of the base class or
derived class we can invoke the suitable
function
so let's move on to our next topic that
is virtual function
virtual function is also used to achieve
runtime polymorphism
it is a function that is defined in the
base class and then is redefined in the
derived class
the function is defined using the word
virtual in the base class and the name
of the function is same as that of the
derived class having different
definitions as shown
it tells the compiler to perform the
late binding on the function in derived
class
the function call is resolved at runtime
and in late binding and the compiler
determines the object type at runtime
with the help of virtual function we can
invoke the derived version of the
function in the derived class
so as we have covered the theoretical
aspect of C plus plus polymorphism so
let's go ahead and cover the Practical
aspect of this topic in our code editor
that is vs code if getting your learning
started is half the battle what if you
could do that for free visit scale up by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more
so here we will make a new file
and let's name it as
poly1.cpp all right
poly1.ctp
so let's save it so here we'll do an
example of function overloading which is
used to achieve compile time
polymorphism and we know function
overloading is a feature in C plus in
which two functions have same name but
differ in terms of parameters or number
of parameters or the type of parameters
can be overloaded so let's start
first of all we'll write the header file
hash include I have stream
Now using namespace standard
all right
so now we will create a class King and
inside that class we'll do the
overloading
so the class name is King
and inside the class first of all
let's make public scope
now we'll create a function
return type is void
and the name of the function would be
Pro
inside this function let's say we are
passing two arguments
hint A and B
all right now we'll print both of these
arguments
or variables inside this function
all right and we'll use handle in the
end
okay
after that we'll create another function
and the name of the function is same
that is prove
and but in this case we'll make the
arguments like int a
and B
and C
and D
and end e
so there are five arguments in this
function second function Pro as we know
that the name of the function is same
and now inside this function we'll
simply add all of these
so a plus b plus C plus d
Plus
e
all right once we are done with this
we'll use semicolon in the end of the
class
all right now we'll start with the main
function inside the main function
all right inside the main function
we will create the object of King class
king and the object would be k
with the help of this object k
we will call these functions as we know
the name of the functions are same the
only difference is in the number of
arguments so so I'll call the row
function
which accepts only two arguments
so the first pro function will be
invoked so I'll pass 10
and 20.
so these two arguments will be passed
over here foreign
similarly
now we'll call the pro function again
but now we'll pass Five arguments
so that the second row function would be
invoked
so let's say I'm passing
12
3
20 and
60 to
6.
these are some random numbers
all right now return zero in the end now
let's try to run this I think we are
done with this
first of all let's save it and now let's
try to run this
so this is our output 1020 let's make it
let's multiply both of them
it will look good let's save it and run
it again
as you can see 200 and 123 so this is
our output 10 into 20 would become 200
and if we add all of these we'll get 123
so this is our correct output so this
was the example of function overloading
and let's start with another example
so now let's create a new file
and name this file as
poly2.cpp
all right we have saved it now here
we'll do an example of operator
overloading as we know that in operator
overloading we give definition to
already existing operators or we can say
we can redefine the functionality of
already existing operators so let's
start
first of all we'll include the header
files as we have done previously
hash include iostream
then the namespace standard
so first of all we'll start with the
mean function
and inside the main function
we will write the name of the class that
we will create and
the object let's say the name of the
object is o1 and we'll pass the
arguments to the Constructor
let's say the argument has 6 and 8.
all right
then I think we can write return 0 and
we'll do the rest afterwards first of
all we will create the class
so as we know that the name of the class
is overload so let's create it class
overload
and inside this class
inside the private scope
we'll start with
the variables let's say the first
variable is N1 and
let's declare another variable N2
then we will create the public scope
inside this we will create the
parameterized Constructor
so
it is of same name as that of the class
that is overload and now as the
Constructor is parameterized
so int num1 and
num to all the parameters
so when we'll create this object open
and we'll pass these arguments so it
will go here
and
all right inside this in the definition
of this Constructor
we will create a we will declare the
variable rest and we will assign
num to N1
will assign num2 to N2
and let's say we'll do the subtraction
all right
N1 minus N2
all right now we will
display the result that is rest
so
res
and then the variable rests
after that we'll use sendle
all right
so
once we are done with this parameter as
Constructor then
we will create a operator function
so void is the return type then we will
write
operator keyword
this is the syntax of operator function
then after writing the keyword we'll
write the symbol let's say minus is the
symbol
then the arguments if there are any
arguments then we can put those
then inside the function that is in the
definition we can perform whatever the
functionality we want to perform
so let's say in this case we'll just
make the numbers negative so we'll do
that
all right
now we'll do the calling part of this we
will simply use the symbol and the
operator
and this is how we will call the
operator function
this is very simple and after that we
have to display the digits as well as we
have made them negative in this part so
we'll
create a function display
and inside this function we will display
those digits or numbers
so we'll write
N1
all right after this we'll write
we'll do same for N2 so we'll write N2
then
there is handle in the end
all right so here we are displaying this
so once we are done with this the class
is finished so we can use the semicolon
in the end
and we have to call this void function
as well so
we will write o1 dot display
oh one dot
display
all right we are done let's see whether
it works or not
let's save it
and check it
so as you can see the result is -2 that
is 6 minus 8 equals minus 2 that is
correct and N1 is minus 6 and N2 is
minus 8 because we have made them
negative inside this operator function
we forgot to add some space in N2 and N1
so that is where it is looking like this
but the answer is correct and this is
how we can do the operator overloading
in this part we have used the return
type then the operator keyword then the
symbol and if there are any elements
then we can pass those arguments and if
there are not we can put it like this so
this is our example of operator
overloading let's do another example so
now we'll do an example of function
overriding so let's name this
poly3.cpb
so in function of writing the function
of Base Class gets a new definition in
the child class and when we call the
function of the child class using the
object of child class then the function
of Base Class gets overwritten so now
let's do the example of this function
overriding
I think we have named it wrong
poly3 dot CPP
all right
let's name it four
poly4.cpp all right now let's save it
now include the header files
using namespace standard
now we'll start with the class parent
so this is the base class
and we have named it parent
inside the parent class we will create a
function
for that we'll create the public scope
inside inside the public school we will
create the function print
and we will display the message this is
the function of parent class or Base
Class whatsoever
foreign
so this is class parent and semicolon in
the end of the class now we'll create
the child class
child
derived from
parent class name of the class is parent
similarly we'll do the public scope and
create the function
void print
so it is same function as that of the
above class and inside this function we
will display
this is
the function of
child class
derived class let's say
all right once we are done with this
semicolon in the end and semicolon in
the end of the class as well
then we can create a main function
and inside the main function we will
create the object of child class
child obj so as we have created the
object of child class or derived class
so with the help of this we will
override the function of the base class
so we'll write obj Dot
print
which is the name of the function so as
we have created the object of child
class so it will call the derived class
or child class function
and in the end let's say return 0.
now save it
and try to run this
this is the function of derived class so
as we have expected so it is calling the
child class function so this function of
the parent class gets overwritten as we
have used the object of child class and
call this function print which is of
same name so this function which is in
the child class gets to print
derived class
so this is our output
so now let's do an example of virtual
function in C plus plus virtual
functions are defined in the base class
to ensure that the functions gets
overwritten and
when we use the Base Class pointer to
hold the derived class object or the
child Labs object The Base Class pointer
will always call the base version of the
function and not the derived version so
so to solve this problem we use the
virtual keyword in Z Plus so now let's
start with it
first of all we'll write hash include I
have stream
now the namespace standard
now we will create the base class class
base
and then we'll use the public scope
inside the public scope we will create
the virtual function use the
virtual the return type then the name of
the function that is print
and we have created this virtual
function inside the base class now we'll
print
this is the function inside the base
class as we have done previously in the
previous question
this function
this is the functional Base Class here
it would be right
foreign
by using semicolon now I will create the
derived class and we'll name it derived
from The Base Class whose name is base
itself
now here we will use the public scope
and we'll create the function of the
right class
print function
and will print
this is the function of derived class
all right
now we'll use the semicolon
to end the class
now inside the int function int main
function
first of all we will create the pointer
of Base Class
base
D reference operator B
so we have created the pointer of Base
Class now we will create the object of
derived class
derived d
so now we will store the address of
derived class object to the pointer of
Base Class
so let's do that
B which is a pointer of Base Class
address of operator
object of derived class
so now we will call the print function
using the pointer of Base Class and it
will print the derived class function
because the pointer of Base Class which
we are using to call the functions
points to the derived class object
so now let's do the calling part
all we need to do is
the pointer and the arrow operator
and the name of the function
that is print
after that we can write return 0
. now everything is done let's save this
and run it
as we can see this is the function of
derived class here we can see
so the derived class function is getting
code which we wanted
so this is an example of virtual
function in C plus plus
we have used this virtual keyword over
here and using the Base Class pointer we
have called this function
and and these were some examples of
different topics in polymorphism in C
plus plus you can try some more examples
on these topics it will help you in
understanding this topic in a better way
in today's session we will learn about C
plus plus operator overloading so
without further Ado let's get started
so we will be covering today what is
operator overloading then we will
discuss non-overloadable operators after
that we will learn types of operator
overloading in C plus that is Unity
operator overloading and binary operator
overloading
so first is what is operator overloading
operator overloading is a special case
of polymorphism in which the operator is
overloaded to provide special meaning to
the user defined data type basically it
adds some features or redefines the
functionality of already existing
operators for example let us suppose we
have three objects of same class namely
a b c
and C equals a minus B
now here we can redefine how minus
operator works and we can write C equals
a minus b instead of writing C equals to
a DOT subtract B
and this is the general syntax of
operator overloading
first is the return type of the function
after that operator is the keyword then
symbol is the operator we want to
overload then the arguments are those
which are passed to the function
now let's move on to the
non-overloadable operators
there are some operators in C plus plus
that cannot be overloaded because it is
not synthetically possible to overload
them
first is the dot operator the next is
scope resolution operator and third is
pointer to member operator and at last
we have ternary operator
coming to the next topic that is types
of operator overloading in C plus
so there are two types of operator
overloading that is Unity operator
overloading and binary operator
overloading
first is unary operator overloading
it is defined as an operator which
contains only one operand or works on
only one operand
increment operator and decrement
operator are examples of it
there are two ways to do operator
overloading that is from the class
function and the front function its
syntax using class function is the
return type operator keyword then the
symbol and the brackets but if we are
doing postfix in the function then we
have to write the data type inside the
brackets
syntax using friend function is friend
keyword return type then operator
keyword after that symbol and in case of
friend function we have to pass an
argument
next is binary operator overloading
an operator which contains two operands
or works with two operands is called
binary operator overloading addition
subtraction multiplication are examples
of binary operator overloading syntax
using class function is return type then
operator keyword then the symbol and
then we have to pass an argument inside
the brackets
and syntax using friend function is
friend keyword then the return type
after that operator keyword and then the
symbol and in case of friend function we
can pass two arguments
now we will do one example of unity
operator overloading in which we will
increment the value of the variable with
the help of operator overloading
so now let's move on to our code editor
that is vs code
so here first of all we'll make a new
file
and name that file as operator dot CPP
now first of all we write the header
files hash include
i o stream
now we'll write the namespace standard
now we'll start with int Main
and inside intmin first of all we'll
write the name of the class that is
increase
and its object Inc
now we will call the void operator
increment function
so we will write
plus plus I and C
here when we write plus plus I and C
then function void operator plus plus
will be called which we will make later
so as of now first of all we
write I and C dot display in order to
display the output we are calling the
display function over here
now after that we'll write return 0.
now we'll make the class
so we'll write class
increase which is the name of the class
now we'll use the access specifier
private
and we'll write the variable
int value
now we'll write another excess specifier
public
and now we will make the Constructor
because we have created the object Inc
so that is why a Constructor is called
and we are making it
increase
and inside the Constructor we have given
the value 10 to the variable
now
plus plus Inc is calling the void
operator plus plus function so we'll
write that function
void
operator
increment
which is the symbol now value equals
Value Plus 5 because we are incrementing
the variable with 5. so we'll write
value equals Value Plus 5.
now after that we have to display the
value variable so we will write
void
display
because we have already called over here
Inc dot display so now we will write
inside
C out
we'll write the message value
is
now the variable value
and handle
after the class we have to use the
semicolon now let's try to run this
here is our output value is 15.
previously the value was 10 then on
increment its value gets 15 which is the
right output
so here first of all we have created an
object and Constructor is called and
inside the Constructor we have
initialized value with 10.
then with the help of object Inc that is
when we are using plus plus Inc then we
are calling the void operator function
which is increasing the value of the
variable by 5 and then we are displaying
it with the help of display function
and one more thing guys in case of post
fix that is in case of INC plus plus we
have to write the data type inside the
void operator function that is over here
now let's do another example for binary
operator overloading
so let's name this
operator
2 dot CPP
now here we will do one example of
binary operator overloading in which we
will add two complex numbers
so let's start first of all let's make
the header files
hash include iostream
Now using namespace standard
now we'll write int Main
okay now first of all we will write the
name of the class that is complex
so we'll write
complex
and then the objects like com1
com2
res we have created three object
now we will write a message because we
have to take the input from the user so
first of all we'll write a message
enter first complex number
because we have to add two complex
numbers
so first of all we'll take the input of
the first one
that is
slashing
okay now we have to
write com1 dot input input is the name
of the function which we will be
creating afterwards
then
C out
enter second complex number
that is
now we'll write slation
okay
now after this we have to write the
semicolon and we'll write
com 2
dot input
these input function will take the input
of complex numbers from the user we will
declare them later we will make them
later
okay now we will now here we will do an
operation with the help of plus operator
function
so we will write
less equals
com 1 plus com2
this function call from com1 will go to
the complex of operator plus function
and comb2 will be passed to the argument
obj and the result will be stored in
variable rest
okay now we will call another function
output in order to display the output
rest dot output after that we'll write
return 0.
now we will make the class complex
we'll write
class
complex
we'll write the access specified private
and the variables int real
and end
image that is imaginary because we know
in complex number there is a real part
and imaginary part
okay now we'll write Public Access
specifier
and now we will write the function input
in order to take the input from the user
void input
now first of all we have to display a
message
we will write enter real in imaginary
Parts respectively
okay
now we will write
C in because we have to take the input
and the variable name real
and imaginary
now we will write the overloading
function we'll write the return type
that is the complex
then operator keyword
then symbol
then
argument
complex
obj
okay now
we will write
complex
temp
so here we have created the data type
temp of complex class
will make it a Capital C
okay now we will write temp dot real
equals to real plus obj dot real so
we'll write 10
Dot real
equals to
real plus obj dot real
in the plus operator over here will add
the real part of the number to the real
part of another number
and similarly we'll do it for the
imaginary part
Right Temp Dot imaginary
equals imaginary Plus
obj dot imaginary
and
and then the value of the variable temp
is returned so we'll write
return
temp
the value was stored in temp so that is
why we have returned temp
now we will make the output function
we'll write
output
right output is
variable real
then
we'll write Plus
then imaginary
and then I because this is the Syntax
for
complex number
okay now we have to put the semicolon
over here
has the value of temp is returned now
the result is stored in variable rest
and then we will print the output using
the output function this is the output
function and the value is stored in
dress and then we are printing the
output using the output function
com1 over here is getting passed to the
complex of operator plus function and
com2 is getting passed to the argument
obj and the result is getting stored in
rest
now let's try to run this code
the first complex number let's say 2
plus 2 Iota so we will write 2 and 2.
and then enter second complex number
that is enter real and imaginary part
respectively now we have to write the
real and imaginary parts of the second
complex number so we'll write
4
Plus
6 iota
so the output is
6 Plus 8 Iota 2 plus 4 equals 6 and 2
plus 6 equals to 8 so this is our
correct output we are basically adding
two complex numbers with the help of
binary operator overloading so this is
how it is done
so these were some important examples of
operator overloading you can try some
more examples on it in order to practice
them well hey everyone welcome back to
another video by simply learn in this
session we will learn about
encapsulation in C plus plus so let's go
ahead and have a look at what we'll be
covering today
so we'll start by understanding what is
encapsulation in C plus plus why do we
need encapsulation in C plus plus then
we will learn about access modifiers
after that we will understand the
benefits of encapsulation and also the
difference between encapsulation and
abstraction so let's start with
encapsulation in C plus plus
encapsulation is a very important
concept of object oriented programming
it can be defined as wrapping up of data
and functions together into a single
unit
just like a capsule the data members and
functions are wrapped together
wrapping them into single unit helps in
keeping them secure from the outside
axis
for example inside a class the variables
and functions are declared and then bind
together with the help of class
which also implements encapsulation
next is why do we need encapsulation
hiding the details or attributes is also
an important thing that one should focus
on
encapsulation helps with that part it
keeps the details of the object hidden
or saved from the users by securing them
from the outside axis
there are many implementation details
that the users are not supposed to see
so these details like the details of the
object are kept secure from the direct
access from outside the class with the
help of encapsulation
the data hiding is done with the help of
access modifiers so let's understand
these excess modifiers
the access modifiers helps in data
hiding part
the access modifiers provides or Grant
the access to the members of the class
or it prevents them from the direct
access to the class members from outside
the class
so there are generally three types of
access modifiers that is public private
and protected
so let's understand them
in public access modifier other classes
and function can access the data members
and member functions of the public class
for example Park is a public property
anybody can go to the park or access the
park because it's a public nobody has to
take the alliance of anybody to go to
the park
now coming to the private
in private access modifiers only the
member functions inside the class have
the access to the class members
functions outside the class cannot
access them for example a house is a
private property
any member outside the family cannot
access the house without permission only
members inside the family can access it
because it's a private property
now let's understand protected
in protected access modifier similar to
private school it cannot be accessed
from the outside class
but it can be accessed from the derived
class
the derived class is also called the
child class
also the protected member of a class can
be accessed from the friend function
so as we have understood about these
access modifiers now let's understand
the benefits of encapsulation
encapsulation helps in reducing the
complexity of Code by hiding the
irrelevant data for information and by
doing so it reduces the complexity
second is encapsulation helps in hiding
and protecting the data by wrapping the
data and function together which are
generally complex and by doing so
provides a simpler view to the user with
the help of encapsulation the variables
of the class can be hidden from other
classes
third is encapsulated classes can easily
be altered using the access modifiers
that is we don't need to change the
entire program all we need to do is to
change the access scope of the variables
that can be private protected or public
so these were some benefits of
encapsulation now let's go ahead and
understand the difference between
encapsulation and abstraction
both of these concepts are similar in
some ways but now we will discuss their
differences so let's start with
encapsulation
encapsulation helps in combining the
data and functions together in a single
unit whereas in abstraction The Unwanted
information is kept hidden
encapsulation helps in hiding the data
and helps in providing an easier View
abstraction helps in hiding the
implementation details
encapsulation can be implemented using
an access modifiers whereas abstraction
can be implemented using abstract class
and interfaces
in encapsulation problems are solved at
implementation level
and in abstraction
problems are solved at design level
so these were some differences between
encapsulation and abstraction
let's go ahead and do some practical
examples on this topic
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit skillup by simply learn click
on the link in the description to know
more
so this is our code editor that is
Visual Studio code and now let's create
a new file
and let's name it
encapsulation
dot CPP
so first of all we know in encapsulation
we can make variables inaccessible by
making their scope as private so in this
example we will do that we'll make the
salary of an employer as private and
then using the Saturn gather methods we
will set the value of salary and return
it as well
the center getter methods are generally
used in these kind of situations where
the variable we want to access is
private so now let's start
first of all we will create the main
function but before that let's add the
header files
Now using namespace standard
now we'll start with the main function
and inside the main function first of
all we'll create an object by declaring
the
class name let's say the class name is
company the object name is obj
now using this object we will call the
set function
or we can say the setter function
we will name it as set
salary let's say
and we will pass
two values
thirty thousand and six thousand
one would be the full-time salary and
one would be the overtime
all right now after that we can display
those
and we can write total salary
and
after that we can call the get function
to return the salary
as the getter function is used to return
the output and set function is used to
set the values so we'll write obj dot
get
salary
so the salary we will display over here
and after that we can write the return
zero
now the main function is done now let's
start
with company class company
class company
and inside this class first of all
inside the private scope
this is the private scope
and this is the
variable salary
now this variable salary is private so
no member outside the class can access
it but using the setter and getter
methods we will access this variable and
we will set the salary and then we will
return it
all right
now
public scope inside the public scope
we will
write the setter methods void
set salary
and and full time
and over time
so these are two variables
this 30 000 as we are passing is a
full-time salary and this 6000 is an
overtime salary
so we need to add both of these salaries
in this part so we'll write salary
equals
full time
plus overtime
so this would be the total salary
and let's just do this
all right so this set salary function is
done this is the center function now we
have to return
using the getter function so we'll write
the data type int
get
salary
now inside this function
we will simply return the variable
salary
as we can see
and once the class
you'll use this semicolon all right
pretty much everything is done and now
we can save it
and let's try
as you can see total salary is 36 000 as
30 000 plus 6000 so it is working fine
so this is how we can access these
private variables using this Saturn
getter methods now let's do another
example
this example of encapsulation will also
be pretty much the same we'll do the
saturated methods in this one as well
but in this example we'll find the area
of circle
all right let's start then first of all
we'll include the header files that is
Hash include iostream
and the namespace standard
we also forgot to save this
let's name this one as
first of all the location is work
now let's name it as
an encapsulation
2 dot CPP
all right now the header files that I
did now we'll start with the main
function first of all
now inside this main function we'll
create an object first of all we'll
write the name of the class that is ball
now the name of the object is obj
Now using this obj object we will call
the setter function that is the set area
function and we will pass the radius
all right
obj
dot set
area this is the setup function
now we will pass the radius
now now we can display the area by
calling that getter function but before
that we will display a message
we'll write
foreign
all right now
we will call that getter function
get area
all right the main function is done now
we need to create the class
foreign
private scope inside the private scope
will create that variable
area and let's make its data type as
float because we know that there are
chances that the answer could be in
decimal form because we have to use Pi
in that because the area of circle is pi
R square so 3.14 is the value so that is
why we are using float as the data type
all right now in the public scope
will
set the radius inside this function
set area and
in 3DS this is the radius that is 6 that
we are passing this is the r this is the
parameter and
inside this function area equals we know
that Pi R square is the formula so we'll
write 3.14 that is the value of pi into
radius again into radius R square
all right so this is the area of circle
or ball we can say
after that
float is the data type now we have to
return the area using the getter
function float getter
its name is get area
get area
and we'll simply return the area
variable
all right after that we can use
semicolon in the end
and pretty much everything is done
so let's save it
and let's check it
if it is running fine or not
as you can see area of ball is
113.04 so if we multiply 3.14 that is
the value of pi with 36 that is 6 into 6
it will give you 113.04
so this is the right answer and this is
how we can find the area of ball or
something like that and as you can see
here the area is private and using this
set area and get area methods that is
the Saturn getter methods we are
accessing this private variable that is
area
so these were two examples of
encapsulation you can try these examples
as well hello everyone welcome back to
another video by simply learn in this
session we will discuss an interesting
topic that is exception handling in C
plus plus
so let's go ahead and have a look at
what we will be covering today
so we will start with what are
exceptions then why do we need exception
handling in C plus plus and what
exception handling is
then we will understand exception
handling keywords that is try catch and
throw and we will understand each
keyword in detail
so first we'll start with what are
exceptions
exceptions are the unexpected events or
the situations that arise during the
smooth execution of the program
so there are times during the run time
when some errors or situations arises
which create issues in the program
these issues are called exceptions
for example let us suppose we want to
divide two numbers one is seven and
other one is zero
now if we divide 7 with 0 it will show
an error because we cannot divide any
number by zero because it is undefined
so exception handling provides a way to
take care of problems like these
so now let's learn about exception
handling but before that we must
understand why we need exception
handling
so why do we need exception handling in
C plus plus
one of its reason includes handling the
exceptions that arise during the
execution of the program
along with that exception handling
provides a mechanism through which we
can handle the error generating part
separately from the rest of the code
exception handling provides information
to the user about the problem so that he
or she can detect the mistake and
correct it
now let's go ahead and understand what
exception handling is
as we have discussed exception handling
helps in dealing or handling the
exceptions that disrupts the flow of
execution of a program
so how does it deal with the exception
so when an exception is encountered it
transfers the control from one part of
the program to the other known as
handlers and makes the code more
readable and maintainable
and takes care of the Exception by
providing certain code
these exceptions are handled with the
help of exception handling keywords
now let's understand these exceptional
handling keywords
so there are three exception handling
keywords named try catch and through
as we can see in the example first there
is try block Then followed by three
catch blocks and each catch block
contains the name of the exception
the try block can have more than one
catch block
inside the try block those statements
are enclosed which may cause the
exception or we can say in this block
that particular code is kept which will
throw the exception
each try block is followed by one or
more than one catch block
the try block throws an exception which
is caught by the catch block
taking care or handling the exception is
the actual job of cash block
this block catches the exception thrown
from the try block
inside the catch block a message or some
code is written to handle the exception
it can be a message for the user or a
default code for a particular condition
both the try block and catch block work
together and every try block has at
least one catch block for it
now next is through keyword
whenever an exception is encountered it
helps in throwing the exception
it is used to throw an exception and its
value to the consecutive exception
Handler so as we have discussed this
topic theoretically now let's go ahead
and do its practical implementation in
our code editor that is vs code
so this is our code editor here we will
do an example in which we will make sure
a person who is less than 24 years of
age is not allowed to drink in the club
so we will create an exception in that
part and with the help of try catch and
Roblox we will handle those exceptions
all right so first of all we'll create a
new file
foreign
exception
one dot cpb
all right now we'll start with the
header files that is Hash include
iostream
now the namespace standard
foreign
now we'll start with the main function
and inside the main function first of
all we will declare a variable named h
so
write int age
equals to Let's assign it as 20.
so this person is 20 years of age and
now we will create the try block
so inside this try block
we'll write an if condition that is if
the age of the person is greater than
equal to 24 then only he is allowed to
drink
so inside this we will print a message
saying that
you have
the access to drink the alcohol
all right
so after this
inside the else block
all we need to do is to throw and the
exception that is if the age of the
person is not greater than 24 that is
age is less than 24.
so in that condition
or in that situation we will throw the
exception that is we'll throw age
to the catch block
and for that we have to create the catch
block
so the catch block
will
catch the exception that is age as you
can see now inside this sketch block
first of all we will write a message
we'll write
you'll write you don't have the access
to drink alcohol
you don't have
because your age is less than 24.
foreign
so after this after this message we will
print the age of the person
so we'll write
your age is
so and so and then
the variable h
now after that we'll write return 0
so in this example as you can see the
percentage is 20 as we have assigned and
inside the try block we have set a
condition that if the age of person is
greater than 24 greater than equal to 24
then he or she have the access to drink
the alcohol
and if not if his or her age is not
greater than 24 then we'll throw the
exception and the cash block with cached
exception and will print this message
that you don't have the access to drink
alcohol because your age is less than 24
and then
his age will be printed
so now let's try to run this I hope it
works
as you can see you don't have the access
to drink alcohol because your age is
less than 24 and your age is 20.
and now let's try to if we assign
let's say 25
the program is working fine but we want
to check the other condition as well
okay so it is happening because you
forgot to save this 25
as we have now saved it now let's try to
run this
as you can see you have the access to
drink alcohol because now our age is 25.
so this is how
exception handling works this try block
inside this try block we kept those
code or statements which will throw the
exception
and then it is thrown with the help of
this through keyword and then the catch
block solves or prints a message in with
respect to that exception
so now let's do another example
so let's create a new file
and name it let's say exception
2 dot CBP
all right so here we'll do an example in
which we will try to divide a number by
zero and as we know that we cannot
divide our number by zero so it will
throw an exception
so let's do this example
so first of all our hash include I have
stream the header file
then the namespace standard
now inside the main function you will
create three variables
mean so inside the main function we will
create three variables
one is for the numerator then
denominator and then in which we will
store the output that is the output
variable so let's name numerator as num
and denominator as denum
because it is sounding familiar then
we'll store the output in the output
variable
all right so we have created three
variables num denum and output now
first of all here we will display a
message to enter the numerator and
denominators
so we'll write
please enter
the numbers
to do the division
all right after that handle
now we'll take the input
see in Num and
C in
denum
so the numerator and denominator we have
taken the input from the user
now after that we'll make the try block
so inside this try block
we will create an if condition
and we'll write if denum that is the
denominator is equal to 0 if it is equal
to 0
then
we will throw the exception
and
the exception would be denum
because denominator cannot be zero
and if the genome is not 0 then in else
condition we will simply divide output
equals to
num divided by D num
all right
so now after this we have to create the
catch block also
because we have thrown the exception now
we want the catch to catch the exception
so we can write D for denum here
now we'll print a message saying that
you cannot enter 0 in the denominator
so we will write
you cannot enter
0 and denominator
while doing
the division operation
all right now after that we'll use
handle
so this is our catch block
after this catch block we will again
write a message that the output of the
division is that is if
the denominator is not 0 then we have to
print that result so for that we will
do
this
the output
after
the division is
and here we will
write the variable output
so this will print the result of this
one where the denominator is not 0.
so after that we can write return 0.
so there is one extra bracket as you can
see
of try block
foreign
now it's done we can save this one and
let's try to run this but before running
this one let's go through this code that
first of all we have declared these
three variables then we ask the user to
enter the numerator and denominator
so then we have used this try block and
inside the try block we have set the
condition that if denominator is 0 then
we will throw the exception
and if it is not then we'll simply
divide both of the numerator and
denominator so the denominator which is
thrown is caught by the sketch block
this and it will display a message that
you cannot enter 0 in the denominator
while doing the division operation
because it is undefined
and if the denominator is not 0 then it
will simply print the message and the
output
so now let's try to run this
so as we can see please enter the
numbers to do the division
so let's say the first number is eight
and second number is
0 that is denominator is zero
then you cannot enter 0 in the
denominator while doing the division
operation the output after division is
zero
so it will show this output only and our
output is correct now let's try to run
this and do the simple division
operation in which the denominator is
not zero
so let's say now again we'll write 8 and
the denominator would be 2. then as we
can see the output after the division is
4. so our
code is correct and our output is also
correct so this is how we can do the
exception handling and handle the
exceptions using this try catch and
throw blocks
welcome to this tutorial on C plus plus
vectors so let's jump in and see what's
in it for us
so we will be covering today why we use
vectors in C plus plus what is a vector
in C plus plus and its syntax then we
will go through the member functions of
vectors like modifiers iterators
capacity and we will understand each of
their functions also so first is why we
use vectors in C plus plus
vectors are used when we are not sure
about the size of data like in case of
arrays we have to guess the size of the
data first because it is not possible to
resize it later
but in case of vectors we don't have to
set the size of vector and it is
resizable that is why it is more
preferable for dynamic elements
and it also has some inbuilt functions
like pushback size empty Etc which helps
in dealing with data values
now let's understand what is a vector
vectors are array-like containers that
is used to store data and the data is
stored in contiguous storage locations
but unlike arrays its size can be
changed automatically depending on the
number of elements and it is not
necessary to mention the size of vector
while declaring it
now let's have a look at the syntax here
inside the angle brackets this is the
data type of the vector
it can be string end float Etc and V2 V1
V3 are the names of the vectors
respectively
now let's understand the member
functions of vectors
a vector container has three types of
member functions that is modifiers
iterators and capacity
so let's understand these functions in
detail
first is modifiers
these are those functions that are used
to modify data elements for example
first is pushback function this function
is used to add a new element to the end
of the vector
next is pop back this function deletes
the last element of the vector
then there is insert function it is used
to insert a new element at a specified
position
in this function there are two
parameters first parameter specifies the
position and second specifies the value
after that erase function raise function
is used to remove the elements at a
certain position or to remove a range of
elements
either you can write the position of the
element you want to remove inside the
bracket or you can write starting
position and ending position of the
range of elements inside it
next is swap function this function is
used to swap the contents or elements
between two vectors and if there are two
vectors named V1 and V2
that we want to swap then its syntax
would be V1 dot swap V2
then there is a sine function this
function is used to assign values to the
vector in this function there are two
parameters first one specifies number of
values to be assigned and second
represents the value that is to be
assigned
last is clear function this function is
used to remove all the elements from the
vector
now moving on to iterator functions
these are those functions that helps in
iterating across the elements
first is begin function it basically
Returns the iterator pointing to the
beginning of the vector
the next is end function this function
Returns the iterator pointing to the end
of the vector
now coming to capacity functions
these functions that lie under capacity
are associated with size
so first is size function
this function Returns the number of
elements in the vector
next is Max size function this function
Returns the maximum size that a vector
can hold
then there is resize function this
function changes the size of the
container
and inside the brackets a number n is
mentioned if n is less than the size of
container then content is reduced by
removing extra elements but if n is
greater than the size of the container
then extra elements are added at the end
so that it reaches the size of n
after that capacity function this
function Returns the size that is
currently allocated to the vector
container
at last there is empty function which
checks whether the vector is empty or
not
if it returns true then it is empty and
if false then it is not empty
now to understand these Vector functions
in a better way let's do some examples
of these Vector functions in our code
editor that is vs code
so first of all let's make a new file
and name this file
vector.cpp
now first of all we'll write the header
file that is
hash include
i o stream
now we will write the header file hash
include
vector
this is the header file for Vector
because we are doing some examples on
vectors so that is why we have to use it
now
we'll write the namespace standard
using
namespace
STD
now we'll start with int Main
now first of all we will Define the
vector so we'll write vector
and inside the angle bracket we will
write int which is the data type
now the name of the vector we'll write n
now first of all we'll see the
functionality of assign function
as we know that a sign basically puts
the value at positions
so we will write
n Dot
assign
now first of all we'll write the number
of values
like 9 is the number of values after
that in the second parameter we'll write
the value
here it means that we are putting one to
nine positions in the vector
that is we are assigning one to nine
positions
now in order to print this first of all
we'll
display a message
saying
the contents are
now in order to print these contents
basically we have to
write a for Loop
we'll write tilt a
equals zero
will initialize it from 0
then
a less than
n dot size
this is the size function it basically
Returns the number of elements
now
a plus plus will increment
we have to now print this
we have to write like an array in order
to print all the elements
we'll write
n
and inside the bracket a
now we will leave some space
he will write NL
we wrote handle over here in order to
insert a new line
now after that
we'll see the functionality of one
another function that is pushback
and we know that pushback functions adds
an element at the end of the vector
so we will write n Dot
pushback
and then the element which we want to
add like let's say 2.
thank you
now
we have to display this last element
also so in order to display this we will
store the size of Vector in some
variable and then we will print the last
element
so we will write
int
and no
this is the variable name
then we will write and Dot size
here we are storing the size of the
vector in some variable and no
foreign
will display
last element
will display the message saying last
element
and then we will
print the last element and as we know in
order to print the last element we have
to print the N minus oneth element so we
will write n bracket and no minus 1.
here we are writing and bracket
and no minus 1.
this will print the last element
after that we'll write handle
now after that we will see another
function that is pop back it basically
removes the last element so we'll write
n
pop underscore back
so this function will remove the last
element that we have added that is 2.
so we need to print this also so we'll
write
first of all we'll display a message
now the contents are
now we again write the for Loop
as we have done previously
we'll write int a equals 0
a less than
n dot size
a plus plus
now we will again print
in the form of array
sorry
and and inside the bracket we will write
a
then in order to give some space we'll
write this
after this we'll write handle to add one
new line
so firstly we displayed the contents
then we added one element at the end and
then displayed that element after that
we have removed that element with the
help of popback function
as you have noticed that we are just
doing the functions of modifiers yet so
in this example we will cover some
functions of modifiers only then in the
next examples we will do for iterator
functions and then for the capacity
function
so now let's do the functionality of
insert function
as we know that insert function is used
to add an element at a specified
position so we will write n Dot
insert
and Dot begin
it will point to the first element
then 7.
as we know that the first parameter
specifies position and the second
specifies the value so n dot begin will
point to the first position and 7 is the
value
so now we will print it also
we'll write
first element
is
then we will write
display the first element
then we'll write angle
now we will use the function clear
to remove all the elements we'll write n
dot c l e a r clear
and then in order to check
we will write n dot size so first of all
we'll write now
the size is
and in order to check whether it is
whether all the elements are removed or
not we'll write and Dot size
it will display the size
the program is pretty long but let's
just hope it runs
here it is
now the contents are last element
let's have a look whether it is right or
not
one is displaying nine times then last
element we have added two
then we have removed that element
it is also correct then the first
element we have added using insert 7 is
there and after using clear function
now the size is zero so this is the
correct output
now after doing this function let's try
another example
now here we will do the example of
iterator functions in which first of all
we will add some elements inside the
vector and then we will print them using
iterators
so let's start
first of all name this
vectors
2 dot CPP
now first of all we'll write the header
file
hash include iostream
then
the header file for vectors hash include
vector
then
we'll use namespace standard
now we'll start with int Main
so here we will write vector
and inside the angle brackets we'll
write the data type that is int
and then the name of the vector that is
num
now we will write the for Loop and with
the help of for Loop We'll add the
elements inside the vector one by one so
we will write for
int
I equals 0
I less than
let's say 5
I plus plus
let's make it 1 over here
okay now
after that
will push these elements one by one
inside the vector
so we will write the function
pushback we'll write num Dot
push back
and here I will write I
okay now
because we want to add the elements from
1 to 5 so that is why we have to use
less than equal to because we want to
include 5 also
okay now
we have to print these elements right so
we'll write
first of all we'll display
that output
from
the begin
to the end
okay
now
now we will write for Loop and with the
help of iterators we will print the
elements of vector so we'll write
motto this is the iterator and
a is the it return name
then we'll write num Dot
begin
as we know that begin function points to
the
first element of the vector so that is
why we have written num dot begin
now we will write
a
less than
sorry not equal to
num Dot
end
then a plus plus
now after that we have written a naught
equal to num Dot N and we know that end
function Returns the editor to the end
of the vector
and after that we have used increment
operator
so this Loop will run from beginning
till it reaches to the end and inside
for Loop we will write the D reference
operator with a so that each element
which is getting pointed by a will
display one by one with the help of loop
so let's write
we'll write
C out
D reference operator a
and then we'll give some space
now let's try to run this
[Music]
this is the output output from the
beginning to end
one two three four five this is our
right output this is the message which
we want to display and this is the
output one two three four five which you
want to display which we have added in
the vector and then we have displayed
so now let's do
another example which includes the
capacity function
so
we'll make another file
Vector 3 dot CPP
so in this example we will add some
elements in the vector and then we will
apply some functions on it
so let's start
first of all we'll include the header
file
hash include iostream
then
the header file for vectors hash include
vector
then we'll write the namespace standard
using name
space STD
okay now we will write int Main
so first of all we'll write vector
and then the data type
and then the name of the vector let's
say V
now one by one we'll put some elements
inside the vector so we'll write for
Loop
we'll start with int x equals 0
X
less than equal to 10
X plus plus
because we want to add these elements
so we will write V Dot
push back
and then we will write X inside the
brackets
semicolon
now here one by one all the elements
from
0 to 10 will be added let's make it 1.
1 to 10.
okay now
we will apply some functions on this
vector
so let's first of all try out the size
function so first of all we'll write
vector
size
is
and then we'll write the function V Dot
size
size and then we'll write
handle
so this function will tell us the size
of the vector because we have already
added the elements from 1 to 10 so it
will display 10
after that we will use the try out the
capacity function
we'll write
capacity of vector is
and then we will write V Dot
capacity
after that here also we'll write endl
now
we will use the maximum size
or the max size so we'll write
the maximum
size
of
Vector is
so in order to calculate the maximum
size we write V Dot
Max
underscore
size
handle
As We Know That V Dot size will give us
the size of the vector and capacity
function this function Returns the size
that is currently allocated to the
vector container
and Max size this function Returns the
maximum size of the vector
so all of these functions
result will be displayed because we have
wrote them inside C out
now
let's try another function
that is resize
now in order to resize the vector we'll
write V Dot
resize and then we'll write
the number that we want to resize it
with like let's write 5.
now in order to check this also we will
display
so we'll write
Vector size
after resizing
resizing is
I forgot to put the commas
okay now we'll write
V Dot size because now we want to find
the size after resizing
so we have written B dot size
now
after that
we will write and L
okay
now we'll try the empty function
we'll put empty function inside if
now inside if we'll write V Dot empty
equals equals false
it means
if the vector is not empty because we
have written V Dot empty equal equal to
false not true we have written V Dot
empty equal to equal to false that means
if it is not empty then
will display
Vector is not empty and in else
condition we will write Vector is empty
so here we will write
C out
back
again I forgot to put over here
okay
vector
is not empty
and in else condition
foreign
Vector is empty
so in this question first of all we have
added some elements inside a vector then
we have used V Dot size function then V
Dot capacity function then Max size
function after that we have resized the
vector and then check it for the size of
it after that we use V Dot empty
function
so now let's try to run this code
okay I think we have done something
wrong
we haven't put the brackets over here
okay now let's try again
here it is
Vector size is 10
because we have put 1 to 10 then
capacity of vector is 16 okay then Max
size of vector is this
then Vector size after resizing because
we have done we have wrote the number
five as we can see so that is why Vector
size after resizing is 5.
and Vector is not empty as we know
because inside the vector there are five
elements so it is not empty which is
true
so
these were some examples of vectors in C
plus plus
you can try some more examples on it you
can practice some more examples and in
today's session we will learn about C
plus plus STL
in this session we will learn about what
is STL then we will understand the
components of STL like containers
iterators algorithms and function
objects so without further delay let's
get started
STL stands for standard template Library
it is a set of template classes that
provide us data structures and
algorithms for containers it allows the
programmer to use predefined functions
which helps them to write the code
quickly and in an efficient way
for example you are solving a problem
that's needs sorting now instead of
writing the code to sort you can make
use of STL
now STL mainly consists of four
components that is containers iterators
algorithms and function objects so first
is containers
these are collection of objects that
store data of similar type in STL we
have different types of containers some
of them are array Vector set map and
these containers are generic in nature
so further these containers are of three
types that is sequence container
associative container and container
adapters
sequence containers these are those
containers that can be accessed
sequentially for example Vector DQ list
are some of the containers that store
data in a linear form
next is associative container these are
those containers that Implement sortie
data structures in this elements are
retrieved via keys and each associative
container maintain its keys in sorted
order
example set multiset map and multi-map
after that container adapters these
containers are like sequential
containers but they are implemented by
modifying their interface to provide the
desired behavior for example stack queue
and prior to queue are some examples of
container adapters
now coming to iterators in STL iterator
plays an important role as it links
algorithms and containers iterators are
those entities that helps in traversing
through containers they are used to
point at the memory address of the STL
containers
iterators also helps in traversal from
one element to the next element in the
range using operators like increment
operator
iterator contains two functions that is
begin function and N function the begin
function Returns the iterator to the
first element and the end function
Returns the iterator to the last element
now coming to algorithms
algorithms in STL can be defined as
procedure that are applied to the
container and provide some operations on
the content of the container and because
STL algorithms are built in so that is
why they save considerable amount of
time
in algorithms we just have to make a
function call and we don't have to write
the lines of code to implement it
now let's have a look at types of
algorithms
first is modifying algorithm
non-modifying algorithm sorting
algorithm searching algorithm and
numeric algorithm
modifying algorithms are those
algorithms that make changes to the
sequences Swap and reverse functions are
some examples of it
then non-modifying algorithm
non-modifying algorithm are basically
read-only function they do not modify
the data on which they work on some
examples are count equal and search
functions
then sorting algorithms this algorithm
is used to sort the container elements
its example is sort function
next is searching algorithm as the name
suggests this algorithm searches for the
element binary search algorithm is
mostly used search algorithm
last is numeric algorithm this algorithm
work on numeric values or we can say it
solves some numeric problems examples
are accumulate function and partial some
functions
now coming to function objects
function objects are also known as
functors a function object is an object
of template class that implements call
operator
this call Operator allows the object to
be used with same syntax as regular
function call
for example suppose you have declared an
object obj of a class in which operator
is defined
then you can use the object obj just
like a normal function
function objects also helps in
generating the data and it also helps in
testing purposes
now in order to do some examples let's
move to our code editor that is vs code
so here we will do an example of vector
container so let's make a new file
let's name it stl.cpb
now we'll add the header files
now writing namespace standard
now we will add before namespace
standard we have to add the header file
for vectors
because we are doing the example of
vector so that is why we have to add the
header file or vector
foreign
we'll write int Main
now first of all we'll declare the
vector so we'll write vector
int
within the angle brackets now we will
write
the name of the vector that is V
okay now we have to push
some elements inside the vector for that
we have to use for Loop so we'll write
for keyword
and I equals
let's say 1
I less than
equals 10
I plus plus that is increment operator
okay now we have to push the elements
one by one so we'll write V Dot
push back
and inside the bracket we will put I
so the elements will keep on adding one
by one at the end of the vector
so now we will check the size of the
vector so we'll write
we'll write the message size
and then the function B dot size
it will tell us the size of the vector
that is the number of elements inside it
as we can see that we have put Talent
elements inside the vector one by one so
it must be 10.
so in order to check it we have used
this function V Dot size
okay now we'll use another function
that is V Dot resize
it will resize the size of the vector
so whatever we put inside this bracket
like let's say I've put seven so its
size now would be 7.
and we need to check this also
so we'll again use the function
size so first of all we'll display the
message
after
resizing
it becomes
V Dot size
it will print the size of the vector
after resizing okay
now
we use another function V Dot empty for
that we have to use if condition
so we'll write
V Dot empty
brackets
we know that if V Dot empty equals true
then it means it is empty and if it
equals false then it means it is not
empty so we'll simply display the
message that it is not empty
all right C out
and now we'll write let's slash n
not empty
before go to
write the
over here okay
now in else
we will write
it is empty
it is empty
we can also do this the other way around
like we can put B dot empty equals to
true and then inside that bracket we can
write it is empty but it's your choice
okay now
we'll display the elements of the vector
for that we have to first
write the message so we'll write
elements of vector
then after this using for Loop and
iterator we will print those elements
so let's do this we'll write for
and inside for Loop we'll write
Auto
ID here the auto keyword specifies the
type of variable that is being declared
will be automatically deducted from the
initializer and it is the iterator
now we'll write i t equals V Dot begin
and We Know That V Dot begin function
will point to the first element of the
vector
so after that we'll write
i t
not equal to V Dot end
and it will point to the last element of
the vector
now we'll write i t plus plus
now
will print the iterator using D
reference operator
and in order to make some space we'll
write this
now we return 0.
okay now
let's try to run this
okay
here's the problem I think
now let's try one another time
here it is size 10
after that after resizing it becomes
seven
firstly we add the elements by pushing
one by one using the pushback function
10 elements were added so size is 10
after that we have resized it so after
resizing it becomes seven
and then we have used the function empty
so it was not empty so that is why the
message display is not empty then the
elements of vector
the forgot to put space over here in
elements of vector one two three four
five six seven
and that is correct
okay
now we'll do one example of iterator
in this example we'll simply
print the elements of a vector using
iterator
so first of all let's name this
stl2.cpp
now we'll write the header files
hash include iostream
in this we'll add three header files
now we'll write
hash include
iterator
because we have to use iterator so that
is why we are doing this
and we also have to use the vector so
we'll write hash include
vector
now we'll write namespace standard
now we'll start with int Main
so first of all we'll declare a vector
in which there are some elements as in
previous question we already learned how
to add elements in a vector so in this
question we'll simply declare those
elements inside a vector so we'll write
vector
in inside the angle brackets
now let's say AR is the name of this
vector
now we'll write the
elements
five five elements are there
now we have to declare iterator to a
vector
so this is how we'll do it we'll write
vector
then
the data type inside the angle brackets
then after this we'll write the scope
resolution operator
like this now iterator
keyword
then the name of the iterator that is
PTR
now we'll display the vector elements
using for Loop and using the functions
begin and end
so we'll write
first of all we have to display a
message
okay we'll write
the elements
of vector
r
okay
now semicolon
Now using for Loop
will write
the PTR that is the iterator
AR
dot begin
as we know that AR is the name of the
vector
AR dot begin begin function will point
to the first element of the vector
then
PTR
less than a r dot
end
we know end function
and function will point to the last
element of the vector
okay now we'll write
AR plus plus
sorry PTR plus plus
now we have to display it and
we'll display it using the reference
operator and the name of iterator that
is PTR
we'll make some space
now at last we'll write return 0.
now let's try to run this
the elements of vector r as you can see
the elements of vector are one two three
four five
so this is how you can print the
elements of a vector using the iterator
here is the vector and with the help of
iterator we have printed these elements
one two three four five
now we'll do one simple example of
algorithm
first of all let's name this
htl3.cpp
now in this example we'll use swap
algorithm to swap two integers
and we know that swap is an template
function so let's do this first of all
we'll write
hash include iostream
Now using namespace standard
will start with int Main
now first of all we declare a variable
let's say seven
and
second variable
let's say 10.
first of all we'll display the value of
these variables that
before swapping and after swapping so
that is where
we will write
value of I
now here we'll write
value of J
handle
okay now we'll use the swap algorithm
and here we'll mention the elements we
want to swap I comma J
it will simply swap the contents of
these two elements
now we'll write
after swapping
handle
will do same for J
this is a very basic example but we have
to see the functionality of it
we'll write
handle
okay
now we'll write return 0.
now we'll run this
yeah value of I 7 value of J is 10 after
swapping I 10 j7
it will look
better if we have root like this
let's make it look good
yeah value 5 is 7 value of J is 10 after
swapping I becomes 10 and J becomes 7.
so this is how we can swap the elements
using swap algorithm there are some more
algorithms you can write those as well
and now at last we'll do one example of
function object
let's name this as stl4.cpp
all right now
we'll add the header file hash include
IO stream
now we'll write namespace standard
now in this question first of all we'll
start with the function so first of all
we'll make a class
function
obj
now we'll write access specifier public
int
here we'll write the call operator
as we know the syntax
operator
bracket
then
another bracket for the arguments
and X
comma and
y
so this is the syntax of it and now
whatever you want to do with these two
variables let's say we want to multiply
so we'll write return X
into y
all right
as this is a class so we have to write
the semicolon
now we'll write int Main
okay now we'll write int main after int
Main
here we will write the name of the class
because
we have to define the object of it now
the object is f o
so here class name is function obj and
its object is fo and as I have explained
earlier here I can use F4 object like a
normal function because f o is the
object of class function obj in which
call Operator is defined so it will act
like a normal function
so now
we'll make a variable let's say multiply
so we'll write mult equals F4
and because it acts like a normal
function so we'll pass the parameters
four and seven
now in order to display we'll write C
out and
we'll write
multiplication
of X and Y
is
now we'll write the name of the variable
mult
because the result is getting stored in
multi variable now we'll write return 0.
now let's try to win this
here we can see multiplication of X and
Y is 28 and that is true 4 into 7 equals
28
so it is working and this is the example
of functor or function object
so these were some basic examples of
components of STL you can practice some
more examples on them in order to learn
in this video we will learn about C plus
plus enumeration so let's go ahead and
have a look at what we'll be covering
today
first is why enumerations are used in C
plus plus then we'll understand what is
enumeration and its syntax and after
that we will learn how to use enums with
flex first is why enums are used in C
plus plus
enums are short for enumerations
these are basically used when we have
some set of possible values and we have
to select one out of it for example
suppose you are the shop owner and you
have four types of coffee in your coffee
machine that is cold coffee hot coffee
black coffee and mocha and you don't
want the trouble of customer putting any
other coffee name in The Machine
which is not there
then in situations like this
enumerations are used
because in enumerations we have to
choose from predefined values and it is
also helpful for documentation and
readability purpose
now let's understand what is enumeration
enum or enumeration is a user-defined
data type in which a set of values are
specified for the variable and the
variable can take out any value from the
set of values and it is also a way to
use integers to represent values we can
assign values to enum but if we do not
assign any value then the compiler
assigns value to them starting from 0.
coming to its syntax
which is enum that is the keyword for
enumerator type then enumerator type
name is written then under brackets
possible values of type enum are written
for example here enumeration name is
player and values are Ronaldo's Laha
Messi Neymar which are the names of
players
in this example by default Ronaldo is
zero salaha is one message is to Neymar
is 3. because we know by default
compiler assigns them value which start
from 0 and so on
but we can change these default values
by assigning values to them like here
Ronaldo's value is now 4 salaha's value
is 2 Messi's value is 8 Neymar's value
is 1.
now let's have a look at an example in
which we will print the default value of
months
so in this example we have enum name as
months and enumerated values as January
February March and so on
and in order to access these values we
have written enumeration name and after
that the variable
as we can see inside main function m is
the variable and its type is months now
here we have assigned the month March to
the variable n and then we are printing
the variable M plus 1. here plus 1 will
print the value next to the month March
that is 3 and similarly if we write plus
2 then it will print then 1 next to it
that is 4. these values are default
integer values
after printing the output value is 3.
because we have printed M plus 1 where m
is 2 and plus 1 makes it 3.
now let's understand how to use enum
with flags
in this example we will choose a mobile
having any of the two features among
three
here the name of enumeration is mobile
and its enumerated values are battery
capacity camera quality large storage
and we have assigned values to them 1 2
and 4 respectively and because we are
doing this example of enums with flags
that is why we are using integer values
of power 2 because it avoids the
overlapping
inside the main function we are using
bitwise or operator because we want to
choose the mobile having both camera
quality and large storage capacity and
we know that bitwise operator adds the
binary of two integers
so the value of camera quality is 2 and
value of large storage is 4.
when we use a bitwise or operator in
between these two features so it will
add up their binary giving the decimal
number as 6. so the output 6 is showing
both the camera quality and large
storage are used
now let's do some examples of
enumeration in our code editor that is
vs code
okay now let's make a new file
and name the file as
enum.cpv
in this example the enumeration name
will be Captain and the enumerated
values will be the team members out of
which we will select one member as
Captain and with if condition we will
verify if he is the selected captain or
not
it will be a basic example so first of
all let's write hash include iostream
now we'll add the namespace standard
okay now we'll write enumeration enum
Captain which is the name of the
enumeration type
and now we will write the numerated
values
which is let's say
a v
said
Robbie
Sami
and Jake
these are the team members
now we'll write int Main
now here we will first of all write
Captain which is the name of the
numerator type
then we'll make the variable out of it
cap
and let's say a v is the captain so
we'll write a v
now here we will write if condition
we'll write if
cap equal to a v
then we'll display
our captain is away and its value is
whatever the value the obvious value
here is 0 so we'll display that
so we'll write
our captain
is a v
and its value
is
then we'll write a v
as we know that a v is at First Position
then its value would be default value
would be zero
Okay so
here we will write handle
now in else
here if we put said row b semi Jake as
Captain or we if we declare them as
Captain then this message would be
declared which we will be writing in
else
so the message would be
he is not our captain
then over here we will write return 0.
okay now let's try to run this
our captain is away and its value is
zero
because here Captain we have declared a
v so that is why this is
printing if we write let's say Sami over
here
thank you
then it will print the else part
he's not our captain and if we write
Jake or said
then also it will print the same
he's not a captain
only in case of a v it will print our
captain is away and its value is
value so this was the basic example of
enumeration now let's move on to one
another example
no
let's make a new file
and name it as enum2
dot CPT
okay
now we will add the header files hash
include irstream
and using namespace standard
so here we will do an example in which
enumeration name will be supercars and
to the values we will assign some
integers to them which will be the speed
of those cars and then we will compare
them using comparison operator in terms
of speed
so
we'll write enum
the name of enumeration that is let's
say supercars
okay
now inside the bracket
will write the name of the cars which
are the values
and we will assign some integers
these integers are actually speed of
these cars
2 6 268
then Valkyrie
speed is 240.
now
Roadster
250.
yeah
okay now as you have created the enum
now we will start within Main
so we will write the numerator type name
supercars
now the variable speed 1 because we want
to create two variables in order to
compare them so first we will create
speed one
now again
speed 2.
now we will assign the two cars that we
want to compare to these variables
so speed 1 will be
Valkyrie
and Speed 2 would be
Roadster
okay now we will write the if condition
and inside the if condition we will
compare the speed of these two cars
so we will write speed one
if speed 1 is less than
speed 2.
okay
then we will print
that it's a win for Roadster because
Speed 2 is Road certain speed one is
Valkyrie so we'll write it's a win for
Roadster
with the speed we'll also write the
speed with the speed
of
this Speed 2 will display the speed of
Roadster that is 250.
okay now else condition
so here we will write
it's a win for valkyrie
with the speed
of
here we will write speed 1.
okay
now we have to write into main but
before that we will write the brackets
which we forgot to mention
returns zero
okay I think it's done now let's try to
run this
thank you
here we can see it's a Win 4 Roadster
with the speed of 250. as we know that
the speed of Roadster here is 250 and
the valkyrie speed is 240 so when we
compare it
Speed 2 that is Roadster winds because
Roadster is 250.
so this was the second example now let's
do one last example
foreign
let's name this
okay
enum3 dot CPP
we'll write hash include iostream
now namespace standard
now in this example we will see how to
use switch statement with the
enumeration
Okay so
first of all
inside int Main
we will write
enum
color is the name of the enumeration
type
then we'll write the values
red
blue
green
and yellow
these are the values
now here we will use switch statement
but before doing that we have to assign
one color to a variable
so first of all we have to create that
variable and in order to create the
variable we will write the numeration
type name color
and then
the variable name select
now we will assign one color from the
above colors
let's say yellow
now in switch statement we will write
first of all we'll write switch
statement
switch and
we will pass here the variable that is
Select
basically we are passing yellow because
yellow is assigned to the variable
select and that is why it is getting
passed so now case 1 that is case red
first of all we'll write the case red
with a colon in the end now we will
print that it is red
now we'll write the break statement
break statement basically ends the case
or terminates the case
so after that
the second case that is case blue
colon
now here we will print
it is blue
and similarly
break statement
we'll do same for all of these colors
green and yellow also
and switch statement will help us to
find which color is passed and will
display the message of that color
so here we will write green
it is green
break statement
now case yellow
now we'll write it is yellow
okay
now he will write break
okay now at last we have to write return
0.
now as we know that we have we have
passed a particular color
to the variable select and select is the
expression and switch statement will
help us in comparing the variable select
value to the value of different blocks
and one which matches that particular
block will execute
okay now let's try to run this one
foreign
here we can see
it is yellow is being printed
which is the right answer because we
have passed the color yellow to the
select that is why only the case yellow
output is being printed
so
this is how you can use switch statement
with the numeration
so these are some basic examples of C
plus plus illumination you can try some
more examples on it in order to practice
it
in this session we are going to learn
about C plus plus GUI that is graphical
user interface and how to configure
visual studio and make a GUI application
so without further Ado let's get started
to develop C plus plus GUI or C plus
plus graphical user interface apps we
must have an IDE that supports C plus
plus GUI applications and visual studio
is one of the best IDE for that here IDE
stands for integrated development
environment
there are many versions of visual studio
for GUI apps but I suggest you to
download visual studio 2019
there are three editions of Visual
Studio 2019 that is community
professional and Enterprise
we can download the Community Edition
once the visual studio is downloaded and
installed then you need to launch this
application after that you can select
the color theme
and change the development settings to
visual C plus
then the visual studio will look like
this
then here we will click on this create a
new project
and now we have to search for a project
template named CLR empty project.net
framework
so we'll type CLR
empty project.net framework here it is
make sure that there is dotnet framework
over here
now all we have to do is to click on
this
and select next
now here we can name our project let's
say I have named IT project 2 and we can
select the location
and now we can click on this create
button
now our project is being created
so here it is
so now let's create a form file by going
to the project
then add item
add new item
now here visual C plus plus under visual
C plus plus we'll click on UI and then
Windows Form we'll click on this Windows
Form and
click on this add button
so our file is loading
so it will show you this error but you
don't need to worry about this one you
can simply close it
now we will go to Project
then into properties
then now we'll click on this Linker
open this Linker
now we'll go to the system
then inside this subsystem
over here
we'll select windows here it is
now after doing this then we go to
Advanced
and in advance we can change this
entry point to Main
we'll write mi in Main
this mean is the starting function
now we can press OK over here
now you need to open this myform.cpp
here it is and you have to copy this
code
and just paste it over here
we will add this code in the description
you can take this code from there and
add it
now make sure to write your project name
over here
like my project name is Project 2 so
I'll write
project
2.
yes
so after doing this we can save it by
pressing Ctrl and S
and now we can go to myform.h
here we can see there is no form so we
need to save it and close this
Visual Studio once
now we need to open the visual studio
again
we'll go over here we'll write Visual
Studio 2019 here it is we'll click on
this
and this is launching
we can click on this project too
now let's go to
myform.h
we'll click on this
it is getting loaded
here we can see the form earlier we are
only able to see the code but now we can
see this form
now we can check this by running it by
clicking on this local Windows debugger
button we'll click on that
and let's see if it is running or not
it will take some time
so here it is it is running properly as
you can see this is my the my form
and this is ready to use so it is the
debugging is going on so if we have to
close the debugging or stop the
debugging we can click on this cross
button
so the debugging is closed now and we
have verified that the form is running
correctly
we can also add some buttons and labels
to this form like this we can click on
this toolbox then we can select this
button
and we can click this over here
so this is our button and we can select
some more labels
all right we can click on this toolbox
again and select another button
like this over here
and now we can select a label let's say
and click over here
and we can also adjust the size of these
buttons
like this
and like this we can adjust the size and
this is the label
we have to adjust his size by setting
its format we can do it by clicking on
this label and going to properties
over here we can see as you have clicked
on the label
so we can see the text that is label one
here we can see text
label one so it is this text which is
written we can change this one
by clicking on this we can select
hello there we can write like this and
it will be shown over this side
now
we must click
the label first then only we can access
the button or label
so now let's say this is the font so we
can click on this font and adjust this
here it is let's say
I have just did it to 18 size and made
it bold now we can click this okay over
this side so here we can see hello there
it is bold now similarly we can do this
for button as well as we have clicked on
this button as you can see now I can go
to this properties
now
inside this properties there is text
that is button one we can see we can
change this like we can write click here
and we can also adjust its font
here it is
let's say 12.
and bold oblique you click on this okay
and here it is
click here
you can adjust it over there and suppose
if you want to delete some button or
label or something like that so we can
click on this and
right click on this side and here we can
see delete we'll click on this delete
and it will be deleted
there are more options in toolbox like
there is text box
list box list View
picture Box
checkbox Etc we can select as per our
choice and we can adjust its layout or
editing by going to the properties
column
so now let's make a calculator program
so for that we have to create a
calculator layout so let's just delete
all these
delete this one and we'll delete this
one as well
now we'll go to the toolbox
and select a text box we can search it
over here
text box
here it is we can click on that
and put it over here
here it is
we have to adjust its formatting
so we'll go to properties and we'll go
to font
we click on this font
now let's say adjust it to
22. and
make it bold
bold oblique yes now I'll click on this
okay
and
we have to create another one so
instead of doing this all we can copy
this one and to copy this we can go to
this side and click right click over
here
and we can click on this copy
and then we can paste it
here it is because we have to enter two
numbers and for that we need to have two
text boxes for a calculator
all right now in between we can mention
the operation or operator whatsoever for
that we can we have to select the label
and we'll go to toolbox
and
here it is
text box
but we have to select label
all right
label
we click on this label and
put it over here
now we have to adjust it
now here we will write let's say it's
font would be 20 and
it would be bold oblique
it will look nice then click on OK
now we have to adjust what is written
inside it so we can go to text and click
on this
label one now
we can write operator
but it would be so long so we can write
op that means operator
all right
it gives the idea
about the operator
we have to adjust it a bit
all right here it is and
okay now we have to create a buttons for
addition subtraction multiplication so
we'll go to toolbox
and now we'll
search for buttons
we'll click on button and put it over
here
and now we'll adjust it by going to
properties
and go into fonts
let's adjust it to
22 and make it bold
now we'll click on OK
and now we have to change the label of
it first of all let's select
its layout like this
it would be made
now we'll go to properties
and we'll go to text
and
will make an addition sign over here
and now I'll click on this so here we
can see so now we'll copy this button to
create the next three buttons so
click on this copy and paste it
will do this for the other two as well
and we'll change the text by going to
properties later onwards
here it is
so first we'll be addition then here
let's make it subtraction we're going to
properties we'll click on this
properties
now
let's make this text as
minus
all right now we can also change the
color of this text
let's say
we can make this
foreign
here it is blue in color now we'll
change this one we'll go to properties
and make this as
sign of multiplication but we'll press X
so that it will look nice
all right now this one will go to
properties and change this to
division sign
and we can change this one as well
it will look nice let's make it this
similar color to the subtraction
all right here it is here are four
buttons addition subtraction
multiplication and division
now we have to display the result as
well so we'll go to toolbox
and we'll search for label
we'll click on this label
and put it over here
all right
let's make it like this and let's put it
about this side it will look nice over
here
property is now we have to adjust it
let's make it 22 bold oblique
okay
here is our result and let's name it as
result as well we'll go to text here it
is labeled to return
we'll write result
now whatsoever operation is done its
result or output is displayed over this
side now all we need to do is to add the
functionality to these buttons
so let's do that we'll click on this
two times
on this button and the button name
actual name of that button is button one
so here it is
so this part is for button one and we
know that button one is addition so we
need to do addition over here
so let's start
first of all we'll
have to declare a variable
hint result or output or answer
whatsoever we want let's write output
now to add those we need the names of
those two text boxes so we'll go to
format design
and we need these names both of these
text box names so we'll click on this
first and we'll go to properties so here
it is text box one we can see and we
click on this
and properties this is text box 2. and
this is similarly this is button one
button two button three button 4. we can
check this by going to properties and by
clicking them and going to properties so
this is text box one and this is text
box two
so now we know the names
now all we have to do
is to write
text box
text box where B is capital
we have to write the exact name we can
check it over here that this is text box
we can check the spelling this is
textbooks too this is label one this is
button one this is button two we can
check the spellings from there now
now we have to use the
Arrow operator
we'll write like this this is the air
operator this will give us the access to
the members of the object
all right so
we have to change the text so we'll
write text
T capital
all right now we have to add
the text box too
and we'll do it same
we'll write this our operator
and text
now this Edition which we have written
over here is ROM
because we are actually adding the
strings
as you can see
when we type any number over here it is
a string and same goes for this part
so we have to convert it
first we will convert both of these text
to integer and then we will
again convert the result into string
because we have to display it over here
and for that we need a string so then
again we have to convert it to the
string and let's do it
so what we gonna do is we'll write
system
and then this scope resolution operator
convert
again scope resolution inverter
operator sorry to
end
16.
I must be Capital keep in mind to int
16.
all right now here we'll write
text
box with B capital
and then this Arrow operator
and we'll write text
all right
after that sign of addition
again we'll do the same System Scope
resolution operator
convert scope resolution operator
to
end
16
and
text box 2 here we have to write text
box 2.
Arrow operator
text
all right
here is the addition part now we have to
display the result
now to that first check the name of the
result like this is the result we'll
click on this and go to properties
its name is label 2. so we have to make
the changes into label 2. we'll go to
this
for match
now we'll
have to change the text that is we have
to change the result that is written
into the output
so for that we will write Label 2 which
is the name
then this Arrow operator
after that we'll write text because we
have to change it
and then
we'll write system
scope resolution operator
convert
scope resolution operator
to
string because we have to display the
output into string
as I have already told you
all right
now
over here we have to write output
this output
okay
so let's check if it is working or not
we'll go to local Windows debugger and
click on this
hope it works
here it is
my form
so let's try to add let's say five
plus nine
and we'll click on this add button
14 and we know that 5 plus 9 equal to 14
so
it is working fine we can see and now we
have to do this for all the buttons that
is subtraction multiplication and
division so let's go ahead and do that
let's first close this debugging
you have stopped the debugging and we'll
go to this
now we have to do that for
the next three buttons will
all right
now we'll click on this subtraction
button two times
here we can see
now
the code is same for all of these and
so we can copy the code from here
and we have just copied it and we'll
paste it and will make the
changes in the sign like I have used
here minus sign for the subtraction
and the rest is good yeah
all right now we'll do it for the next
one that is
multiplication
I'll double click on that and here it is
we'll copy the code from here
and paste it
will change the sign
the subtraction note the multiplication
sign this is this multiplication sign
and now
the next one that is division
here we go
we'll again select
copy
and paste
let's change the sign of this as well
okay
as we have done the changes so let's
save it by pressing Ctrl and S
and
it is saved now let's try to run this
hope it works we'll click on this local
Windows debugger
it usually takes some time and here it
is so let's try now five
Plus
six let's do this first of all Edition
11 now
we'll do
20 minus 6 so we'll click on this minus
and 20 minus 6 equals to 14 that's right
and now we'll do 20 into
3 that is 60. click on this multiply
sign 20 into 3 that is 60 it is right
now let's say
15 and
3 yeah
we click on divide and this is 5. so all
of our buttons is working fine so this
is how we can create a calculator
in Visual Studio 2019
you can also create this calculator
program in your PC all you need to do is
to download visual studio 2019 and
install it and you can follow the steps
and you can create this calculator
application in this session we'll make a
project in C plus plus
this project will be a hotel management
project in which we will have the
information of the items or rooms that
we have in the hotel and what are the
food items ordered by the customer
also we have the information that how
many rooms are allotted to them
also this project will tell us about the
sales and the remaining food stocks we
have and the total collection of the day
we will make this project in three parts
firstly we'll discuss the first part in
which we will declare some variables and
then initialize them after that we will
enter the quantities of items that we
have in the hotel
then we'll make a list of items or menu
of items and rooms that we have in the
hotel
so let's start
now we'll switch to our code editor that
is Dev C plus plus
so this is a code editor so here first
of all let's make a new file
we'll click on file and now we'll create
a new file
so now let's start with the project so
first of all inside the main function we
have to declare some variables but
before that we will
write the header files that is Hash
include I have stream
and then the namespace standard
foreign
so we have included the header files now
we'll start with the main function
inside the main function
we will declare the variable
so first variable that we'll declare
would be Quant which stands for quantity
and the second variable would be choice
now we will declare those variables that
store the quantity of food items or
rooms so let's say
the variable which will store the
quantity of rooms would be queue rooms
and
we have to initialize it also
all right so similarly we have to do it
with the food items as well so let us
suppose one of our food item is faster
so we'll write Q pasta that is quantity
pasta
will initialize it with 0
similarly we'll do with the rest of the
food items
that is Burger
noodles
and Shake
and chicken
your chicken would be let's say chicken
roll
so these are our food items so these
variables will hold the quantity of
these food items
so now we will declare those variables
which will hold the value of the number
of food items that have been sold so for
example Q pasta holds the value of
number of pastas we had in a hotel and
as pasta will hold the value of number
of pastas that have been sold
so let's start
similarly we'll write s rooms that is
sold rooms
we have to initialize it with 0 as well
and S pasta
similarly s Burger
as noodles
as chicken
all right
now we'll create some more variables
that will store the price of the total
price of each of these food items or
rooms so let's do that let's say in
total
underscore rooms this is the variable
name it will store the total price of
the rooms
we will initialize it with zero
similarly
total
pasta
equals zero
total
Burger
all right so these variables holds the
quantity of food we have these variables
holds the quantity of food we sold and
these variables will hold the price the
total price of each of the food items or
rooms
so let's
comment it this holds quantity
so that it's easy for you guys
all right so here we have declared these
variables
now now we will make a list kind of a
structure in which we will ask
the user to enter the number or
quantities of food items or rooms that
we have in the hotel
so
all right now let's do this
first of all we have to display a
message
but before that we'll use slash in and
slash T So slash N means the next line
and slash T will add a horizontal space
in the output so we need that horizontal
space
so we'll write
foreign
let's say items only quantity of items
we have
we have in a hotel
all right
now
we'll write rooms available
so we'll add slash n and
rooms
available
all right so after this
we will write C in and take the input of
quantity of rooms we have because here
we are asking to enter the number of
rooms we have
so we'll write C in
Q rooms because it holds the quantity of
rooms we have
we have initialized it with zero
similarly we'll do it for the rest like
quantity of pasta like this will do
inside the
slashing
now we'll write the quantity of pasta
C in
Q pasta
all right
now similarly
let's copy paste and save some time
so this first was the pasta then Burger
foreign
then there was noodles
chew noodles
similarly we'll do it for Shake
and then
hit chicken is the chicken roll
so quantity of chicken rule
cute chicken
all right
so
one by one Q room the quantity of rooms
we have to add Q pasta the quantum pasta
we have to add then Quantum Burger we
have
all right now we have to create a menu
to select the pasta Burger room all the
items we have to create a menu like that
and for that let's do this
we'll write C out again we'll use
slash in
slash and then
again slash d slash
T because we want some horizontal space
in that
will display a message saying that
please select from the given menu
options
foreign
so it's a message for the users
or the customers I would say
now again we'll use slashing
because I want to add some new lines
so I'll use two selection
now
first is rooms
secondly we'll use only one slation
and
here we are creating the menu to select
the food items or rooms
so now we will write
pasta
and similarly we'll copy paste
foreign
chicken roll
we also have to change the remaining
that this is one this is two then this
is three we are doing the numbering
because the customer will press the
number
and then he can order
five
six
and now again we'll
in seventh position We'll add the
details or information regarding the
collection in sales
so
we'll write
press 7 if you want to see the
information
regarding
sales
and collection
this option would be used by the owner
of the hotel to check the total
collection for the day
all right now again
the eighth number
this word
if you want to exit
yeah
so this is done now after that we'll
display a message saying that
please enter your choice
so we'll use slash and slashing and
right
please enter your choice
now we'll write C in choice we have
already declared this variable
now based on this Choice your order is
selected like if you press 2 then this
pasta would be selected like let's say
if you want to order noodles then you
have to select four and if you want to
order Chicken Roll then you have to
select six and if you want to check the
total sales and connect collection of
today
that is for a particular day then you
have to click seven and eight for the
exit
so a first part is done now in the
second part we have to add the
functionality to the choice part that is
if a user enters the first number that
is number one then rooms is selected and
then he or she have to add the numbers
of rooms they want
similarly for the other food items as
well like if they want to take two
burgers or three burgers instead of one
and we only have one Burger left then
also we have to display a message saying
that only so and so burgers are left
so now let's start with it
so now we'll write switch case
statements so when the user will select
a particular number
so that particular case would be
executed
so now let's do that
right switch
and
inside the switch statement
will write choice
now the choice can be one two three four
five six seven eight
all right so now we have to create eight
cases for that
so case one would be
we'll start with it there's a space
between case and one all right so case
one would be
first of all inside the case one
that is the case when rooms have to be
selected so first of all we'll display a
message saying that enter the number of
rooms you want
so let's do that
you slash n
now
enter the
number of rooms you want
all right
now after that
the user will enter the number of rooms
that is the quantity of rooms
so now we'll take the quantity in the
quantity variable that is Quant variable
so the user will enter the number of
rooms that is the quantity of rooms he
or she wants now we'll use a if
statement and if statement inside this
if statement now inside this if
statement we'll check do we actually
have that many rooms in our hotel or do
we actually have that many pastas or
burgers in our hotel right now so for
that we have to write down a condition
that is
Q rooms minus s rooms
is greater than equal to Quant
that is
Q rooms is the quantity of rooms that we
have and S rooms the number of rooms
that we have sold
so if V minus both of these that is if
you subtract the quantity of room we
have
minus the rooms we have sold we'll get
the remaining rooms now if the remaining
rooms it's greater than equal to the
quantity of rooms that have been ordered
by the customer then we can give the
room to them otherwise we have to
display a message saying that we don't
have that many rooms or something like
that
so let's do that so we'll write s rooms
that is the rooms that we have sold so
initially its value is zero so we have
to add the values of quantity that have
been
entered by the user so we'll add the
Quant variable that is if the user have
entered two rooms he or she wants then
we'll add the add those two values to
this sold rooms
all right after adding the quantity to
the sold rooms now
we will do the total price of the room
or rooms and for that we have the
variable total
room
so we'll add this Quant into the price
of a one room to this total room
so we are simply adding
total room Plus
want
into the price of a single room that is
let's say 1200 is the price of a single
room
if a person orders two rooms then it
would be like Quant that is 2 2 into
1200 2400 will be added to this total
room this total room is the total price
of a room
all right
now we also have to display a message
saying that these many rooms have been
allotted to you so for that let's
display a message first of all we'll use
slash n like two times now we'll add
some horizontal space as well
all right now we'll display this Quant
variable
and write a message that these many
rooms
have been
allotted to you
let me let's make it rumor rooms
room or rooms have been allotted to you
so this message will be displayed
all right
now this is the if block
now we'll have to make the else block
that
if the
amount or quantity of room entered by
the user is more than the remaining
rooms then we'll display a message
saying that only so and so rooms are
left in the hotel
so we'll use slash n then again slash d
now we'll write
only
Q rooms
minus s rooms that is hit Q root minus s
room is the remaining rooms are the
remaining rooms so subtracting both of
these variables will give us the
remaining rooms
so these were the remaining rooms
and
Hotel
all right
and let's not add this as there's a
single statement
also we have to use break
so we'll use break statement now
similarly we have to create case two
this case was for the room
so whenever a user click on this one
then this case will be executed so
similarly we'll create case two
so let's
we'll copy it now we'll paste it
so
I will case to
foreign
so in this case enters the number of
rooms you want we can't we can't write
that
so we'll write pass the quantity so
let's do that
we'll write
enter
past the
quantity
all right so in this case the C in would
be same that is quantity variable we
have so now in this case the different
thing would be the Q rooms instead of Q
rooms we'll use the Q pasta that is the
quantity of pasta
minus sold pastas
it must be greater than quantity of
pasta we have
then only if block will execute
otherwise similarly as that of this
block will display a message
so now the S rooms instead of s rooms
here will use as pasta
which is initially zero
so we'll add the quantity of pasta to
this variable that is We'll add the
quantity of pasta that is ordered by the
customer to this variable
now total pasta that is a total price of
the pasta
so the number of pastas ordered by the
customer into the price of a single
pasta let's say the price of a single
pasta is around 250.
so quantity into 250.
now
rooms instead of rooms let's do here
pasta is the order
so Quant
so Quant will display the
quantity so it will display like if you
have ordered two pastas will it will
display two
pass the
is the
order
and
Q rooms here we have to display the
meaning so we'll do the Q pass the minus
as pasta
and here we'll do is pass the remaining
in hotel or stock
faster remaining in hotel
so it will display the remaining pasta
remained in the hotel now
so
else everything is fine now similarly
we'll do for the next
we'll copy it it will save some time
and paste it now this is case three the
case three is of burger
so we will write
Burger
quantity of burger minus
sold burgers
similarly as Burger
now the total price of burger
so let's say the price of a burger is
around 120
and so
the remaining burgers
Q value minus Asperger
the fourth case now
that is the noodles case
so enter noodles quantity
now case five
now case 5 is of shakes
so we'll write enter shakes quantity
now
case six we have to create
in the case 6 there was chicken rule
so let's do that
Q chicken
minus s chicken
also we have to change the price of each
meal like chicken roll
would be of around 150
and this shake would be
120
noodles
140 let's say
Burger is okay then
pasta is also okay
so we have created six cases as of now
so our second part of the program is
done now we'll start with the third part
of the program
so the third part will contain the case
7 case 8 and the default case that is if
the user enters any other number which
is not in the list that will come under
default case
in case 7 we have to display the
information of sales and collection that
is how many money we have collected for
the day and the remaining food items Etc
so now let's start with the case seven
so when the user will enter 7 that is
case 7
then he want to see the details of the
information of sales and collection
so we'll display a message saying that
details
of sales
and
collection
all right
so after this message let's add slashing
slash T slash t
all right so after this message
we have to display the number of rooms
we had the number of rooms we gave for
rent and then the remaining rooms that
is minus the quantity of rooms minus the
sold rooms then the total rooms
collection for the day
so similarly we'll do for all the meals
like pasta Burger Noodles Etc so let's
do it
so we'll start
display
first of all We'll add slashing
now
number of rooms we had
display queue rooms that is the quantity
rooms we had
now
similarly
number of rooms
we give for rent
all right
so we'll write
s rooms
now we have to display a message
similarly we'll write slash and slation
remaining
rooms
so for that we have to Simply subtract Q
rooms with s rooms that will give us the
remaining rooms
after that
the total price that the room has
collected or number of rooms have
collected
so we'll write
total rooms
collection
for the day
now
it is stored at total rooms
this variable is stored in the total
drives of rooms
this is the complete information of
rooms similarly we have to do it for the
burger noodle pasta Etc
so we can copy we'll copy this part
and we'll do
copy and paste
and paste
again we'll paste now number of rooms we
had instead of this we'll simply write
number of pastas we had
number of pastas
we have to change that number of pastas
we
sold
yeah that would be right now remaining
past us
there are few minor changes that we have
to do
total pasta collection
also make sure to change the variables
total Costa
then
Q pasta
all right now
after pasta it was Burger
because we have number of burgers we
sold
all right so it would be Cube Burger
and that's Burger
remaining burgers
total Burger collection for the day
all right now we'll do same for
noodles
all right now shakes
number of shakes we had
number of shakes we give
we sold
remaining shakes
now there is chicken roll
number of chicken rule we had
all right now the case eight the case
eight we have used four this was the
case seven and the case eight we have
used for exit as you can see here
this is the exit case
and for that
we'll simply use
the exit statement the exit statement is
used to terminate the program to shift
the control out of the program or exit
the program
so here we'll use that so case 8 would
be
exit and inside that we'll use 0 0 will
mean that zero millisecond
and now after that we will have to use
the default case that if the user enters
any other number that is not present in
the menu list then this default case
will be executed so in this default case
we'll display a message saying that
please select from the numbers that are
mentioned above
so we'll use slation
please
select the numbers
mentioned above
so this message will be printed
and also one more thing is there
we have to use a go to statement
and we'll have to label a part with m
now I'll explain to you that why have we
used this jump statement that is go to
statement
so after making a choice we again want
to choose another option that is if I
have ordered two pastas then I also want
to order two burgers as well so we will
Mark or label menu with M so this is a
menu please select from the menu options
so here we will label m
and
in the last we have used the go to
statements so the go to statement here
will transfer the control to the menu
after making a choice
so again m is the label we have used for
the menu and we will use a go to
statement to transfer the control to the
menu after making the choice so that we
can make more choices
go to is a jump statement basically that
is used to jump from one part to another
part having a specified label
so we have labeled menu with M and this
go to jump state will help us in jumping
to the menu after every choice
all right so our code is done we have
done all the things that we need now we
need to run it and for that firstly we
need to save it
all right so let's go to files and save
it
and now let's
select the destination folder
let's name it as management
.cpp
yeah
all right
so the program is saved now let's try to
compile and run this program
so there are some errors I can see
Okay so
we have used the semicolon
now this will take care of many errors
now let's try to again compile and run
let's check Q noodles
all right I think uh
Q noodles
so we have two Backspaces now
let's try to
compile and run again
hope it works now
so quantity of items we have as we can
see
so rooms available let's say we have 10
rooms
and quantity of pasta
we have 25 Pastors in our hotel and
around 50 burgers
and 30 noodles
and 30 shakes
Chicken Roll we have 40
so this is the menu please select from
the menu options as we can see First
rooms then pasta Burger noodles Shake
Chicken Roll information regarding sales
and collection and then eight to exit so
first of all let's say I want to order
two rooms so I'll click one
please enter your choice I have clicked
one and I'll press enter now enter the
number of rooms you want and let us
suppose I want two rooms
so as we can see
two room or rooms have been allotted to
you now again the menu is displayed on
the screen now let's say I want
Burgers so I'll click on three
and I want two burgers
and two Burger is the order it is
displayed now again I want uh
pasta let's say
I want six pastas
and six past ID order I want to order
now shakes
let's have something to drink I want to
order nine shakes
nine shakes is the order
and let's say so as we know that we have
only 10 rooms now let's try to enter 11
so first of all we'll enter one that is
rooms now let's try to order 11 rooms
as you can see only eight
eight rooms available or remaining in
hotel so we forgot to add some space
over this part
but we can easily read it now as of now
so it is displaying the message that
only eight rooms are available because
already we have ordered two early it was
10 then now only eight rooms are
available so this is showing that if we
order
more than the quantity then it will
display this message
now let's say I want to
check the information regarding sales
and collection of two days
rooms and as well as meals so I'll
simply click on seven
now as we can see it will simply display
all the
sales and collection
rooms and meals as you can see number of
rooms we had 10 number of rooms we gave
for rent two remaining rooms are eight
so total rooms collection for the race
2400 as one room is of 1200 so similarly
number of pastas we had 25 number of
pastas we sold six remaining pastas we
had 19 so the total pasta collection is
1500 so and so the Burger and then
noodles and then shakes and chicken roll
so this is the total Chicken Roll
collection for the day that's that is we
haven't ordered a single Chicken Roll
also we can do one more thing we can
simply
display the total result of all the
collections of rooms and meals
so let's do that
so now so to display the total
collection of the day all we need to do
is to add all the totals of pastas
burgers and rooms
so for that we have to go to K7
foreign
three times
so here we'll write total collection for
the day
and after that
total rooms
Plus
total
total burgers
total pasta
this total
Burger
total
chicken
all right after this we will use the
break statement
now let's run the program
so here it is Rooms available
let's write 10.
quantity of pasta 30
Burger 50.
quantity of noodles 30.
shakes 30
chicken roll
40.
so first of all I'll book two rooms
click on one and now two rooms
and again if I'll click on
rooms
and then if I try to click
10 rooms because already we have two
sold we sold two rooms and it will
display that only eight rooms remaining
in hotel now I'll
click on two to order pasta let's say I
have ordered five pastas
and
five pasta is the order now let's say if
we click on nine although we know that
only one to eight numbers are available
but if we click on 9
so it will display message please select
the numbers mentioned above
all right now let's say I have I want to
order chicken roll
10 chicken rolls I want
so 10 chicken roll is the order now I
want to check information regarding
sales and connection for the day right
click on 7
and then here I can see
number of rooms we had number of rooms
we gave for rent remaining rooms and
total collection for the day similarly
for the pasta
similarly for the burger similarly for
noodles
shakes and
Chicken Roll as well
and this is the total collection for the
day 5150 exit and if we click on it we
can exit
so as we can see this is our hotel
management project
and this is how it's done
the code is bit long but it's worth it
you can also try this project on your
own in this tutorial we'll make a
project in C plus plus this project will
be a login and registration system in C
plus plus
in which a user can register login and
also if he or she forgets the password
then also it can be recovered
we will make this project using the
fundamentals of C plus plus like switch
case statements and file handling
operations
Etc
but before that if you are new to our
Channel then consider getting subscribed
to our YouTube channel as we have daily
updates on multiple Technologies
so let's go ahead and understand this C
plus plus project of login and
registration system
in this project first of all we will
make a menu page in which there are
options like login registration for good
password and exit
then we'll ask the user to select anyone
among those options
once the user has selected a particular
option then we have to continue with the
functionality of that
so now let's switch to our code editor
and do its practical implementation
so this is a Dev C plus code editor and
now let's create a new file
now first of all we will include the
header files
the hash include IO stream
important
then there is
F stream class or file handing operation
hash include fstream
then there is string dot Edge
for string
then we will include the namespace
standard
now we will do the forward declaration
for three functions that is login
function registration function and
forgot function and after that inside
the main function we will make the menu
for the login page
so let's start
first of all we are doing the forward
declaration
this is the login function
this is the registration function
and this is the forward function
now inside the int Main
first of all we'll make a variable C
which stands for Choice C for choice
so now
we will make the menu page
so let's create
we'll use
slash t for adding the horizontal space
now in the end we will use slash n
all right similarly we'll do here
welcome to
the login page
now again we'll do the same
foreign
and now
underscores
menu
slash and slashing
all right now we will make the options
so we'll do the slash t
now after slash T we'll add vertical bar
then
we'll right press one
to login
let's make it capital
press 1 to login
and after making some space then
vertical
drag it again
then handle
similarly
we'll copy it and do for option two
press two
register
all right
let's maintain the symmetry
press 3
if you forgot your password all right
press 4 to exit
foreign
and for that we'll display a message
saying that
please enter your choice
but before that we'll use slash n and
some slash D's
all right now we'll ask the user please
enter your choice
all right
now we'll take the input of the choice
that is C that we have already declared
next line now we'll use switch case
statements for example if the user
selects two to register first of all
then inside the switch case statement in
case 2 we will call the registration
function
and if the user enters one then we will
call the login function
so let's do that
let's create a switch statement
and see that is choice
now inside the switch statement first of
all we'll create a case one
inside this case there would be login
we are calling this login function and
then there is break statement
all right similarly now we will
create case two
so case 2 would be registration
here we are calling the registration
function
and then there is break statement
in case three there is forgot function
that is if the user forgets the password
then this function will be implemented
now
there is a default case no now there is
a case for
in case 4 there would be
a message saying that thank you
because ks4 would be exit
so we'll display a message saying that
now we will also have to make the
default case
that is if the user selects five six or
any other number that is not in the menu
then we will display a message saying
that
please select from the options given
above
so before that we'll add the slash t
please select
from the options
given above
after that we'll use slash n
and L
after that we'll call the main function
so that the control goes back to the
main function and
will also use
system
CLS that is clear screen
it means every time the code is
processed it will clear up the screen
now all we need to do is to create the
login function
so we'll write void
login
and inside this function first of all
we'll create some variables and so let's
do that int count
user ID no this user ID would be of
string
right
string
user ID
then there would be password
then ID
then pass
all right so these are the variables
that we have created
now again we'll use this
we have to
write CLS inside the double quotes
all right now we will display a message
that please enter the username and
password
so we'll do that and we'll write slash T
slash T slash t
and
please enter
the username
and password
all right now
we'll again display a message saying
that
username
now we'll take the input
so here user ID is the username that the
user will enter
now again we will display a message
saying that password
let's make it capital
again we'll take the input
now as the user has entered the username
and password now we will check that if
that username and password already exist
in our records
and for that we will use the file
handling operation of if stream class
because if stream is used to read the
data so we will use if strain
and if stream class
this will read the data from the file
input is the object name
and the file name would be records
Dot txt
all right we'll have to
make it inside the double quotes
all right so now this if stream will
check inside the file that if that login
password exists or not
and to check that we will have to use
the while loop
inside the while loop we'll write
input that is the object name
then there would be ID
and that
pass
so this is the ID and password and this
is how we read in file handling
operations here what we are doing is we
are reading that if that ID and password
is there and then we will match those ID
and passwords with the ID and password
that is entered by the user
so for that we will have to use the if
condition inside the while loop
so let's do that
we will write if
ID equals user ID
and
pass equals password
then
count would be 1.
and then we will use system CLS to clear
the screen
here we have assigned 1 to count because
in the next part we will use an if
condition that if the count is 1 then we
will display a message saying that your
login is successful that is the password
or username entered by the user matches
with the record that is the user has
already registered
so now before that we have to close this
file
so
let's do that
we will to close this file we will use
the object name that is input Dot
close this is how we can close the file
all right now we'll use the if condition
and inside this if condition
as I have said if count equals 1
all right if count equals 1
then we will first of all display the
user ID that is the username
and then we will display a message that
your login is successful
so let's do that
your login
is successful
now thanks for logging in
now again we will
shift the control to the main
because there is the main menu
and now
inside the else block
we will display a message
that is if the user and password is not
found inside the file then it means that
the user is not registered so he can't
log in he has to register it first
so we'll display a message
saying that
login error
please check your username
now again
main function now we have to create
another function that is the
registration function
that is if the user press 2 then this
registration function
would be called
so let's create this function
void registration
now inside this function we will first
of all create some variables then after
that we'll ask the user to enter the
username and password pretty much the
same as that of the previous function so
first of all string
are for registration user
ID our user ID
then r
password
then rid and R pass
foreign
now we will display a message saying
that enter the username
again
enter the password
or password
all right so in the previous function we
have used a stream class but in this
function we will use off stream class
because we want to write inside the file
and offstream helps us with that
so for that we will use off stream
and object name would be F1
and records with a file
and we will use the
app mode this iOS means the input output
stream and app will open the file and
append the output in the end
so this is our app mode there are
different modes so here we are using
this app mode
so after this we'll put the semicolon in
the end
now we have to write inside the file so
we'll do the F1
and this is how we write inside the file
F1 here is the object name and our user
ID
here's the username and after that we'll
add some space
and then
r
password
that is the password
we want some space between the username
and password that is why we have
use the single quotes and
this is how we write inside the file and
after that we'll again use the system
CLS that is the clear screen
all right
now I will display a message that
registration is successful
as we have already written inside the
file so now we can display this message
saying that registration is successful
now again
control back to the main function
so now we will create the forgot
function
this is the last function
void forgot
so this function
would be called when the user forgots
the password or username
so first of all we will create a
variable
option
now we will ask the user that you forgot
your password no worries then we'll ask
the user to press 1 to search your ID by
you by your username and press 2 to go
back to the main menu
so let's start
before that we will use system CLS
all right now we'll display the message
saying that
you forget the password
no worries
and then
we'll use slash in
now press 1
to search
your ID
by username
all right now
press 2 to go back to the main menu
all right now after that
we'll use slash d
all right now enter your choice
now we'll take the input C in
option
after that using the switch case
statement
option
now inside the switch case
will create cases
so case 1
that is when the user selects option one
then
end
will use bracket over here because there
will be
multiple lines
all right now end count
will initialize it with zero
now some more variables we will declare
a string
s user ID
and
S ID
then s pass
so these are some string variables and
count is the integer variable after that
we'll display the message that enter the
username which you remembered
so let's do it
to the username
if you remembered
all right
now
you will take the input from the user as
user ID
so once the user entered the username
then we will check
that if that username exists in the file
using the if stream object as we know if
stream is used when we want to read from
the file or check from the file so we'll
create the ifstream class
and the object name would be F2
and
records.txt is the file
all right now using the while loop
we will check that if
the username is there inside the file or
not
so S ID
and S pass
so now
if
S ID equals
as user ID
then
count equals 1.
so we will assign one to count and
after that we will close the file that
is F2 Dot close
so here what we are doing is we are
checking inside the file using the
stream object that if that ID or
password is there and if that ID is
there then we'll assign one to the count
as initially it was 0 and then again
we'll do the same as that we have in the
pre as we have done in the previous
function that if count equals to 1 then
we will
print a message that your account is
found
so let's do that
so as we have closed the file now after
that
we'll use an if statement
with a condition that if
count equals 1
then we will print a message saying that
your account is found
foreign
so it will display the password
again the control will be shifted to the
main
where there is the main menu
and inside the else block now
inside the else block will display a
message
saying that
sorry your account is not found
sorry
your account
is not found
so as the case one ends we will use the
break statement
now we will create case two
in case 2 as we have said that it will
simply call the
go back to the main menu so
all we'll do is
call the main function
so that the control will go back to the
main menu
and now also we have to create the
default case
in the default case we'll simply print a
message saying that wrong choice please
try again
so we'll use slash T slash T slash t
wrong choice
please try again
foreign
we'll call the forgot function so that
the user can try again with the correct
option
all right so
we forgot to save this
so let's name it as
register
dot CPP
and save it
now let's try to run this
go to execute and compile and run
there is some error
all right so it must I must be capital
as we have declared
let's try again
so as you can see welcome to login page
this is the menu and this is press one
to login press 2 to register press 3 if
you forgot your password press 4 to exit
so now we will enter our choice first of
all we need to register so we'll write 2
and our username as
Sam at the rate email
this is a username
and now our password same one two three
is our password
so as you can see the message
registration is successful
now after that we will login
as we have registered now we'll try to
login
Sam Android email is our username
and Sam
one two three other password
so as you can see your login is
successful thanks for logging in
now let's say I forgot my password
so I'll press three as if you forgot
your password you have to press three
so there is a message you forgot the
password no worries please press one to
search your ID by your username so I'll
press one
now I'll write my username the last
username I remembered
Sam at the rate
email
so your account is found your password
is this as you can see
so let's say
again if I forgot the password and by
chance I write
Sammy
at the rate email
then sorry your account is not found is
displayed as Sam at the rate email is
the registered customer and not Sammy at
the rate email so it will display this
message that sorry your account is not
found
and let's say
again if we try to press let's say five
then we can see that please select from
the options given above actually we have
to make it below options given below but
we can do that else everything is
working fine so now we will click on
exit that is four
and this is a message thank you
so as we can see this is our
registration and login
system in C plus plus and this is how we
can do it we have created these three
functions that is login function
then there is registration function
after that there is a forgot function if
you forgot the password and the code is
pretty easy and not that much long so
you can try this code on your own hey
guys welcome to another tutorial by
simply learn I hope you all are doing
well
so in this session we will learn how to
create a supermarket billing project in
C plus we will create this project in
small parts as there are various
functions that we will be creating for
this project like the add function to
add the goods and products in the market
and delete function to delete some
products Etc
also we will create a buyer site where
the buyer can buy the products or food
items of his choice
so now let's go ahead but before that
make sure to subscribe to our Channel
and press the Bell icon to never miss an
update from Simply learn
now we will move to our code editor that
is Dev C plus plus
so now let's create a new file
and we'll start with adding the header
files first of all we'll add hash
include I have stream
then we'll include the app stream file
right hash include fstream because here
we have to do the file handling
operations as well so we'll add
thestream file
now we'll write the namespace standard
now let's save this one and name it
billing one dot CPP
all right so we have named this file
now first of all we'll create a class
and we will declare some variables and
functions
so let's create a class and name the
class as shopping
inside the class shopping first of all
inside the private scope we will create
or declare some variables
P code
then float type
price
then another variable discount or flow
type
then name which should be string
all right let's name it P name
P stands for product
all right now inside the public school
we will declare the functions
so
let's name this function as menu
because we have to create the menu then
administrator function
all right now let's create a buyer
function
a buyer or customer whatsoever
all right now let's create add function
then the edit function
these definitions of these functions we
will create later first of all here we
are declaring these functions after that
we have to remove some products for that
we will create remove function and then
the list function to display the list
and at last
receipt function
all right so here we have declared the
functions and the variables
so now we'll put semicolon in the end of
the class
and we'll start with the first function
that is the menu function
so we'll write white class name
then the scope resolution operator
and menu function
so now inside this function
first of all we will create a
variable
that is choice
and some more variables like let's say
email
and password
because here we will need email as well
as password for the login purpose
so now we have to create this menu and
for that we have to first of all display
Supermarket main menu and after that we
will display that administrator buyer
Etc and
all that so now let's start with that
for that we have to display and you can
display in your own style like I usually
do like this
slash T to add some horizontal space
it's just for formatting and
after that same will do
to save some time let's just copy and
just paste it
and but now we will here we'll write
supermarket
main menu
reduce some space
all right now similarly we'll do here
foreign
now let's just copy and paste this part
all right now again some space
all right now we'll create a menu in
which the user have to select the
customer have to select whether he is an
administrator or a buyer
so let's do that
and for that
we'll write C out
slash T slash T slash D to add some
horizontal space
and
all right now
foreign
we'll add some space over here
just remove this one
in number two we'll write buyer
the person who wants to buy stuff
from the market
all right
now
let's format it
will add some space over here
now in number three we'll write exit
all right it's pretty much done
after that again if you want to add some
space we can
add some
it's just for formatting purposes you
can do it in your own way and after that
we have to display a message saying that
please select
so we'll display a message
for good to use semicolon
now we'll take an input from the user
that
whatsoever he wants to click on like if
he is an administrator he'll click on N1
if he's a buyer then he'll click on Two
And if he wants to exit you can click on
three
so we will take an input of choice now
we have to use switch case
and let's create that
switch and inside this we'll write
choice we all know how switch case works
all right now for case 1 that is
administrator case
we will ask the user to enter the login
credentials if he or she is an
administrator
so let's just do that
so first of all we'll display a message
saying that please login
so slash T slash t
enter email and then
we'll take the input of email we already
declared this variable
email and now we'll take the password
from the user
now I will take the input of the
password
so as we have taken the email and
password from the user now we will set
an email and password that only admin
knows and no other person can enter that
and let's say
for that we have to use if else
statements so if
email
equals
now let's set the email first of all
Robbie at the rate email.com
you can write the email and password as
of your choice
and I'll set the password now as
Robbie at the rate one two three
now inside the if block if the user
enters this that means it is the
administrator
and we will call this administrator
function
all right now in the else block
we'll simply display a message saying
that invalid username password
invalid username
invalid email password
foreign
to end the case
now we will create case two case two is
for the buyer so we'll write case
two
and in this case we'll simply call the
buyer function
so this is the case too and now we have
to create the case three
inside the case three
case three is for exit so we'll do Exit
0
it means successful termination of the
program
Now default case
so inside the default case we'll simply
display message saying that
please select from the given options
default case will execute if a person
selects any other option
rather than one two three
so we'll have to instruct him that
please select from the given option
select from the
given options
now after this we'll use a go to
statement
after the switch statement
so go to is a jump statement so it will
help us in jumping to the main menu
again
after the completion of the switch case
and this m is a label we have to put
this label at the starting of this
menu
so let's do that
right m
now coming back to the next function
so this function is done
so we'll close this function
all right so now we will create an
administrator function in which there
will be different options inside the
administrator menu so now let's start
with that
so we will write
void
shopping that is the class name
crop resolution operator
administrator
so our function name is as mainly
straighter
so inside this function first of all we
will declare a variable choice
now after that we will
create a menu in which there will be
different options
so
let's do that
first of all we'll write slash in
then slash D some horizontal spaces
so that administrator
menu
all right
after that
it will be our first option
so first of all we'll write slash and
then slash D's
just to make it bit fancy we can do this
add the product
so the user can select this option if he
wants to
add the product not user the
administrator
now we will add some space in this one
now again same
we'll copy it from here then paste it
so here we will change it to the modify
the product
modify the product and
we have to adjust it as well
all right now again we'll add some space
so you can copy this one
now here will be right delete the
product
now here again
three and make this four
4 will be of back to main menu
all right
now after that we will ask the user to
please enter your choice
so we'll display a message saying that
please enter your
choice
all right
now the user will enter the choice
now again we have to use the switch case
statements
inside this first case first of all
we'll
make and inside this first case
we will call the add function
after that we'll use break statement
now we'll create case 2.
in case 2 we will call the modify
function or the edit function
so we'll write
edit
and again the break
now
we'll create case three
in case three
there will be delete function
so we'll name this function as remove
REM stands for remove
now ks4 would be back to main menu
so for that
we'll simply call the menu function
now after case 4 there would be default
case
so we'll write default
and we'll print a message saying that
invalid choice
all right so after the switch case
statement again as we have done in the
previous function we will mark
M with the go to statement which is a
jump statement and label it over here
all right so administrator function is
done
after this function now we will create
another function let's say buyer
function
so for that
word shopping
scope resolution operator
buyer
all right so inside this buyer function
first of all we'll declare the variables
in choice
now inside this function we'll ask the
user that he or she wants to buy the
product or go back so let's create that
first of all here we'll write
by the product now first of all we'll
write buyer
yeah
after that
let's get some space
now
here and
all right selection
okay
go back
so the second option is
[Music]
all right so these are some options
after that we will ask the user to enter
your choice
then the user will enter his choice
so we are taking the input
after that we'll use the switch
statement
and choice
so inside the switch statement first of
all we'll create case one
inside this case
we will call the receipt function
inside the receipt function all the
operations of the buyer will take place
so this is the receipt function and
after that we'll use break
now we'll create case two
in case 2 we'll write
or call the menu function as
2 would be go back as we can see Now
default case
we'll write invalid choice
now after this again we'll use the go to
jump statement
and Mark here m
all right so after this function now we
will create the add function
so as we know if the user over here the
administrator over here will click on
this add the product that is the first
case then this add function will be
called so now we'll create this add
function
so we'll write void shopping
add
so inside this function we will use some
file handling operations so create an
object of f stream class
so data is the name of the object now
we'll create some variables like in C
and
token equals zero and
float p
float d
and
string n
so these are the variables that we have
declared now we have to create a menu
kind of a structure in which we will ask
the user to enter the product code of
product the name of the product price
discount Etc
so let's do that
so let's write
add new
product
all right after that we will write the
product code of product will ask the
user to enter the product code of the
product
so we'll write slash and slash in and on
slash d
will
take the input in P code we have already
declared these variables at the top of
our code now we will write another
message saying that name of the product
for that we'll write name
of the product
now we'll take the input in P name
now we'll display
price of the product
we'll take the input in price
now we'll ask to enter the discount
so we'll write
discount of the
discount on the product
all right so here we are asking the user
to enter the product code of the product
and the user will enter the product code
then the name of the product then he
will enter the name then the price and
then the discount
so after that now we will have to open a
file
because as this add option is being used
by the administrator so we have to store
these product details inside a
particular file so that we can display
to the user that we have these products
in our supermarket
all right so for that
you'll have to use the file handling
operations data is the name of the
object as you can see and with the help
of data dot open
we can open the file
and
the name of the file we can write here
database
Dot txt
all right after that
we want
to open this file in reading mode
iOS in will open the file in reading
mode and iOS out will open the file in
writing mode
so now
we will use if statement and we'll write
if not
data that is if this file
doesn't exist then
inside this function we'll write
data dot open
database Dot txt
we will open this basically we will open
this file in writing mode if this file
doesn't exist
and if this file exists then in else
block we'll do that
iOS out IOS app stands for append mode
and IO strong out stands for right mode
now
in order to write inside the file
will give some space and
now we'll write P code
this is how we can write inside a file
after that P name
then again some space
after that there is price
and again some space
after that
this for Discount
then we'll use slash n
all right so after that we have to close
the file as well
.close
data Dot close after that
in else block
that is if the fight exists then
we will read from the file so this is
how we can read from file
and
the these are the variables here we are
initializing the file because after that
we have to use the while loop to iterate
through the file
so let's do that
first of all I'll write this part and
then I'll explain
inside this we'll use if statement and
if C equals to P code
then
token will be incremented
and
4
initialization
or for iteration
we'll again do that
so here what we are doing is first of
all we are initializing the index of
file here we are initializing the index
because after that we will use the while
loop inside this while loop we have
written
not data.eof this eof is the end of file
function this while loop will make sure
to check every content of the file by
iterating it so one by one each content
of the file is checked if the code
matches with the p code that is if there
is a duplicacy then the token variable
which we have
we can see initialize with 0 will be
incremented
it will become 1 basically after that
for the iteration purpose we are reading
from the file
and after that now
we will close the file data dot Clues
all right
now
we'll use if statement that if token is
one as We Know
if token gets incremented that is if
there is a duplicacy
then again
it will go back to the menu that is if
the product code entered by the
administrator already exists then he
have to enter another product code
because if
the administrator enters the duplicate
code then it will again go back to this
menu
so this go to m
we have to label it over here
all right now in the else block
that is if the token value is not
incremented that is the product code
entered by the administrator is unique
and Not Duplicate then we can enter the
product the product that is its product
code its product name its price
so for that we can just copy paste this
part
it's the same
and
you can paste it over here
so here we are writing inside the file
so this is how we can write inside the
file and here we are opening the file in
append and writing mode
to write inside the file we have to open
the file in writing mode
so after that
we will display a message saying that
record inserted
oh this bracket error the else block
will close over here
all right
now this add function is done
we have done this part
now we have to create another function
named the edit function
as the add function is used for adding
the products in the market
based on their price
names discounts Etc now edit function
will edit the products like if you want
to edit some product like choose instead
of milk or something like that you can
do it with the help of edit function so
we'll do that functionality in edit
function so let's do that
we'll write void
shopping
edit the name of the function
so inside this function we will create
two objects
of f stream class that is data 1 and
data 2.
it is data and data one
all right so these two are the objects
of a stream class
now we will declare some variables
foreign
all right
now we'll write
a message displaying modified the record
so we'll write slash in
now we will ask to enter the product
code
so we'll write
now we will open the file and check if
that file exists or not
yes
now if
that file doesn't exist
then
we'll simply display a message
saying that file doesn't exist
and in else block
we will open the file but not the same
file the other file this file would be
database one and we will open this file
with the help of this object that is
data man
so we'll write
data 1 dot open
the name of the file would be
database
1 Dot txt
and we will open this file
in append mode
and writing mode
so here what we are doing is we will
save our edited data in this file and we
will rename it to the original name that
is database.txt the name of this file is
database one dot txt we will save the
edited data in this file and then we
will rename this file as database.txt
that is the original name of the file
so now we will write data
P code
then P name
price
and then this
so we are initializing this file
basically we want to iterate this file
so
not data dot end of file
it will check each and every content of
the file
all right now
using if statement
we will check if P key equals to P code
P key is the code that is entered by the
administrator
which he wants to edit
so if that matches
then inside the file
right slash n
slash T slash t
and then product
of new code
product new code
here we are asking the administrator to
enter the new code for the product
so
CNC
he or she will enter the code then we
will ask
to enter the name
so let's slash and slash in
name of the
product
P name
and
now the price
so we'll write
foreign
now all the updated details of the
product will be entered with the help of
data one object
foreign
then
n
again some space
and here p
then here D
all right
now we'll write
a message saying that record edited
record edited all right
after that we'll increment the token
that is token plus plus
now this was the if block now in else
block
gain data 1
that is if
the product key would product code
entered by the administrator doesn't
matches with any of the product code
within the file then
the hold variables that is
P code
B name
price
and after that discount
that is this
all right after that
yeah
we'll do that selection
now outside this else block we'll write
that
e-code P name
just for increment purpose
we want the while loop to iterate so
that is why we will use this one
so that this while loop can I trade
all right after this
we will close both the objects that is
data Dot close we are closing both the
files
and data one
Dot close
now as I already discussed that we have
to rename that database one back to the
original name that is database so we
will use two functions in C plus plus
that is remove function and rename
function with the help of remove
function we will remove the list that is
the database.txt file we will remove the
database.txt file and then with the help
of rename function we will rename
database1.ext to database.txt
so let's do that
remove inside remove we will write the
name of the file
it will basically remove all the list
inside the file
all right now rename function
inside the rename function first of all
we have to write the old name
that is database
1 Dot txt
then the new name
that is database
Dot txt
so now using this function
this name will be changed to
database.txt
all right
now if
token value is not incremented or we can
say is zero
then
it will display a message saying that
record
not
found
sorry
and with that we are done with the edit
function and now we will create remove
function
so we'll write
void
shopping
REM remove
this remove function will be bit similar
to that of the edit function
so now let's start with that
F stream we'll create two objects
data in data one
now
hint P key
and int token
he'll initialize it with zero
now
will display
slash d
delete
product
now we'll display
to enter the product code so we'll write
similar to previous function
data dot open
database Dot txt
we are opening this file
in reading mode
and then we will check if this file
exists or not
so we'll write
so here we will write
if
not data
then inside will display
file doesn't exist
all right
now in else block
inside the else block we will open the
data one file
and the file name would be database 1
Dot txt
and we will open this file
in append and writing mode
all right now after that
a VSP code to initialize over iterate
the while loop we will write this
this is how we read from the file and
here we will use data because we will
iterate through data.us that is data
file
now inside the while loop
again we'll do the same as that we have
previously done
data Dot eof and file
now
use if
e-code equals to P key
then
will simply display the message saying
that
product
deleted
successfully
all right and now we will increment the
token
now in the else block we will write
data one
space
then P code
then P named then price then discount
now we name
then
price
and discount
here the peaky entered by the
administrator will check for the first
product code if it matches the if block
executes
in the second iteration it will not
match an else block will execute and
database 1 file will be displayed
in other words in else block all the
products will be displayed except the
one which you want to remove or delete
so we will show this file database 1 and
then rename it with the previous one
that is database
alright so now let's go ahead
we'll do the same in order to iterate
this while loop
now
as we done previously
data Dot close as we have to close the
files
data one
Dot close
and after that again the remove function
to remove the database file
and rename function
firstly we will write the database one
that is the old name
make sure to put semicolons then
database
then database
dot txt the new name
all right after that if
tokens is not incremented
that is if token is zero then it will
simply display a message
saying that record cannot found
or record not found
so as we have created three major
functions now we will create another
function named list
it will help us in showing the list to
the customer or the buyer right shopping
now we'll write
list
inside this function
write
the data
the object of the stream class
then data.open
will open the database file
Dot txt
in the reading mode
all right after that
we will format it a bit
so after that again
you have to write the product number
name price Etc so we'll write
product number
and then we can use slash t
again name
then
price
and then we'll use slation
please put them inside the double quotes
and now again we'll copy this part
you can design it in your own way
and
now we can do
the Reading part data
P code
then the name as we have done previously
price
this
while loop inside the while loop again
we'll use
not data dot EOS
now inside this file
we'll write the product code product
name and the price we'll start with 2.
code
then product name
that is p name
after that
price
for the iteration purpose we'll write
again P code
P name
price
discount
all right now after that we will close
the file by writing data Dot
close
all right so we are done with this
function as well after this now we will
create the receipt function in which all
the customer operations will take place
so now let's create this receipt
function
so we'll write void shopping
our ecipdrecept
and now inside this function first of
all we'll create the object of app
stream class then we'll declare some
arrays because we have to store multiple
product keys and multiple quantities of
those products so that is why here we
have to use arrays and then we will
declare some variables
so let's start
first of all F stream class the object
of this class is data
now after this we'll create
array
array c means array of codes
so I'll declare it in that way
now after that
now we'll decline on another array
array of q that is quantity
now
Choice variable
then there would be
a counter variable let's say
then discount variable
will initialize it with zero
and we'll initialize amount with 0 as
well
all right now
total variable
now we will display a message saying
that receipt
so that the user will know that this is
the receipt
foreign
that is data.open will open the
database.txt file and then we'll check
if that file or database exist or not
so
we have done this previously data dot
open
database
Dot txt
will open this file in reading mode
now we'll use a if block and inside this
if block will write not data we are
checking that if this file or database
exists or not
all right
if it doesn't exist if not data that is
if this file doesn't exist or this
database doesn't exist then we will
print the message saying that empty
database
empty with a p
now as this
now in else block we'll write if that
file exists
then first of all we'll close the file
that we already opened
now in else block we will call this list
function that we have created because if
the file is created then we have to call
the list function and we'll show the
user or the customer that these are the
products available in the supermarket
and for that we are calling this list
function
now we'll
design the structure and ask the user to
place the order
so let's do that
please place the order
now again we'll copy this part
all right so now we'll use do while loop
the purpose of using this do while group
is that we have to run a specific part
of the code every time and the other
part of the code we have to run based on
the choice
so now let's start with that
inside the do
block first of all we will
ask the user to enter the product code
and enter the product quantity
so first of all
right
product code
enter product code
will take the input in the array
now we'll ask the user
to enter
the quantity
all right now
will take the product quantity let us
see in
ARR Q
C
now
we will check that If the product code
entered by the user matches with the
product code that is being already
entered then we will display a message
saying that duplicate product code
please try again
so for that we have to use the for Loop
first of all and inside the for Loop
we'll initialize I with 0 I less than C
we have already initialized C with 0.
now I plus plus
so inside this
for Loop use if condition and check if
the product key or product code entered
by the user matches with the product
code that already exists in the file
then we will display a message saying
that duplicate product code so we'll
write
if
RAC of
C that is entered by the user equals
array of C
I
so I will keep on iterating as we have
used for Loop
so inside this if we will display a
message saying that
duplicate product code
please
try again
all right
now we'll write go to m again jump
statement as we have already discussed
now after this
we will increment C plus plus that is
If the product key is Not Duplicate then
C will increment that is the counter
will increment
all right now
we'll display a message saying that do
you want to buy another product or not
we'll write
all right so as we have displayed this
now we will take the input of the user
see in choice that whether he wants to
buy the product or not
so this is our do Loop now we'll have to
use after this do block we'll have to
use while loop as we're using the do
while loop now here is the condition
that if the user will press yes that is
why
then this Loop will execute
all right now
we'll make a design structure so we'll
write C out
and
slash and Slash and slash d slash T
slash t
and now we'll write receipt
right now after that
thank you
now we'll write product number
Sorry by mistake we write
capital N now we'll write product number
then now we'll write
product quantity
product name sorry
no
product quantity
then the price
now we'll use the for Loop to iterate
through the file so we'll write
4 and I equals 0 I less than c i plus
plus
so now inside this for Loop first of all
because we have to do the iteration we
will open the file data dot open
database
double quotes database Dot txt
and we'll open this file in reading mode
so iOS
in
all right so after that
we will kind of initialize this file
we'll write P code
P name
then price after that there was discount
all right now as we have done previously
while not
data dot eof that is end of file
and inside this while loop we will check
we are actually matching if the code
entered by the user that is a r r c i is
equal to the code present in the file
and if so then we will do the
calculations and add those file in the
customer basket
so let's do that P code equals array of
C of I
here we are checking
if so then
we'll do the amount amount equals to
price of the product into the quantity
of the product
all right after that we'll have to do
the discount part
so in this part we know that the
discount is calculated by multiplying
amount with discount divided by 100
and then we have to subtract it from the
amount
so let's do that amount minus
amount
into
discount
divided by 100.
all right now after that as we are done
now we'll have to add discount to the
total variable
because in this part the total amount
after getting discount is stored in this
disk variable now we'll add this
variable to the total variable
all right so as this is done now we will
print this part
so in this part we are just printing so
we'll
do the slash in and now then P code
then pname
then array of q05
array of Q
I
all right now after that price
then amount
and amount after discount or we'll write
discount only
because we have to write the variable
all right now we'll have to add the
slash keys in between them
so let's do that part
all right so we have added the slash T's
in between them for the formatting
purpose now to iterate the file for the
iterating purpose we'll do the same that
P code
pname
price
discount
all right now after this while loop
now we will have to close the data file
so we'll write data Dot close
so after this data.close we have to
print the total amount so let's do that
first of all we'll do some
designing part like let's say selection
selection
now
just for design purpose
I will simply print the total variable
we'll write first of all total amount
now the variable
total
all right so everything is done except
the main function now in the main
function
will write
so int main now inside this main
function as we know we have created the
class shopping class so we will create
the object of that shopping class and we
will call
the menu function with the help of that
object as we know that is the first
function that must be called so we'll
write shopping
and let's say the object of this is s
and s dot
menu function
so as we know the menu function is the
topmost function
so this menu will display when we run
the file
so now everything is done
and now let's run this file
let's press compile and run
I hope it works
there are some errors
all right so 335 okay
so this is the error and now
57 line
number 57
yeah we have to use double equal to
and one more error is there I think
now let's try to run this
there might be some more errors
as you can
alright after this 386
okay so we haven't labeled this one
we have to label m
now let's try to run this
so here we can see Supermarket main menu
first is administrator then second if
you're a buyer three to exit
so first we'll log in as an
administrator
so as you can see please log in
so now we'll enter the admins email
so we'll write
Robbie at the rate
email
.com
now the password
one two three
now this is the administrator menu as
you can see first is the add product if
you want to add the product second to
modify the product three to delete the
product and flow to back to main menu
so now I'll click on
like I want to add the product so I'll
write one I'll press one and enter add
new product so now I have to add product
code of the product
like let's say the product code of
product is one
name of product let's say juice
and price is 70.
and discount on product is
two percent record inserted
now again I want to add so I'll click on
one product code of product would be two
now name of product would be let's say
bread
price 30
discount again to
record inserted now again
product now would be let's say butter
three
inverter
price of product would be 60.
discount would be 4
now fourth product
sorry add product Now product could be
fourth
and this would be
let's say X
price would be 170.
discount three percent
record inserted so now we will check
that these records are inserted or not
so we can cross check it by
going here and open this database file
so as we can see one juice
product code one is Juice price is 70 2
is the discount then second is bread
third is butter four is egg so first
this is the product code this is the
price and this is the discount on that
product
now let's come back and modify the
product
let's say first product was juice
and we want to modify that product
so what we'll do is We'll add the
product code one and the new product
code would be one only let's say we
don't want to change that and name of
the product would be
chips we'll replace it with chips
price would be
20.
and discount would be 2 percent
so record edited as we can see here
record edited and now we can check
so now we'll open this database file so
as we can see
as you can see one Chips
two bread three butter four eggs so the
first product that was used is replaced
by chips
so this function is done now let's try
the delete function
we'll click on 3 for delete
and now we have to enter the product
code of the product which we want to
delete so let's say we want to delete
the fourth product
and we can see product deleted
successfully we can check that
as you can see
there are three products left the fourth
one got deleted
so now let's go back and let's check if
the customer wants to buy the product
how can he or she buy so let's first of
all we click on phone to go back to the
so now let's click onto as a buyer to
buy some products now we'll click on one
to buy the product
so as you can see our products are chips
bread and butter
so product numbers are one two three and
their price are 20 30 60 respectively
and now we'll enter the product code of
the product which we want to buy so I'll
click on one
and the quantity I say to
want to buy another product or not they
are asking if you want to buy another
product if yes then press Y and if no
then press n
so we'll click on why because we want to
buy another product so now I'll click on
2 that is bread
product quantity I'll add product
quantity as four breads
and now butter so for that first of all
why
for butter I will click on three
product code of batteries three now
quantity would be two
now I don't want to buy any other
products so I'll click on n
so as you can see
product numbers product name their
quantity price amount and amount with
discount
and the total is there that is 272
and if we wish to buy another product so
we can click on one else we can click on
two to go back
so this is our receipt our total amount
is there
so this is our complete project on
Supermarket billing in C plus plus you
can try it although the code is bit long
approx 400 to 450 lines of code
but it is worth trying
all right guys with that we have come to
the end of this session if you like this
video please give it a thumbs up I hope
it really help you all thanks for
watching stay safe and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here